on a un petit peu de redire et stéphane
hains on a un petit peu de retard on va
pas se mentir mais ça nous fait très
plaisir d'être avec vous et on va
pouvoir enfin commencer on a fait un
petit tacle un petit peu de technique là
j'ai une master class de stouffville
m'expliquer comment ose t toute la
solution et c'est vrai qu'on était qu'on
ait été un petit peu juste il ya eu des
petits soucis techniques pour juste de
toute façon vous ceux qui connaissent un
petit peu la bête technique que je suis
ce qui a eu des petits des petits soucis
panne d'électricité toute l'argentine
est coupée en terme d'électricité
apparemment ccsa ses fans a à peu près
ça en gros un vous pour faire un petit
résumé rapide ben je devais stream donc
je devais poste depuis depuis la part
d'un pote à moi
malheureusement le gobie demain m'a
touché donc je ne peux pas aller
vraiment pattes du coup j'avais une
solution pour stream quand même depuis
chez moi en contrôlant leur départ de
mon pote etc mais mon pote m'a tassé
réveillées sans électricité et du coup
là je trouve une autre solution bref là
kevin yost donc je veux tout expliqué je
veux tout installé on a tout fait
ensemble il s'en est bien sorti et du
coup maintenant je pense qu'on est parti
pour une peau même deux bonnes semaines
de commentaires sur le tata steel oui
parce que tout ça on l'a appris à 13h10
sein du coup mettre tout en place en
cinquante minutes c'est un beau défi
mais mais du coup ça a l'air d'être
d'être plutôt pas mal ouais donc l'as
lens et donc du coup est ce que tu peux
nous présenter un petit peu les joueurs
du tournoi kevin ouais alors j'ai pas
tout le monde avec avec moi évidemment
mais on a le numéro un mondial vous
voyez il est il est à l'oeuvre là la
directement donc
il joue il jouait cipango donc on a
plusieurs plusieurs joueurs on a aussi
évidemment caruana caruana on n'a qu'un
yakine donc arias keane qui est connu
pour être peut-être le plus grand
théoricien du tournoi je sais qu'il
n'était pas forcément tendre avec magnus
carlsen au niveau de ses préparations
théorique ce que j'ai du mal un peu à
comprendre parce que pour moi carlson
même en théorie il reste vraiment
impressionnant parce qu'il fait pour moi
beaucoup de bons choix d'ailleurs il est
numéro un mondial c'est pas pour rien et
c'est vrai que c'est incroyable que
coquard yakine puisse se permettre de
dire ça mais s'il le dit je pense qu'il
a il a un grand respect pour pour 40
cents c'est que lui ce sont hyper fort
sur le sujet théorique il a travaillé
comme un comme un malade quoi tout
simplement souffre donc voilà je sais
que et du coup bon ça on va dire que
j'ai présenté les favoris à auxquels
s'ajoutent bâton petit poulain duda qui
est à nouveau là sauf pour qu'on rigole
un petit peu tous les deux fallait qu'il
soit présent quoi vous savez ce qu'est
le poulain de stouff aux championnats du
monde de rapides qu'on avait eu la
chance de commenter sur surface com fr
donc je remets une couche a comme
d'habitude et je charrie compost ouf par
rapport à cela puisque son poulain est
fini tout juste derrière derrière le
mien et du bien et
peu
oui il
il a gagné c'est assez simple comme ça
il s'est dit je n'ai pas volé stouff à
chaque fois il en avait marre je crois
je crois que c'est plus c'est plutôt ça
par contre ça dans un pour ce tournoi je
tu vas changer des novateurs
suivre le
qui
a joué le top 12 pour dégeler et
et franchement mais clairement
tout a brûlé très sympa en plus oui on
on peut citer qu il ya une particularité
c'est qu'il vient du même club de la
même région que
niall nihal sarine à la base
et ils sont retrouvés à être champion du
monde et vice-champion du monde des
moins de 12 ans moi je sais que je vais
ni à la sarine son copain quand il avait
11 ans et j'avais dû perdre pour la
première fois alors que j'étais déjà m
contre un petit gamin de 11 ans ça fait
mal à l'égo et bat façon on sait que
prague d'ananda et niall sarine
représente l'avenir indien en fait des
échecs mondiaux sur le plan sur la scène
internationale donc c'est vraiment un
des joueurs à suivre je crois que j'ai
pas citer mamediarov m'avait dit rov
j'adore ce joueur et en plus il est de
la magie cannes et 4,85 du coup il ya
beaucoup de très fort joueur de 85 et du
coup c'est la génération dorée et du
coup je vais le suivre tout
particulièrement je dis ça vous l'aurez
compris hein je suis né aussi en 85
souffle voilà toute l'histoire voilà la
chute voilà la chute voilà après on a
des joueurs plus confidentielles alors
attention c'est c'est pas des tops 10
mondiaux on hache en club jean-claude il
a été champion des états unis il est en
travaillant sur deux ans il est passé à
peu près de 2600 de 1650 à plus de 2700
a gagné le championnat des états unis à
travailler avec aa garde qui est un des
grands maîtres les plus connus qui fait
des supers livre de très haut niveau et
il a énormément progressé maintenant ils
commencent à arriver sur sur la scène
sur la scène internationale dans l'est
dans l'effort tournoi ou très fort
tournoi même bon nils grandi à deuce
le numéro un suédois depuis un moment
maintenant richard rapporte qu'on avait
commenté au speech est ce le hongrois
qui est connu pour son style hyper
fantasque il nous plaît beaucoup avec
stouff aussi puisqu'il est plus de 27 50
et il a un style incroyable
ouais on l'avait vu me contre le match
contre rennes et ça avait été énorme ce
matin j'ai beaucoup aimé la les perles
en parts ou deux parties sont
prometteuses et là c'est vraiment très
intéressant à voir la partie elle en a
pas on se fait presque tenir tout
médecin et deux joueurs jouent par gagne
tout le temps et en tous cas yab jeanne
très sain à niveau était
aussi plein de husky préparateur de
quartier
qui accompagne par exemple et je pense
qu'en pense pas et brut partie très
intéressante à voir un peu autour d'eux
des partis
et du coup et juste pour finir j'ai
passé juste deux joueurs souffrent on a
du beauf qui a défrayé la chronique
aussi en russie par rapport au match de
championnat du monde où il accompagnait
la team car la scène alors que comme
cela a été proposé à nepomniachi donc vu
qu'ils sont du même pays tous les deux
russes ça n'a pas trop plu cette
histoire touche et et d'autre part je
n'ai pas cité le mal-aimé anish giri qui
a souvent des sorties assez durs ou
assez maladroite vis-à-vis de ses
collègues de très haut niveau et du coup
il paraît pas très apprécié du grand
public et de ses collègues
maintenant c'est un des joueurs est
évidemment dangereux puisqu'il est il
est quand même proche des 2800 lots donc
ça reste quand même un des favoris du
tournoi voilà voilà ce que veut dire
toujours
je suis d'accord est contré dans un
petit trou et des savoirs de ce qui se
passe si si un petit tour des stades un
petit tour des échiquiers
c'est clair ça serait ça serait pas mal
du coup on va on va arriver là dessus
donc là on a une
smith la ventre et si penco et magnus
carlsen magnus carlsen a les pièces
noires donc smith lave très bon choix de
tanus moi j'adore cette ouverture se
trouvent parce qu'on peut jouer des
parties assez funky sur des cats avec
les noirs sauf que là c'est pas très
sympa ce qui vient de se passer c'est
comment dirais-je et si penco qui a joué
le système on va dire anti mayrand avec
dams et 2b 3 si tu veux c'est un système
un peu casse pieds et d'ailleurs ma
venue ça tranquillement jouer b6 ou
bessette allez mon prono déjà je vais te
dire comme ça se trouve c'est ça va déjà
faire un beau match nul cette partie je
pense qu'ici point qu il joue magnus il
va pas prendre de risque avec avec les
blancs et il va tranquillement annuler
cette cette partie voilà comment je vois
les choses je peux me tromper
yes alors on voit que l'année dernière
quand même
et si benneteau a battu car c'est dans
le même ton nom donc
donc je fais pas peur enfin tu me fait
pas peur du tout fait avec ce que tu me
dis là je pense que je pense qu'arsène
aura
dans ce cas ça n'aurait à coeur
d'essayer de se refaire cet ancien ouais
c'est possible après pour l'instant les
blancs ils prennent pas de risques ils
n'ont pas joué les lignes les plus les
plus tranchantes et voilà on va voir ce
que si et si bien qu il a un petit
quelque chose parce que là avec les
blancs un joueur de haut niveau comme si
penco bah forcément il va peut-être
tenté un petit quelque chose il ya
peut-être une petite idée et
si manu sa rivale bloqués après ça de ça
fait partie des positions où après des
coups comme katia souvent pas mal de
pièces qui peuvent s'échanger il va bien
sûr préparé cela avec peut-être des
tourrades est un des choses comme ça
mais le coût de 4 à seyches le plus
souvent la position de pièces on verra
comment ça va se passer mais en tout cas
c'est un petit plus blanc et on verra et
on verra comment ça se passe mais c'est
pas la vendre la plus ambitieuse et on
sait qu'arles scène très fort on sait
que personne ne perd pas beaucoup donc
ça paraît pas très tranchant pour aller
le battre voilà voilà comment je vois
les choses stéphane y est ok allez tour
des stades stouff qu'est ce que tu veux
qu'est ce que tu veux choisir comme
comme stade comme stade comme échiquier
à comme au foot ici
et bien du coup comme quand j'ai pas
entendu ta réponse stéphane on voit
qu'il ya peut-être eu un petit un petit
crash de chez toi connexion capricieuse
pour souffre et ben je vais aller voir
caruana car jaeckin et maintenant je
vais je vais essayer de trouver la cam
qui va bien on voit se roder avec ça et
hop tac caruana car yakine tac tac tac
est en fait je te demandais tout ce que
tu voulais aller voir et du coup je me
suis dit tiens je vais aller voir
caruana écart yakine puisque j'avais pas
eu le droit à sa réponse et est du coup
le temps de trouver les calmes on les a
à l'écran ça y était arrivé voilà
tranquille
donc du coup on est parti là encore on
est sur un gambit dame refusait
variante des changes on peut montrer un
petit peu comment ça s'est passé pour
pour tout le monde du coup des quatre
cavaliers f 6 et 4 assists donc on a
l'impression avec un début comme ça que
les noirs ont soit tenté une bo go ou
une nimzat indienne donc la bourgogne
viennent c'est sûr qu'à valiev 3faire
fou bekkat échec et l'animent the
indienne ces cavaliers c3 est fou b4 le
clouage qui vise à contrôler en direct
du centre en tout cas on veut empêcher
la poule 4 à noter ici juste pour faire
le tchèque des ouvertures sur cavaliers
f3 il y avait si c'est ça c'est l'ouest
indienne avec l'idée de mettre de fou
sur la diagonale qui est qui est libre
en fait tout simplement bon ça c'est la
petite explication théorique il joue
cavalier f3 là il y avait pas mal de
choix il y avait b6 il y avait foule des
catéchètes convient de citer et il ya
encore un autre coup vous voyez la
théorie c'est très riche encore rien à
plusieurs on peut jouer même ses cinq
pour essayer d'aller dans les dents les
comment dirais-je structure de benoni c5
d51 structure de benoni mais là haut up
des 5 donc c'est encore une ouverture
différentes vous voyez qu'avec un les
deux mêmes premier coup on peut aller
bifurqué dans d'autres ouvertures on
peut transposer comment on dit vers
d'autres ouvertures et là on arrive dans
un gambit dame classique ou le coup
cavaliers f3 a déjà été jouée ce qui
intéresse quand même pas mal les noirs
s'il ya quelques bonnes variante à base
de cavaliers eux deux qui sont qui sont
joués pas tout de suite évidemment après
le développement mais du coup quand on a
les infos du cavalier en f3 ça engage
plus
sans doute car yakine à jouer le gambit
dame donc c'est chose faite et il ya
bien eu un gambit dam des changes avec
s'éprend d'un e prend des deux fabiano
caruana cavaliers c3 c6 dans ses
positions le coup le plus classique
c'est fou j'ai cinq et il a choisi
d'aller vers l'autre version classique
de jouer au f4 se trouve donc déjà voilà
c'est pas une grosse surprise mais on
est dans dans des débuts assez assez
simple assez robuste 1 on voit que sur
une première ronde dans les deux parties
qu'on va le voir il n'y a pas beaucoup
de prise de risques on va pas on va
croire pour l'instant être dans des
débuts excentré cas-là mvl où il y aura
beaucoup de calculs là c'est très très
stratégique déjà
en restant ce de l'impression que les
joueurs ont envie de rentrer dans leur
tournoi tranquille devant un peu ce qui
se passe et
voilà donc je pense que je pense que il
tâte un peu le terrain tout ça après ben
caruana bon c'est le numéro deux mondial
il a un petit peu baissé maintenant mais
bon c c'est un genre à 2800 depuis des
années je pense que cardiaque in car
akin je pense c'est peut-être le joueur
le plus solide 1 2 qui existe en ce
moment sur la terre
car à khimki et qui perd rarement aux
échecs qu'il a eu même si le match
contre 40 cents il avait été incroyable
et puis comme il est très fort en
théorie stouff baffe c'est dur de le
panneau à la voilà donc tu les feras en
théorie libérale solide donc juste car
là je pense qu'il veut jouer aux échecs
sa terre ses pièces normalement et
peut-être éviter un peu les débats
théoriques je te vois un peu comme ça
moi je pense car en a il est nettement
plus fort mais il veut je pense éviter
les débats théoriques claouey pas tout à
fait ça paraît pas hyper ambitieuse
qu'il a joué avec les blancs d'ailleurs
mai force est de constater que ça à fait
réfléchie car yakine parce qu'il s'est
fait croquer un petit peu autant une
vingtaine de minutes voilà donc avec un
début assez logique s'il voulait le
fouet sortir en f4 et pour accélérer son
développement car yakine il a sorti son
fou en d6 donc c'est très bien
d'accélérer son développement seulement
sont bons fous le fou qu'il faut et
circuler par rapport à sa chaîne de
pions donc le foot cases noires il n'est
plus là tandis que caruana s'est
débarrassé de son fou c'est un qui
aurait pu être bloqué par le pion de
trois qui auraient pu être bloqué par sa
chaîne de pions voilà du coup ben
logique imbéciles va essayer de
valoriser ce fou c'est 8
et pouvoir peut-être pousser ses cinq un
jour tour c'est un donc on se met par
rapport aux faiblesses on se met en
place et finalement il a joué g6
peut-être avec des fouets f5 directement
caruana empêchait cfo détroit c'est la
bonne can pour le full est très jolie
voilà il fait pas mal mais il est joli
bon on peut directement aller voir
d'autres d'autres joueurs parce que il
s'est pas passé grand chose pour
l'instant non jusqu'au répond aux
widgets
alors battre mais elle me demande si il
viserait la nulle du coup
caruana ben non je pense car là il a les
blancs ils valent c'est de gagner contre
n'importe qui m'amène compte 47 mais
juste la stratégie c'est de pas jouer
hyper théorique est pas tout à lancer
parce que baccarat qui nous avait très
bien préparé mais mais juste avoir une
position jouable une bonne position de
laquelle il peut exprimer et c'est de
prendre l'aventage tranquillement
complet longueur complet
un petit plus blanc c'est comme la
partie des six points qu avant
on voit que ben les joueurs avec les
blancs ils ne peuvent pas trop se
permettre de perdre un trophée du coup
maintenant voit de plus en plus
d'ouverture style catalan c'est à dire
petit plus blanc à faire fructifier à
pousser mais on espère surtout pas et
peut-être qu'on aura une chance de
pousser pour la wind voilà comment ça se
passe dans les parties de très haut
niveau en règle générale et il ya des
joueurs qui sont moins comme cela
qui sont un peu plus fantasques on a
cité richard rapporte jo baba qui est
plus sûr le tout premier premier plan
mondial en partie lente mais qui était
dans ce style là et on a des filles
rouges amv l on est bien représenté au
niveau français dans des styles un peu
plus fantasques ou plus flamboyant on
peut dire ça ils prennent plus de
risques des fois ça se passe mal mais
dans l'ensemble firoud déjà élevées
elles sont des grosses grosses pointures
et d'ailleurs on regrette qu'ils soient
pas là quand même on peut le dire
d'ailleurs on a d'ailleurs on a aussi un
joueur français inquiets jour qui joue
l'open fall open
le petit tournoi le petit tournoi est ce
le plein de le pen bé le pen bé oui mais
il ya marc andrieu rizzi ben là le plus
gros espoirs français actuellement
puisqu'il est tout jeunes grands maîtres
à 14 ans il a battu le record de
précocité
des autres stars françaises etienne ban
on peut citer
du coup
oui donc pour lui c'est hyper
intéressant parce que le tournoi b il ya
beaucoup il ya une moyenne ne s'est pas
de 1550 j'irai à peu près sous j'ai vu
la liste mais j'ai pas fait la moyenne
est logé pas regarder mais en tout cas
céder très fort joueur il ya erwin l'ami
des vieux routards à 2006 des jeunes
stars franchement c'est un tournoi y
perdure ce tournoi mail
j'aimerais parfois béthunois
moi j'aimerais bien mais je sais que ça
serait pour se faire épiler entièrement
le dos mais moi ça me vient d'aller au
combat se trouvent dans des tournois
très très fort et tant pis si ça se
fasse mal mais c'est vrai que là les 24
50 qui sont présents dans le tournoi
c'est des jeunes pépites c'est pas pour
des vieux de la vieille qui ont dépassé
35 verges et qui ont justement tout
juste 24 ans lassé pour dc pour les
vrais espoirs et du coup c'est super
qu'ils aient enfin que marc andrié
obtenus sont son avis de la chanterelle
alors comme ça ça montre déjà une
certaine reconnaissance
donc c'est très positif est maintenant
fort qui confirme parce que plus qu'on
le confirmera vite dans ce genre de
tournoi plus ça peut être un nouvel élan
pour pour sa carrière parce que
maintenant grand maître c'est très bien
mais il ya plus de titres avaient
cherché on sait que bonté de 1500 et
2500 alors dans la tête maintenant très
vite que la prochaine étape on peut dire
qu'une barre symbolique ses 2600 hélas
et c'est une autre forme de grand maître
pour moi à 2600 on rentre dans les
grands maîtres d'élite voilà j'ai déjà a
tenu ce discours de 1700 c'est encore
autre chose mais lui doit se fixer ces
gars plat et déjà step by step bas ce
tournoi comme tu le dises to fly il faut
c'est un gros challenge et il faut
confirmer ouais donc ça va être
incertain ça va être intéressant on
continue un petit peu le tour des stades
yes qui tu veux aller voir alors au menu
giry premier mandat du beauf mamediarov
duda rapporte vide shankland vent de
forrest grande hélios qu'est ce que tu
nous choisit tout tu connais mon tu
connais mon poulain donc donc alors tu
veux prévenant daoudou da parce que j'ai
un petit doute du coup quand je faisais
plus la gt2 mais on était donc ton
poulain certains mandats ou d'agde par
vincent alors lui tu peut le virer
c'est vrai j'avais oublié j'avais oublié
que oubliettes donc non mais tu dois me
vendus par des jeux terminés je sais pas
qui je vais choisir parce que tu as
chaud en fin au quai il a choisi prague
le mandat qui a un jeune espoir
évidemment il est très fort mais c'est
encore la grosse cote que tu as choisi
ce que tout film dit j'ai l'habitude de
perdre beaucoup de paris bailly bon mais
les plus petits lots du tournoi il va
falloir que je choisisse correctement je
vais être obligé de faire quelque chose
d'assez fantasque quoi mais je vois pas
tout à fait déjà la crosse de hockey lah
jeu pour perdre si tu veux je vois c'est
gentil de ta part donc on va aller voir
prague 90 da contre le mal aimé
contre le mal aimé voilà je pense pas
qu'il sent mal aimé à chaque fois que je
discute avec elle car les gens là mais
c'est trop mal en fait il est il et rool
à 1000% et
je pense que je pense pas que ça va
aller mais je pense qu'ils s'entendent
bien avec 47,7 à mettre tout le monde en
france
ouais mais du grand public je dirais
c'est encore plus et parce que en fait
les gens comprennent pas qu'en fait ils
manquent de tout le monde mais parce
qu'il est il est comme ça quoi il est à
cannes oui mais c'est pas quelqu'un de
méchant et ils peuvent parler d'elle
mais ouais jeu mais j'ai pas ouais j'ai
pas l'impression que ça soit pas il
faudrait vérifier moi je connais pas
assez bien les joueurs de tout premier
plan pour te dire qu'elle est mais
souvent ce que ce que je vois c'est que
ouais au niveau du grand public en tout
cas c'est certain dès que j scout avec
avec des amis joueurs d'échecs et il
fait pas grande impression avec avec ses
petites blagounettes lorsque son franc
parler discuter je pense que tu joues
pas trop avec le premier bar d'aix il il
est il est complètement fan de de guérir
le farming c'est une référence toi tu me
cites a encore un extraterrestre de la
planète échec française
at qui viennent dans le chat nous en
parler alors tous et que barbie c'est la
grande référence à mes yeux c'est
à quel niveau à quel niveau à quel
niveau offre par exemple un niveau et on
boit on va pas rentrer dans le souci d
pas là
du coup donc c'est la partie de gai
comme un gamin je crois que c'est une
anglaise a un petit peu la structure
montrer ça tu as tout à fait raison
souffre voilà
c'est que j'ai trois qu il était six ou
way le système c6 bongrand grands
classiques de ce genre de position
l'objectif vous le voyez c'est évident
c'est de faire des cinq
îlots un petit peu la cité avec les
blancs vous voyez que là s'il sort de la
finance est exactement exactement
et du coup il ya exactement le même
schéma c'est à dire que comme les noirs
vis des 5 et 2 5 comme tu lui dis prie
du centre total le centre parfait à ce
moment je dise à son dessein que cinq
salles sont parfaits et bains et une
réaction classique 1 va peut être de
jouer assez rapidement des quatre pour
obtenir après on prend des daims prend d
un pion 17 faible puisque quoiqu'il
fasse option sera soit à rire et soit
isolé en cas de descente on échange tout
est le pion devient isolées et en plus
on peut faire particulièrement des
quatre danseurs de position parce que
cavalli viendra pas gêner date d'annoncé
6 il ya aussi une autre manière de
fonctionner ce qu'il a joué cavalier f3
je tape le pion au sac si je fais des
six je fais plus des 5 donc ça
m'intéresse pas f si c'est pas un coup
c'est moche ça bloque la case naturel du
cavalier ça défonce monrocq futur
dame ce stade je regarde poche 60
dessins qui sera difficile à faire après
calais c3 bon bref
du coup les noirs qu'est ce qu'ils font
dans ses positions eux quatre ils
gagnent au tempo sur le cavalier mais
les blancs ont délié le centre parfait
et faire avancer le centre noir c'est
pas toujours négatif parce que même si
sam asphyxie un petit peu je pourrai
plus facilement le cas c est après
cavaliers des cadres rouges et de
détroit bah je pourrais me refaire sur
ce centre là voilà donc validé cats a
été jouée des cinq puis on prend et sur
pions prend bas on aurait fait ce que
j'ai dit un fou j'ai deux des trois
c'est la raison pour laquelle toujours
dans ses idées de coopi quand dame prend
des cinq a été joué par le jeune price
nalanda et je t'avouerai que je trouve
que je connais plus la position l'aprec
avaler ces deux puisque je joue pas
cette preuve que les noirs moi je savais
qu'une horde non mais voilà on est bien
tombée c'est c'est pour ça en fait ils
sont par les généraux c'est là que se
trouvent
les préparer pour le tournoi je le
prépare ce qu'on en retient la gare est
en fait et
tu me l'as gérer la technique du coup
évidemment d'éviter évidemment c'est
l'idée gravel donc du coup donc la
cavale et c'est donc là les blancs
veulent faire cavaler c3 donc ici
généralement joue cavalier m6 et donc
avalé f6 g2 et donc il ya plein d'idées
par exemple
sur cassé trois ici à entendre ce qui
est intéressant sur ce qui est
intéressant à la paire de dames 5 jeux
des médecins que c'est un coût mais un
autre personnage 5 en fait
ce qu'on aime du coup à la rapporte on
voit déjà les petits gris qui veulent
mature qui veut mettre sur le roi
en fait ça c'est risqué parce que
parce qu'avec l'idée c'est que sur su
refuser de manger fouarge trois directs
étrangers les voilà et donc du coup il
faut je crois vraiment h30 match 5 après
tout du goût des sites etc et puis la
position allait elle est lé père normal
[Musique]
qu'ils vont occuper en attendant le 5
mai c'est plutôt intéressant vous voyez
l'idée 2 tout vert classique en tout cas
pour les joueurs un peu plus débutants
c'est d'enlever le fou g2 qui est le
protecteur du petit rock il le fait
sauter du coup ça fera un trou pour
toute la partie dans le rock adverse et
du coup on essaiera d'infiltrer nos
pièces voilà ce que ce que le tout en
plus là vous voyez que les noirs dans
une position ils ont à lantages des spas
5e pions en quatre les pièces en cavale
en c2 c3 ne sont pas très actif l'idée
c'est que si je fais d'un match cinq
fois je crois que je peux rapidement
changer les fous de cases blanches ben
le roi blanc anges en danger un va être
un petit peu faible le pion aux quatre
gardes la case f3 importance est réservé
trois parce que c'est la casse de
cavaliers normalement un qui est là pour
défendre le roi donc en fait le roi
blanc et de là un petit peu affaibli
voilà le récital voilà donc c'est
intéressant comme idée en tout cas il ya
eu 25
25 foulée deux cavaliers a systematic
ici donc ça me semble intéressant vous
voyez c'est quand même que la dame reste
au contact des pics atteints voilà c'est
sans doute une ligne plus solide on voit
tout le monde a décidé d'être solide on
n'aura pas la ligne de ce tout fait avec
des machins qui a et richard rapporte
s'il avait joué cette position on aurait
eu droit sans doute à damas shaink plus
rigolo
négocié bleus après faut voir le niveau
de coopération il est sûrement supérieur
à celui de touche mais
prévost on va peut-être aller bien des
idées un
nom en tout cas avant les deux buts des
deux coups sont intéressants oui mais
voilà si c'était mal tout ce qu'on peut
dire en tout cas effectivement souvent
insiste sur l'importance de la
préparation on a vu le championnat du
monde car ce n est pas match il ya des
grosses préparations donc les joueurs
connaissent vraisemblablement là
position jusqu'à c'est loin là ils sont
arrêtés on voit prague nalanda avec 1h20
il a dû réfléchir à des choses pour
approfondir la position et sait pas
jouer trop vite mais on peut estimer qui
connaît la position peut-être tout à
fait possible cavalia rigolo
généralement le fruit doit plutôt
investi dans ses positions parce qu'en
fait il ya des plans alors j'explique un
petit peu il ya pas mal de plans et
photos avec h 5 h 4 pour le noir et donc
ça peut paraître bizarre 2h 5h 4 parce
que
parce que bâle iii et souvent derrière
en fait mais l'idée le faisait quand
même à lantages des espaces le blog du
mal à réagir au centre vous savez on dit
un faiblissement à l'ale avec option
d'achat par exemple réaction au centre
avec des 4 et la lampe ou un petit peu
de mal à un réagir au centre et du coup
h 5 h quatre super intéressant en tout
cas h55 ou hyper intéressant aussi pour
empêcher les idées avec h3 trouvent être
des fois les blancs peuvent aussi
vraiment ch tranche de 4 ya des prix est
aussi vite et aussi comme ça des fois et
est en tout cas à 104 c'est un plan que
que j'aime bien avec les doigts et c'est
pour ça que des fois le fou noir est
plutôt indécise pour après met la
pression sur les gaz - sommes plongés 3
donc je crois que toi ça fait un peu
comme une taupe jeune tu vois un an die
il est encore jeune un toit je lui ai
fait la patte à leur bon bah il se
trompe on devait me koua succédé
ici je ne sais pas quelles raisons
logiquement j'aurais joué detroit alors
j'imagine que c'est quoi le problème de
détroit s'est prise d'un bâtiment
généralement
en fait tu joues l'avantagent
développement c'est un peu comme dans le
30 dans la
labine 1 c'est une voix toujours jeu
pour leur talent au développement donc
oui je pense petit rock forest f5
bêtement je livre les mes impressions de
manière classique surtout que tu me
parles de ton attaque avec h144 comme tu
l'as dit à la carène réaction au centre
et je peux peut-être déjà anticipé avec
des trop d'écart et c'est assez marrant
losc ou de dany j'irai c'est assez joli
quand même ce qu'il a fait là il devait
connaître aussi cette belle idée parce
que moi j'étais un peu sommaire avec mon
idée des trois tout c'est vraiment
l'idée de base 1 il n'y a pas beaucoup
de recherches c'est plus un mimétisme de
ce que j'ai vu ailleurs et annie agréé
il a joué cavalier 1 au début je me suis
dit mais c'est c'est quoi son idée là où
ça parce que c'est vraiment sympa est la
même pour alors c'est sympa pour tous
les types de joueurs pour les joueurs
amateurs pour les joueurs débutants et
pour les joueurs de de bon niveau
puisque là l'idée de cavaliers c'est
absolument incroyable
ils avaient ils avaient prévu un petit
f3 derrière c'est quand même hyper sympa
vraiment parlant pour obtenir une ou
même à une magnifique majorité centrale
waouh je vois ce qu'il a fait de
cavaliers la ville a fait le cavalier
qui fait cavaler f 3 des 4 c 2e 1 pour
revenir à f3 c'est magnifique tacle
regarde l europe voilà
tour de l'échiquier de 3,9 axa pour les
joueurs débutants c'est pas
nécessairement à reproduire
normalement dit qu'on doit pas jouer
plusieurs fois la même pièce dans
l'ouverture avant que toutes les pièces
mineurs soient sortis ça c'est le
conseil de gaz maintenant des joueurs
comme anish giri et tous les joueurs
présents au tata steel a et b d'ailleurs
bas ce sont des joueurs qui ont appris
toutes les règles générales tous jeunes
et au fur et à mesure de leur montée en
compétences aux échecs ils ont appris à
désapprendre les règles de base au bon
moment alors pas forcément à reproduire
à la maison ce qui est fait là parce que
sinon vous aurez peut-être des problèmes
les singles aux cavaliers et c'est
génial là par contre parce qu'on va
tenir la pole à la position avec la
majorité centrale le concept est super
jolie parce que visuellement c'est un
peu dégueu cavaliers 1 est en fait à
glee des f3 derrière là on a le droit
super sympa
alors pour répondre à un float d'or qui
me demandait si des d4
enfin pour graver des trois ehpad des
quatre à la page des canadiens pareils
mais en fait ça revient au même mais je
pense que des trois forces plus les
choses parce qu'avec des trois classes
comme de manger 1 4 alors que sur des
quatre peut-être que je peux ignorer
fatah f5 je sais pas du tout si c'est
possible ou pas mais dans l'idée
répondre moi des trois des quatre
c'était à peu près du même acabit un
donc
voilà ce qu'on va manger en passant de
toute façon sous des 4 1 ce qu'est le
coup normalement mais ce qu'on peut dire
stop par rapport aux autres partis c'est
peut-être celle là qui est la plus
rigolote parce que les les les
structures sont pas du tout les mêmes on
les pièces sont ni bizarrement on a
assisté d'ailleurs à un cavalier avec
l'idée de f3 on voit que c'est une
partie beaucoup plus créa quand même à
terme cavani prendre j'adore l'idée joué
par anish giri je trouve calais où les
annales il la connaissait peut-être à
l'avance quoique il en manque de temps
qui avait pas ça mais il a pris un petit
quart d'heure de moins autant si ce
n'est que c'est vraiment assez sympa ce
qu'on va tout j'avais une question avant
de l'oublier on n'a pas expliqué à ceux
qui nous regardent comment ça allait se
passer aujourd'hui au niveau des pubs
à et ben écoute je compte en envoyant un
mail au chef pendant la pause
mais
donc du coup je ne sais pas je pense
qu'on va faire comme la dans la foi à
peu près une fois par an d'accord mais
je
veux faire ça la première fois et comme
on était en live à 30 de la dent mais
dans une pose comme ça
une pub de six minutes par heure si j'ai
bien six minutes toutes les 60 minutes
c'est ça stouff la règle
de la est là il faut voir
en fait on m'apprend n'a pas dit mais je
sais que normalement c'est à peu près ça
on va commencer comme ça et puis je vais
envoyer un mail
je leur ai envoyé un mail
[Musique]
pendant la pluie mais on ne serat de
voir un psy qui se passe alors nous
annoncer que le prix du boeuf était
assez rigolote
et on finissait sur des quatre carrés bd
5 ok on est on est dans cette position
en tout cas moi j'aime bien les blancs
pour le côté majorité centrale
j'aimerais bien à terme je sais pas
faire dame c24 quelque chose comme ça et
et
montrer à tout le monde que je les
centres on va voir ce qui va se passer
par la suite ça paraît assez assez
logique maintenant est en pleine
réflexion cool
tu vois bon en finlande a été très fort
tu es là il à 26,12 mais c'est vrai que
n'a pas énormément joué en partie lente
depuis la reprise des déchets capelle
coville dont 50 évident mais il n'a pas
énormément rejoint parties lentes par
contre il ya beaucoup de tournois
parties rapides et blitz un fait et pas
internet et
il a montré dans beaucoup de tournon qui
les acquis qui peut battre deux joueurs
à 2700 euros même plus et donc là son
lots à 26,12 je pense qu'il est
légèrement sous-évalué
enfin c'est mon avis c'est mon poulain
donc du coup je le sais ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce que je veux dire c'est
que c'est c'est
dans le tournoi c'est le joueur qui font
un peu pointe et qu'il faut essayer
battre parce que c'est le plus faible
enfin en termes dé l'eau tout ça se vend
le plus faible donc guy hallet blanc
contre lui parisot gagné donc qui va
tenter en tout cas de gagner et c'est
peut-être là que du coup prague - loi
peut-être contre-attaqué
enfin c'est de regarder pendant qu vide
le joueur le plus sous évalué
et tu t'es dit je vais miser dessus
punaise toof là vraiment il ya beaucoup
de préparation dans dans ta volonté de
lâcher du sob du coup alors on va aller
donc c'est pas de métal je crois qu'il
parlait de la position entre du boeuf et
mamediarov on pouvait imaginer assez
facilement que c'était une structure
catalan ce que je reconnais le fou en g2
on sait que c'est un début des cats et
cas puisque le pion ca volet puisque les
noirs on ont un beau on va regarder un
petit peu ça et ça commence donc par une
slave au départ cave aux lièvres trois
cavaliers f6 cavaliers c3 c'est marrant
parce que c'est encore une smith
l'avancement c'est l'ouverture que
j'enseigne le plus parce que je la
trouve bien et
compliquée oui mais il n'y a pas non
plus une jungle astronomiques comme dans
l'east indienne la grenade et je trouve
que c'est un bon compromis j'adore le
grand vide à m'accepter aussi dans le
même style mais j'aime bien cette semi
slave très dangereuse et le système g3
g3 c'est assez rare normalement contre
la semi donc c'est la préparation de du
boeuf la problématique non normalement
on dit que c'est une variante qui est
pas tip top parce que les noirs vont
pouvoir prendre en c4 et le fou j'ai
deux il va taper sur du dur bon et
j'imagine que du golfe il avait des
idées derrière mais en tout cas c'est
pas la vendre la plus recommandée voilà
voilà ce qu'on peut dire donc des
princes et qu'at-il s'attendait à ce
coup là c'est le coup classique et après
fou g2b 5 ben on va tenir le pion c4 et
le fou qui est d'habitude en f1 ne t'a
pas du tout sûre le champion c4 on va
jouer plutôt sur la grande diago donc
cavalier singles logic instrument
jusqu'ici s'est pas passé grand-chose à
6 bon là à 6
bon c'est assez logique de protéger le
pion v5 ya le pion c6 qui va vous
inquiétez je pense pour la plupart sur
cavaliers français 6 on va bouger la
dame et faire et faire flamber set dans
la foulée donc y aura pas de grosse
problématique pour le moment
par rapport à ça et vous prend encore
moins va pas donner notre fou j'ai deux
magnifiques et en fait dans cette début
là on veut dans ma catalan et tous les
débuts du fou j'ai de presser sur la
halle d'amag le fou donc finalement si
je prends le pion c6 qui est totalement
jouable
la problématique c'est que mon
adversaire va pouvoir très vite remettre
le fond en baisse est et du coup j'ai
plus trop l'avantagent de rechercher
dans l'ouverture quoi se trouvent
les pièces vont ainsi changer d'abord un
lecavalier des flux exactement donc il a
continué par petit rock pour garder le
pressing fou bessette et là on le voit
beaucoup au niveau le b3 et qui peut en
fait ils payants s'éprend b avec dame
prend b ou après mais c'est à dire que
là dans cette position on accepte de
donner un deuxième pion et du coup on va
en récupérer un et on aura l'initiative
avec un meilleur jeu de pièces c'est
finalement un grand bi allez on va
l'appeler le grand me catalan si vous
voulez contre la suisse lave pourquoi
pas à quoi ça pourrait ça pourrait
exister cette histoire et il ya une
opportunité dans cette position mais en
jouant sa du beauf y penser quand même
avoir l' avantage c'est de prendre b4
dans la tronche cavaliers à 4 mais on
cavaliers une case de rebond donc n'est
pas au bord est mort mais on se pensait
3 et c'est quand même un gros pont plus
en c3 compensées ou non par un forget de
pièces pour les blancs voilà ce que je
dirais stéphane en est pas de
trop d'autres commentaires en position
de gambie pour moi et pas deux
il n'y a rien à signaler à lyon il ya
aussi à trois petits prix après qui a
été joué wey kaw de ces quatre d'abord à
5 à 3 comme tu le dis
et c'est pour la c1 c'est la structure
nord
est
et au final ok c'est intéressant parce
que le pion en d4 1 6 3 ils vont ils
vont rester là pour l'instant donc ce
cas une force des noirs est sur cette
position tu vois que le pion ses trois
saisons passées quand même pour les
finales peut être compliqué mais les
blancs ont des cases au centre et le
flou des deux quais fort c'est vraiment
une position en tout cas intéressante
ici
on est con complètement parce que ici il
ya des arguments des deux côtés donc
position de gambie
avec baignoire ce que je rêve de faire
c'est une partie très très longue où il
se passe pas grand chose
j'ai envie
d'aller en finale et de convertir mon
qui ont de plus avec les blancs je dois
me dépêcher je dois jouer dynamique je
doit enfoncer l'adversaire et le jeu de
pièces est très sympa dans cette
situation il a continué parfois f4 bons
fous b5 c'est très logique il est très
bien passé soit en bessin qui tient ses
six il est actif il pèse sur les deux
cavaliers
plutôt bien eu quatre ça c'est un petit
peu plus étonnant parce que ça casse la
diagonale du fou j'ai deux voies ya sans
doute une idée derrière mais on peut pas
non plus si facilement fait ressac parce
que le cavalier noir pour aller sur
cette belle occasion des 5 ou alors
faudra des arguments comme la taxe sur
le roi mais pour l'instant on a du mal à
voir le plan qui dessinent pour du boxe
savate à lui de nous montrer comment il
valorise
son fera comment ils y trouvent les
conventions pour le club - en tout cas
ça m'intéresse énormément ces femmes
parce que il ya quand même un une prise
de risque importante de du beauf
franchement c'est beaucoup plus rigolo
et regardez on avait commencé deux
parties plus plate et si penco carlson
et caruana car yakine qui me font pas
rêver on y reviendra après et là par
contre j'ai ri et du boeuf le jre
premier mandat et du boeuf le combat est
déjà commencé on se régale déjà en fait
on a quand même des genres plus
fantasques dans cette partie là quand tu
vois ici penco c'est moi c'est l'école
russe c'est solide et je compte quatre
scènes dont il j'avais un peu voir ce
qui se passe il ya pas dû rentrer dedans
comme ça et puis le cadre anna cabana
c'est là qu'ils ont déjà parlé tout à
l'heure par rapport à la stratégie de
match je pense de caruana qui est de
jouer un peu moins théorique et c'est
donc là maintenant on a les mêmes et
dire avons ces deux joueurs qui aiment
beaucoup attaqué qui joue pour le gain
blanc et noir à chaque fois donc c'est
quand même assez clair qu'ils vont pas
jouer un peu c'est vraiment des joueurs
qui aiment bien les les tactiques les
prix sont ouvertes les nouveaux coups
etc et quand on voit aussi dire ils vont
dire il est connu propos enfin beaucoup
de nuls etc mais ça c'est une fausse
idée qu'on se fait je pense parce qu'on
va toi qui fais beaucoup de nuls mais il
joue comme pour le garde en partie moi
j'aime beaucoup venir le voir je guéris
parce qu'il fait des parties
intéressantes souvent la dette belge
sera proposé dans tous les cas
guy riba ils jouent à domicile
guigui bien nommé maintenant se trouve
par rapport à ce que tu as dit
oui je vais d'abord jouer alors je serai
capable d'en faire mon poulain
ajustements
mais bon en fait je trouve que c'est pas
correct en fait j'aurais bien choisie
comme poulain mais je trouve qu'il ya
trop d'écart entre guy et prague nalanda
donc j'ai
envie d'être un peu plus joueur parce
que je trouve que tu as pris un gros
risque
du coup je vais j'ai quand même choisir
un hollandais et je vais essayer de
choisir un petit jeune donc je veux les
plus forts un petit peu je choisir
jardin devant de forest
parce que je pense qu'il y avait plus
fort vous avez compris on ne choisit
jamais les grands favoris n'a pas dire
qu'arsène on peut pas
on peut pas dire qu à roanne on pourra
dire car yakine donc voir forrest ça
sera ça sera lé celui que je vais
surveiller dans ce tournoi et ce sera
mon poulain du coup jordan qu'on voit
souvent championnat de france puisqu'ils
jouent pour clichy échec et et du coup
il est très régulièrement dans les très
forts échiquier voir les médailles de
deux top 12 ou 16 mai dans le chemin de
français top 16 par équipe voilà est-ce
qu'on continue le tour des échiquiers
aller alors c'est parti on va aller voir
ton ancien poulain il va il va être pris
sa mauvaise nouvelle de la soirée lundi
bahia richard apporte en face
franchement d'houdain rapporte ça peut
être pratique salive
apparemment je te dis ça mais je vois
les chics et là on ne peut pas qualifier
cette position de tête explosive
il s'est calmé alors je vais essayer de
vous trouver la cam la cape qui va bien
voilà je vais avoir avoir du mal n'y a
pas de pas de joueurs hop le d'houdain
rapporte voyez que sur les calmes pour
l'instant je suis un peu balbutiant et
c'est bon on à richard apporte moi quand
je les ai connus richard rapporte il
avait il avait 12 13 ans la première
fois que je les ai vus en mitropa cup et
jouer au numéro à l'échec et numéro un
de la hongrie et du coup c'est un tout
petit bonhomme avec le crâne rasé et une
coupe un peu ouais ouais au dessus avec
des pics enfin bref il a bien changé
maintenant il a les cheveux longs et il
joue encore mieux aux échecs il était
déjà grand maître il était déjà très
très fort et maintenant c'est une des
stars et il est opposé à jan christoph
duda que j'ai déjà joué et qu'on jeu qui
j'avais perdu quand ils étaient 22 80
était passé 24 50 au classement d'après
joueurs hyper bien préparé on sentait
qu'il était déjà très très prometteur et
du coup duda beaucoup plus stable que
rapporte pourtant ils ont même lots et
on est dans quelque chose de plus plats
tout faits
juste les chéquiers et un petit souci
pour les chéquiers si on regarde bien
sûr le switch et ben je ne peux pas par
rapport à la caméra
peut pas modifier si je vais te faire un
petit plaisir
c'est quand même étonnant
pourquoi pas ce que je fais mais à les
enlever d'accord j'ai fait une petite
petite blagounette regarde regarde tous
fois
ouais c'est ça la magie de la technique
un mix caméra d'habitude c'est souffre
qui gère tout ça et je me retrouve au
pied levé à gérer cela
oui je vais à mon ami tu touchais de
payer au moins double voire triple c'est
ça va être ma demande dès ce soir j'en
vois j'envoie un mail direct
mais c'est vrai qu'on a eu on a eu des
soucis un peu technique donc pour ceux
qui n'étaient pas tard au tout début à
la base c'est moi qui devais qu'il
devait hausse en fait c'est moi qui
devais m'occuper de tout ça et est en
fait je devais le faire depuis
l'appartement d'un pote à moi qui avais
les connexions
le problème c'est que j'étais détester
productif hier du coc vide et que du
coup 20 je ne peux pas les rares bons
potes parce que du coup bah je suis
positive du coup on a mis en place un
moyen des pouvoirs stream à distance en
prenant le contrôle de son ordinateur
etc et bref il y aura préparé ça pendant
des heures et des heures et puis ce
matin il se réveille il me dit que on
lui a coupé la l'électricité chez lui et
du coup bah qu'est ce qu'on fait donc du
coup j'ai appliqué lunelloise il écoute
tu vas devoir le faire toi même qui
voulait pas le faire il sait pas trop
comment faire etc et du coup je lui ai
tout expliqué directement à 50 minutes
du live j'ai été vraiment de bonne
composition pause pour aider tous faim
pour les sous mais j'avais dit hier à
stoke j'étais passé voir en live sur sa
sur sa chaîne et du coup je me disais tu
imagines souci un jour je suis obligé de
dust est la solution et il rigole et ça
se finit comme ça ça c'était hier et la
50 minute du live il me dit ma sai et
baptême du feu je t'explique avec le
partage d'écran et on y va eh ben ça
c'est fait mais on n'a pas mis 50
minutes on a mis un peu plus de temps
vous avez vu on arrive à 25 je crois
mais ouais il faut il faut un petit peu
de temps pour mettre les caméras en
place sur les différentes scènes sales
fait mais c'est toujours un peu un peu
plus chaud quoi mais en fait ce qu'ils
avaient envie que je monte monte en
compétences ça y est j'ai des fins effet
il ya un début de quelque chose il ya
frémissement un frémissement on va
appeler ça comme ça bon est ce qu'on
parle de cette partie on vous dit
comment c'est arrivé c'est arrivé comme
ça en fait il ya eu faute il ya eu des
bulles londres
ok système symétrique avec fouet f5 et
du coup dès que le fou vient f5 dans le
début de londres c'est très tentant pour
les blancs de jouer avec ses 4 pour
avoir pas mal de chez madame b 3
ça c'est un grand classique quand vous
sortez dans les variantes du gambit dame
ce qu'on voit que c'est une structure
grammy dame celle là vous reconnaissez
je pense pour tous ceux qui connaissent
des quatre c4 c'est le gambit dam des 5
e cissé candidat me refuser mais il
alphonse et 8 c et sortis auparavant
avant de jouer le 6 puisque les blancs
ont tardé de jouer ces 4 est maintenant
en fait une des grandes idées de la
position c'est de jouer d'un b3 pour
appuyer sur le cube et 7 c'est le grand
classique qui arrive tout le temps ça
pas manquer il ya eu un petit 3 d'accord
cavaliers b17 et d'un b3 et d'ailleurs
et y est ce que c'est là qu'il ya un
truc marrant où il y avait un truc
marrant
dans cette position on pouvait penser à
vous prend bien j'ai déjà vu moi j'ai
toujours peur de jouer les coups mais je
dois pouvoir quand même faut produire
soyons fous soyons fous donc former un
jeu quand vous montrez c'est vrai
j'étais bourré comme les pièces bouger
un petit peu mais là il va très
intéressante et je crois que c'est comme
ça alors si je me sens ouais il ya
comment il s'appelle
le franco-italien remballe dix rangs
baldoni remballe di francesco rombaldi
il a fait une partie intéressante dans
la balle donc fou prend bien tout
reprend bien c'est normand s'est pas
bien donner le fou contre un cavalier
non développés mais la foulée quatre
échecs ici et si je joue cavalier de
deux je perds la partie à cavalière 4 ça
tout le monde le voit il ya un clouage
appuyé sur la pièce cloud et termine à
dos donc là en fait faut jouer la partie
de folie à groix ou deux
et cette position il est ultra bizarre
mais elle est quand même plutôt avantage
blanc je crois à cause de la perte de
fou je pense que c'est ça l'histoire
après il ya quand même des petites
blagues je peux jouer pour ces 5 ça peut
être quand même compliqué j'imagine que
si le joueur noir
richard rapport n'a pas joué ça
j'imagine que jude avait bien étudiés il
lui a laissé faire en b1 et
richard rapporte qu' on le verrait bien
jouer ça vous prend bien stouff pour moi
c'est typiquement son style va s'il n'a
pas joué ils avaient sans doute bosser
il a joué quelque chose de plus
conventionnel
devez connaître ce petit truc cavaliers
b17 food et six sur d'un b3 avec
toujours l'idée je me développe vite
comme ça je peux rockets et sur dame
premier set j'ai des tours b 8 tours b 2
donc c'est pas clair
donc il ya eu fou j'ai trois n'a pas
trop envie de densifier le centre avec
avec les blancs en échangeant on préfère
faire payer les changes ça c'est une
notion importante faire payer les
changes aux échecs ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que si moi j'ai change dans
syphilis entre 6 et mon adversaire qui
échangent je prends un opioïde jouve la
colonne de matour il ya pas mal de
joueurs amateurs qui s'en fiche un petit
peu que ce soit eux qui échangent ou
l'adversaire ils disent que ça peu près
pareil non pas du tout parce qu'il faut
voir les conséquences en fait de l'
échange et dans un des cas souvent je
préfère faire payer les changes à
l'adversaire faire payer stouff campari
bon voilà c'est tout le même registre
tout ça
c'est assez logique c'est assez logique
et là je vais laisser tous se
débrouiller par ce que je comprends pas
trop le coup qui a été jouée par les
noirs dont je vais lui poser la question
les noirs ont joué dépensé 4 normalement
c'est pas génial ses pions du centre
compte qui ondule elle
donc je te laisse avec le bébé
souffre du coup généralement
généralement dans cette édition connaît
quand les noirs jouent des princes et
gâte c'est qu'ils veulent après réagir
au centre avec ses 500 avec b5
il ya beaucoup de fois dans des
positions les noirs jouent au préalable
à 6 avant de prendre ses cadres pour
répondre avec par exemple six avaient
été joués avant
bahia rue des princes et 4 ans et
kativik bessac le foot bougé après donc
réellement très sain qu'un joueur
acceptera donc on peut se douter que
l'idée des noirs ce décès d'après de
réagir avec a6b cinq ou six bessin même
si ces sacs genre d'idée
donc c'est quand même un choix important
pour les noirs parce qu on laisse le
centre au blanc pour ge poussée avec b 5
30 de l'espace du coup aller à dame donc
c'est qu'un marchand responsable c'est
pas évident vu le temps que achats
rapport à la pendule je pense que cette
position lui gamme assez familier je
pense qu'il connaît un petit peu les
idées et du coup je pense que le
dépenser 4 à des villes
pas bien expliqué d'ailleurs souvent on
comprend l'idée maintenant en fait on
donne le centre dans un premier temps si
je comprends bien pour après venir le
cas c'est avec la poussée 5 et vous
pourquoi pas la pousser à 6b cinq ans
plus quoi
c'est ça c'est ça et d'ailleurs quand on
voit quand on voit le coup qui a été
jouée après en fait part par rapport
moi j'aime beaucoup ce que je trouve que
c'est très original en tout cas après il
faut prendre ces quatre qui est le cool
normal il ya eu ici des tours b 8 tours
sur la colonne
voilà donc si je veux jouer bessac ça
c'est clair et donc bon sur a6 irait
probablement d'un premier set qui
quittent c est le coup donc la victoire
de huit banques des champions et il le
pousse et des 5 tout à fait donc ce qui
est pas facile à faire parce que après
cavale et c3 le pion et les gamins
triste plusieurs fois
vis-à-vis qui va permettre
par exemple admettons
cavale et c3 qui est la règle et jouer
d'ailleurs
alors s'il faut prendre et ça nous ont
juste pour voir ici en fait il faut bien
voir que si ça ne marche pas à cause de
fou prend des six parce que si on fait
tomber 5
si tu fais saisissent le food & cie ne
serais plus protégée dont curry rouge et
3 prendre soin de vous décider à faire
une petite amélioration donc tu fais un
gros intermédiaires tu te débarrasses de
durée du défaut dans les échanges les
fous et après tu fais le c6 donc un
prompteur c6 est pas à six parce que
donc la l'envoyer là le fou est cloué il
ya le visage il a entouré la dame enfin
vous ai perdu à la place on a des vrais
à six il y aurait eu le petit coucou
prend 17 qui fait échec et qui permet de
débarrasser de visa et robin d'un combo
de la cdu pas tant que ça c'est du
détail de trois pions trois pions ou non
donc attention à quand vous faites la
combinaison faut vérifier ce sera autre
chose sinon ça peut être deux drames
clairement clairement donc du coup b5
mais bon c'est osé 1 et a fait au final
l'argent trouvé une des cinq mâts gagne
du temps parce qu'ils jouent pas assise
joue pas donc ils vivent ils arrivent
quand même à
il fait ça de manière assez énergique
toutefois jeu je trouve ça c'est sympa
en tout cas de givet où on pourrait
faire un petit quizz au chat maintenant
ce qu'on vient de montrer fou prend b5
qu'est ce qui se passe sur cavaliers pro
b 5 en fait c'est assez rigolo sauf par
rapport à ce que tu viens de nous dire
on a regardé comprend b5
et cavaliers pro b 5 6 si on a un petit
peu un petit peu mais qu'aucun on peut
proposer ça
au chat ce que ouais les gars et du coup
là on joue comme ça on travaille pas
trop non plus ce que c'est vrai concours
est assez clair il faut faire travailler
tout calculé tout c'est pas trop dur
alors bien sûr mais mais c'est rigolo
quoi ça rigolo est-ce que vous avez des
idées sur le chat de ce qui se passe sur
cave à l'étranger 5 qu'est ce que vous
pourrez faire pour réfuter un petit peu
les blancs dans le but il ya une
alliance matour la dame on veut gagner
là on veut gagner la pièce donc on va
les prendre et ça qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait le faire avec les noirs 6,6 à
travailler un petit peu aussi ça juste
ça ça boit son petit café en nous
regardant on va voir un petit peu ce
qu'ils sont ce qu'ils sont actifs de
ceux qui dorment voilà pas de raison
maintenant que tout est ok à notre
niveau on va faire à faire bosser tout
le monde
après cette levée après ça te va on
passera à voir rapidement marc andrieu
si tu veux et puis juste après centre un
petit page de pub ça fait quasiment une
heure là il va falloir qu'on la fasse ok
ok ils voudraient bien les voir marc
andreu rien voir les deals qui français
avant de de falla pub donc je crois que
le chat il est complètement endormis ils
dorment complètement
devoir l'expliquer ni même
à ya quand même flooder qui nous dit
qu'il boit son p'tit kawa ce qui veut
bien dire ce que ça veut dire se dire
les gars laissez moi tranquille je suis
là mais je me sens moi tranquille comme
alors regardez on voit c'est la même
histoire que se trouve nous a raconté
quand le fou prenait 1 mais maintenant
faut inverser un peu la combine est et
ça qui est rigolo ya quoi comme
comme répondre oui néandertal il est
toujours là avec avec les petites
réponses
et on tactique il voit bien ce cas tout
ça ce qui était assez marrant c'est que
ce refus b5
il fallait prendre en g3 pour éviter que
le foot soit en prison glacée un peu le
même principe parce que si on joue le c6
ou à 6 tout de suite dans ses positions
à ça va pas il ya qu'à y apprend des six
à chaque fois qui est grave sur échec
donc on fait fou prend g3 d'abord puis
on prend g3 mais là ce qui est ça assez
rigolo c'est qu'on a la même position
tout à l'heure avec le cahier en c3 il
faut en bessin que tout aille bien
précis anjou c6 pour éviter faut prendre
17 et cette fois ci on joue ces 6 2 tout
à l'heure mais il ya cavaliers des six
échecs intermédiaires et sur sept on
peut même prendre un f5 et chaque aussi
est ensuite enlevé notre dame donc là il
est très précis de jouer à 6 comme ça a
été précisé par néandertal et sur a6
effectivement là les les noirs gagne
aussi ça c'est marant il y avait deux
petites variantes n'y pour gagner la
pièce bon évidemment dans cette partie
il faut de petit rock et la partie
continuer à base de tours d 1 qui place
la tour devant la dame pour un jour
évitez les c5 voilà donc les blancs
veulent garder leur centre et richard
rapporte va devoir essayer de le casser
du coup donc tu me donnes tu travailles
tu veux qu'on aille
voir le tata steel challenger ouais eh
ben c'est parti on y va vers le tata
steel challenger et effectivement il ya
une position déjà assez avancé de marc
landry mao rizzi pour assez avancé gens
qui les opposait aux grands matches
ganguly qui est indien qui à 26,30
quasiment donc à un grand maître de tout
premier plan et donc marquons dream
house dj est aussi grand maître mais les
25 02 et comme on dit donc voila et il
ya encore du boulot pour arriver à 2600
points elo d'écart c'est très important
mais
bangou lit sa carrière et quand même
derrière lui disons qui se maintient à
ce niveau là depuis depuis très
longtemps entre 26 26 50 et marc andré
malraux angie va maintenant devoir
lutter avec ce genre de joueur il a les
noirs donc c'était déjà pas si facile
que ça j'ai absolue' verture c'est quand
même plutôt bien passé se trouve puisque
la position à l'air a l'air tout à fait
tout à fait correct et s'attend déjà
vers l'égalité puisque le plateau s'est
vidé
ouais est ce qu'on peut voir parce que
ces personnes là bien sûr dès le début
donc un petit répit pour démarrait donc
leur ai tissé cavaliers f3 au premier
coup des 5es e3 dont alors on sait pas
trop ce que ça va être mais normalement
quand on fait cavalier f3c le début
gourévitch donc début gourévitch et
micha gourévitch
le fort grand maître si les belges
gourévitch turcs je sais plus il a
changé
mais michaud
il est belge maintenant je veux qu'on
lui d'ailleurs sur ce point comme assez
récemment on a fait une grosse session
de blitz et il m'a battu salé ouais
j'étais content de faits contre lui tu
vois c'était moi j'ai joué en top 12 ah
bah ouais bah ça c'est la chance d'un
jamais eu l'occasion de jouer en lan et
là je sais quand je dis retrouver sur
chaise comme j'étais bien content mais
et premier à 5 et 5,4 voilà bah bravo à
lui un badass ans et il est fort du coup
maintenant pour revenir la position et
trois cavaliers f6 sekkat donc quelle
est la particularité de social dont six
pour tenir le centre et maintenant on va
faire prochainement un petit b3 pour
mettre le fou sur la meilleure diagonale
puisqu'on voit déjà qu'en ayant joué
trois rapidement même ça permet de
sortir notre fou ben on est gêné avec le
phocéen et on va pouvoir mettre notre
fou sur la diagonale un libre pour tout
vous dire ce qui se passe c'est assez
c'est assez tranquille quand même
dansé dansé position là franchement avec
les blancs on joue encore pour le petit
plus ce qu'on a vu dans la partie des
sites penco carlsen dans caruana car
yakine c'est une ouverture où les blancs
ils disent ben joue un petit jeune
normalement j'ai plus d'expérience j'ai
parlé dans le débat théorique je vais
essayer de l'avoir à l'usure dans le
milieu le jeu plat
il se doute aussi gants gulik marquant
dream à maui jim pour arriver aussi tôt
aussi fort ça doit être une machine de
calcul il n'y a pas que ça mais il a des
grosses capacités de calcul du coup
pareil on joue tranquille on va jouer
aux échecs et surtout on rende pas dans
des débuts compliqués et c'est ce qu'il
est en train de faire avec les blancs
hop il met les pièces en place alors là
il ya un moment important
structurellement parlant qu'on trime
arudy joue c5 et là il ya quand même
potentiellement à terme des idées de cas
et ses 6 des cas tous des choses comme
ça donc très très vite là il n'a pas
hésité il prend au centre directement
avec une petite astuce donc la marque
andry peut prendre de la pièce sont des
cinq pour favoriser le jeu de pièces ou
alors du pion pour ce faire un gros
centre et peut-être avoir l'idée à terme
de d4 sauf que l'idée sous jacente du
dernier coup des blancs c'est
directement de faire des cats et bam on
va obtenir un pion isolé c'est sûr parce
que si les noirs prennent le pion isolé
arrive si les blancs prennent le pion
isolé arrive voilà et l'idée aussi c'est
que si jamais les noirs venez à juin
tout comme b6
à rien dépensé 5 b process 5 est bon
dans les structures de pions pendant
avec les pions c5 et des cinq ans
peut-être pendant ces des pions qui qui
sont collés équipe a défendu par des
pions sur des codes adjacentes et libé
en fait des blancs se serait d'attaquer
ses pions donc tour c'est un travail à 4
par exemple etc donc elles démarreront
le ventre on contrôle des cases mais les
pions soit un peu faible donc ce sont
des pions forts faibles voilà souffle
nous a expliqué contrôle beaucoup de
cases et asphyxient un peu les blancs
mais par un bon jeu donc on va faire
flot d'europe pour pas avoir de problème
et se trouve nous proposer le plan tour
c'est un cavalier à 4 pour commencer à
travailler sur ces sacs pour travailler
sur des sacs aussi il y à d'autres plans
par exemple de ramener la tour et l'idée
ça sera de faire bouger un jour un des
pions dans de mauvaises conditions pour
les noirs pour roba pour les manger et
délié ses deux pions qui côte à côte
comme nous le disaient se trouve
contrôle beaucoup de cases
donc petit plus
petit plus blanc dans dans cette
position foods donc parce que pourquoi
petit plus qui aura une faiblesse mais
marc-andré il a fait ce qu'il fallait
quand vous avez une position comme ça
qui sur le long terme et légèrement
défaillante il a commencé à travailler
sur le jeu de pièces à prendre
l'initiative
a joué dynamique pour faire évoluer
cette position et ne pas rester sur un
pieu isolé qui petit à petit va se
dégrader pendant la finale ou préfinale
donc des français dit ça y est dans
gouly fait le choix allez vas-y
maintenant montre moi ton pu isoler et
la marque andry je pense qu'ils étaient
toujours dans sa préparation il a joué
damas 5 avec une pression sur ses 5 /
cavaliers c3 il essaye de faire mal des
coûts piquant tour c'est assez logique
fois f6 fait très très mal là encore ça
travailler
cavaliers des quatre qui est le seul
coût pourrait empêcher la pression du
cac et ses trois ans +5 ou vers l'avant
le cavalier bien sûr une bonne case ce
qui peut laisser le fou passé peut-être
petit rock derrière cavaliers français 5
est maintenant cavalier processus a été
jouée par par camboulit ça c'est un coût
qui est un petit peu plus étonnant
quoique il ne trouvait pas de solution
puisque là il ya une menace des noirs
c'est de
daisy lowe les leurs pions c'est ça
qu'on dit dans les livres stouff
je ne sais pas revient à flot et ils ont
créé rétablir l'équilibré changer la
structure
de façon favorable
je sais pas si des isolés ça existe les
bricolos du chat pour me le dire mais
nouveau cavalier français 6b france et 6
en a une qui ont pendant ça y est en
fait c'est ce que gang ou lui a voulu
avoir plutôt que marc andry arrive à
rééquilibrer la structure d'un gouvy
sediba je fais une petite concession je
laisse mon petit bonhomme tu n'auras
plus tokyo isolé mais tu as des pions
pendant qu'ils sont légèrement moche du
coup ben c'est bis repetita marc-andré
se retrouve encore à devoir jouer
dynamique après petit rock et il a joué
l'excellent cavaliers 4 pour ba commencé
à travailler sur le cahier c3 un souffle
propres c'est une bonne partie de
dames et il a tout bouffé tout bouffer
l'a toujours fait des percées 6 mai pour
est volé sur le pion bête sur le pion
béthouart est ce qu'on peut imaginer
comme position en fait c'est qu'en fait
les noirs font perdre un mollet
a et c est un droit et en fait on va
réussir à manger le pion b contre le
pion à avoir une position où qui
sibea saute vraiment ça va être très
difficile parce que même dans la
perspective sig en boule y arriver à
leurs espions là où s'échangent les
finales de pièces lourdes avec 4,3 sur
la même elle c'est extrêmement dur à
gagner si c'est une finale deux tours
c'est archi nul assez facilement sauf
position très très spécifiques
et du coup la finale de pièces tous
réduire nos coûts là on peut imaginer
que
marc-andré fait une excellente partie
tout comme son adversaire qui finalement
allégé plus en pratique qui ne devrait
pas réussir à convertir sur un bon jeu
de marc landry franchement une super
partie pour démarrer même si c'était pas
la partie la plus rigolote à regarder on
constate que c'est l'adversaire de
marc-andré qui aveugle et blanc faisait
le choix de la guerre ou non et il a
choisi un truc quand même relativement
calme pour et sept pouces et un petit
plus et finalement marc landry dans le
débat stratégique a répondu présent
franchement jolie partie a souffert on a
fait le travail dans la partie mais très
peu et les joueurs aussi mal qu andry ça
sera un très bon demi point d'entamer
une ouverture propre des bons coups et
maintenant il faut qu'on qui
convertissent cette position qui est pas
trop technique mais faut toujours faire
attention parce que c'est quand même
plus facile à jouer pour pour les blancs
sauf si on essaye un truc comme ça j'ai
pas manquer normalement ça devrait ça
devrais je pense ce liquide et c'est de
cette position
alors ce qui est la première raison
c'est après on revient sur le jeu super
tournoi legg magnus et et et compagnie
c'est ça
donc on va faire une petite pause donc à
césar et ben non c'est ce que je viens
de ce que j'ai dit à l'ats me suis dit
du conteur s'impose
c'est rare
et poly jeunesse les deux tu vas y si tu
vas dans obs et tu cherches en relais
commercial ok ok ok pour la première par
exemple un petit peu en
stocker à prendre la première celle là
là il faut qu'il gagnera la sni caméra
pour le public ok bah je vais faire ça
et j'en suis
ouais attendra je coupe le son et c'est
ça que cacher ligue du sucre à cliquer
et nous voilà reparti directement pour
le tata steel donc là on était sur la
partie vous rappelez un de marque andry
mao rizzi est bon ici se passe pas grand
chose pour le moment
puisque il ya une suite de coups et où
l'adversaire gong li a encaissé le pion
sait qu il va essayer de tenter le petit
pressing dans cette position c'est
certain
mais on peut dire que pour l'instant la
partie est très qualitative stéphane et
du coup que ça devrait bien se passer
pour pour m'apprendre i du coup on va on
va continuer à aller voir notre open
assad va
ses fans yes avec ces les autres on
avait quasiment fait un tour total des
échiquiers on va le finir ce tour total
des échiquiers
on n'avait pas vu ni shankland ni dont
contre visite ni grande des lieux compte
revendre forest à les envoyer sur le
camp des lieux souvent de forest d'abord
et du coup hop on va on va mettre leur
petit calmes comme ça on aura tous voilà
on va être hyper bien
tac
et voulait faire face ils sont là facile
facile
ok et ben du coup on est parti pour pour
7 pour cette partie donc votre corps est
grande et use alors question bête parce
qu'on a quand même
je sais que je l appelle un mais
au niveau des départs y on a chacun
choisit notre poulain donc toi tu es tu
es guan trust moi je suis avec le petit
prince d'aaland à qui j'aurais indien
quels sont les
les
[Musique]
les paris est ce que qu'est ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait qu'elles sont ce que je vous
propose ils vont elles pas ça sera basse
on a parié sur le grand paris c'est
toujours 5 seube l'ensemble du tournoi
tu vois et ça c'est bien c'est notre
pari max et après des fois il faut qu'on
trouve des petits intérêts à deux seuls
comme on a dit qu'on peut se faire si tu
veux on peut se marier 5 seube pour bon
le voir le joueur qui est devant l'autre
à la fin du tournoi et en prime on peut
se
marier un seube
par victoire de nos couleurs ouais c'est
très très bien
donc s'ils ont avant tout une nation
aussi en a un qui avant comme chaque
jour ça marche comment ces genres ton
poulain a fait quatre victoires il en
fait 3 le mien ça fera ça fera du coup
plus + 1 c'est ça
c'est ça quand messi par exemple
aujourd'hui premier mandat il a co la
grille ce qui va se passer ok et ben du
coup de coutume dans ce stage et
je
vois que tu es dans cet esprit et
stéphane la prime à la victoire le beau
jeu ça ça fait plaisir s'est passé c'est
le beau jeu le baril et un nouveau pari
si on peut aussi rajouter si tu veux un
petit pari quand les joueurs ce jour bah
oui oui moi ça on est obligées ça c'est
le seul d'ailleurs ces deux sable double
le double sommet ne sais même pas quelle
couleur tu sais bien que moi j'ai pas
regardé ça parce que j'avais pas prévu
de se dire particulièrement venteux
forrest je pense que c'est ouais tu
n'aurais pas soutenu prime nalanda
ouais j'aurais été verre en main comme
mamediarov voilà dans ce style là tu
vois mais là du coup c'est plus
intéressant on à paris cider c'est ok
alors du coup dans cette position qu'est
ce qu'on va pouvoir a expliqué on
regarde un petit peu commencé survenu on
n'avait pas eu d'espagnol jusqu'à
aujourd'hui c'est chose faite avec cette
partie espagnole
classique jusque là on n'échange pas le
cavalier celles ci sont garde nos fous
et sur cavaliers f6 qui est grand
classique où l'on joue plutôt des choses
avec petit rock là il avait choisi de
jouer assez vite avec détroit dont les
variantes un petit peu un petit peu plus
modeste quoique on trouve maintenant ça
très régulièrement du c3 c'est logique
aussi à terme avec le plan fous ces deux
des quatre qui se dégage très souvent
donc le grand des lieux s'il a choisi un
système un système fiant kétou donc on
n'est pas dans les schémas ci classique
que sa vague les noirs il a envie de
grands des lieux se sont ils jouent aux
échecs dans le sens
c'est pas comme les top10 mondiaux qui
ont des ouvertures très solide avec les
noirs lui il est un peu plus fantasques
quand même comme joueur donc tour un
petit rock cavaliers b d2 pour l'instant
vente fort est celui se casse pas la
tête il joue très très simple avec du
plan archi-classique franchement passe
pas grand-chose b5 ok je mets mon petit
fou en c2 un jour je pourrais peut-être
joué pour d4 à voir
donc à 5 réactions à la dame f ou g 5
coups de coude développement basique
parce que peut-être que je peux aussi
jump et le cavalier par trois des cinq
et obtenir un beau jeu de pièces parce
que là on est dans la bataille
d'après ouverture si vous voulez où on a
sorti toutes les pièces maintenant faut
les améliorer fois au faut essayer
d'avoir une structure avantageuse
puisque les deux rois sont tranquille
pépère dans leur niche bah c'est le jeu
de pièces et
la bonne structure de pions qui vont
faire les différences dans cette
position à ses fans
ouais c'est que là après tout le centre
c'est aussi un coup intéressant dans
l'idée que très souvent nature
provoquent un coup comme agissent pour
affaiblir un peu la production par
exemple h6 bon live wave 4 mai sur 1,6
peut-être que on aurait pu reculer que
le four en d2 ou en 3 on va préfère un
come down cern ou d'amd ne pourra
l'attaquer le pion à justice d'oran m le
kwassa foulée 5 ça peut provoquer de
peut donner envie aux noirs de faire 1 6
pour provoquer un pour forcer un petit
peu les choses c'est qu'après hcc manu
bout je peux reculé pour après allait
attaquer le plus rage 6 provoqué roi h7
et au final à poussoirs un peu fragilisé
depuis un an si c'est leur âge c'est
donc c'est aussi une idée mais là du
coup avec injustice flash 4 on voit que
peut-être que les blancs veulent sur le
long terme avec tout les 4 et le fou qui
va l'arranger trois trains jour attaqué
la cheffe de pions des indécis ce sens
et merci à papa de metal aussi qui suit
très bien et du coup pas de métal on ira
voir la partie de marinières off pour
parce que pat métal il surveille bien
qu'ils ou quels sont les avantages et
les parties marquante c'est toujours
bien quand dans le tchat vous nous dites
qu'il ya une partie qui vous intéressent
que ce soit dans le haut ou même le b1
pour une partie vraiment sensationnel
dans le b n'hésitez pas à nous dire si
quelque chose se passe de très fort et
merci à tous ceux qui nous rejoignent
pour les petits mots et on s'inquiète de
ta santé souffre on fait au mieux mais
sachez qu'il est hyper content de
commenter et après ils auraient aimé
forcément le faire je pense dans de
meilleures conditions stouff et en plus
il doit faire chaud en argentine effet
combien chez toi sauf le lampe tout là
je sens dans une rue hyper passant donc
il ya beaucoup de bruit donc si je le
voulais fenêtre vous n'êtes pas mon
temps
je tapais j'ai tapé juste hyper content
la question
sur toutes menaces à la bombe et même
pas compte
on
fait des échecs on va voir des beaux
échec pour le consoler et quand il fait
chaud
[Musique]
réfléchir c'est maintenant la seule
chose qui peut me souviens c'est que
oui non plus haut plus on sait comme les
échecs sont rudes et les échecs ça
apprend l'humilité se trouve dans les
paris il a pourtant appris l'humilité
mais il va continuer à apprendre j'ai
l'impression aujourd'hui parce que
finalement il a quand même joué la
grosse cote
et du coup je vois bien
je vois bien vendre fera et cela collait
à grande des lieux pour ce premier jour
et prague dont on doit se la faire
coller aussi histoire de bien mais bien
entamé ce championnat avec avec la
totale alors à chis a été joué
effectivement
après ça va tu vois là juste pour voir
venir surprise est là aujourd'hui fait
que 36 degrés tu vas away au
colisée 40 il ya deux jours et si et si
je te disais qu'en bretagne il fait
aussi 36 degrés tu en penses quoi
souffre
est ce qu'un jour il ya eu 36 degrés en
bretagne c'est honnêtement 36 degrés
c'est extrêmement rare même au maximum
de l'été pourtant rennes en plus c c'est
un des endroits où il fait assez chaud
je dirais 33 degrés c grand max bon ok
ça devrait plus des fois mais mais c est
déjà 33 rebonds c'est la folie quoi
maintenant tout cela en plus la ccc là
on en janvier janvier ces endroits c'est
le ce petit mois de juillet quoi en
en février
[Musique]
on est loin de 30 sites à nager du
visage en a d'autres il ya du il ya du
forcément du breton dans le chat ça
l'univers mentez salut à tous ceux qui
nous rejoignent
et ça lui à hyannis aussi ok ben on est
donc on est parti pour cette partie
alors est ce qu'il ya une prise
davantage là dans l'ouverture ou doc
grand des lieux se sont travaillés à l
dame et la logique on va taper la case
fort puisque on tape le cavalier f6 tout
tout semble normal fou bessette
et c4 alors ces quatre c'est un coup
assez original comme stouff là on voit
la compréhension des grands maîtres en
termes de structure de pions donc déjà
ça évite tout des cinq mais surtout sur
bbc4 qu'est ce qu'il a prévu
d'avoir comme structure il ya plein de
structures potentielles parce que c est
ce que c'est pour prendre le pion à 4
est ce que c'est pour un moment faire
dépenser quatre à avoir cette structure
là où cavaliers français 4 enfin vous
voyez ça c'est typiquement
la ou les grands maîtres excellent c'est
l'interprétation des modifications
structurelles alors j'espère que tout le
monde me comprends bien quand je dis ça
c'est à dire que quand les pions sont en
tension comme ici il peut y avoir bekkat
il peut y avoir dépensé 4 il peut y
avoir je touche à rien et quand je fais
des français 4s que sur beuvron saccades
les blancs prennent ici ça change la
position et est ce que ils reprennent
comme ça c'est encore une autre position
est ce que sur mes prince et cathya
calais prend ses 4 et giget qu'il ya
aussi possibilité de ne toucher à rien
donc ça c'est extrêmement compliqué
hyper intéressant et ses quatre vents de
forrest on voit qu'il a une heure à la
pendule donc voilà il a réfléchi une
demi heure sur l'ensemble de sa partie
donc il a joué ça assez vite et c'est la
folie et du coup dans cette
configuration
bah grande des lieux à jouer un coup
déjà compliquée cavaliers bekkat parce
que ils lâchent ils h le pion bessac
pourquoi peut-être prendre la perte de
fou mais le sert en même temps c'est le
mauvais fou donc qu'est ce qu'il avait
prévu sur ses preuves et 5 badham 17
apparemment
et c'est assez étonnant puisque dame 17
francs m6 vous prendrez fils fou prend
1,4 et du coup mais on se retrouve avec
un gros pions de moins deux pions de
moins et il ya cavaliers prend des trois
qui étaient des peut-être prévu voyez
c'est de la folie des appartient
franchement je monte ça assez vite parce
qu'on va pas rentrer dans les grosses
complications mais ce que voulaient au
bout du compte grand des lieux c'est une
position un peu cheap et alors de très
loin dans le brouillard un peu dans le
style benko c'est à dire des tours qui
vont pouvoir se tester sur les pions à 2
b2 b5 qui sont peut-être un peu fragile
bref le fou bessette fait du travail
aussi il a une paire de fous des relatif
et baissent parce que attention même si
les pions à deux baies deux peuvent être
fragiles peuvent aussi est très fort
rapidement un gros pari là de grands des
news dans cette position qui veut jouer
à l'initiative
on va voir on va voir les prochains
coups vont être déterminants si van de
forest arrive à trouver la précision et
à s'accrocher à ses pions en ayant un
jeu de pièces acceptable voilà tout le
pari tout l'enjeu de cette position le
fouet f6 et là c'est la concession de
grands des lieux si vous voulez il a
pour l'instant pas prévu de temps que ça
va améliorer mais par contre il estime
grandi lui ce que pour le pion de moins
il a quand même c'est toutes ces pièces
là qui jouait et soyons fous mais tendue
vers mais c'est ces voix là c'est quand
même une très très belle si j'arrive à
leucate avec les noirs après je pourrai
peut-être l'un f5 essayer de sortir ce
fou noir d'ici et
et avoir des conversations mais pour
l'instant en fait ça va se jouer là
dessus parce que les blancs cette
majorité elle est damée votre pouce le
pion à quatre à cinq à six et ils ont
aussi la case des 5 donc il ya des
choses à des choses à voir en tout cas
ouais ce qui ce qui me gêne énormément
si tu veux toof c'est
le caractère figé pour l'instant de la
structure de pions restantes qui devrait
favoriser normalement les cavaliers
c'est à dire qu'il faudrait que la
position soit encore plus ouverte alors
il faut en fait si les blancs harry et
sans avoir pardon arrive à péter sur
quatre balles à là c'est le jackpot bien
sûr je dois absolument pas le laisser
premier coup je regarderai dans cette
position c'est plutôt qu'à et d5 aveugle
et blanc et j'essaie de bloquer cette
cette position de profiter de mon pions
d'avancé et de la majorité elle dame
voilà le premier coup je regarderai par
contre si j'arrive à péter le pion aux 4
et ensuite même fait re 4 moi même alors
là c'est le jackpot pour les fous mais
je pense qu'on en est très loin là c'est
aux blancs de jouer j'ai cavaliers d2
comme candidat tous les coups de
cavaliers qui protège le pion aux oeufs
par transparence avec la tour qui se
libère mes cahiers des 5 c'est vraiment
le coup que je jouerai en blitz
et après avec l'idée à terme de jouer
b34 quelque chose comme ça bon voilà on
va voir mais il ya plusieurs kutwa sont
jouables dans cette position après il va
essayer de trouver le meilleur mais j'ai
l'impression que vente fort est passé
mon poulain de façon donc tu sais bien
comment ça se passe dans ces cas-là ce
tout franchement c'est sûr qu'il va
ouvrir sa
technique et c'est bon un peu de
technique et servent-ils free va gagner
facile et et du coup on peut aller voir
champion de vie dit ça vous va avant
d'aller passer à la phase
6 est la position choisie par comme ça
on aura fait un tour des stades et
champlan de vie dit c'est la seule pour
laquelle j'ai pas j'ai pas la caméra
active en d'accord
souffre il me semble que c'est par le
début elle
voilà j'ai pas aimé
donc bah je vais move est du prof m'a
médias comme ça vous êtes petit un petit
peu de un petit peu d'humains donc
shankland vie dit qu'est ce que ça donne
aux sports va pas se régaler l'a1
franchement j'ai pas vous endormir
longtemps vu partir son devoir c'était
juste pour voir donc on va vous dire à
chaque fois donc encore cette feinte un
hymne zoo indienne et finalement même
sur cavaliers c3 il a décidé de jouer
des cinq donc en fait jean claude on
peut commencer par cavalier m6 est joint
en gambie dame refusait ça ne pose pas
de problème donc c'est la position du
gobi dame refusait hélas et prend des
cinq c'est le gambit dam des changes
dans madame variantes des changes
puisqu'on prend au centre évidemment je
prends des 5 fu g5 si le grand classique
c6 hockey est roi fou aussi être c'est
le coût normal fou détroit petit rock
bon là majoritairement le coup que je
connais dans cette position que je joue
ces dames c'est 2 le plan que je
conseille un niveau amateur quand je
fais les stream souffle ses cavaliers eu
de f 3 ou 4 parce que je trouve que
c'est vraiment après avoir roque est un
vraiment le plan de base est une plante
plus simple je sais pas si toi un plant
affectionne
ben ces thématiques assez surtout facile
à jouer en plus tu vois ce que je me dis
un autre thème de cette position quand
le cavalier vie en f3 parce que c'est
notre façon de jouer la position avec
dams est de toujours et petit rock vous
avez le plan de la tacc de minorités qui
est hyper connue avec tour à b1 b4
bessac qui vise à attaquer les dames
attention sur deux plans très différents
mais je trouve pour des joueurs amateurs
que le plan va cavaliers edf 3 4 une
fois qu'on invoquait c'est mieux
d'ouvrir le centre convoquée c'est plus
sécu
c'est le plan le plus logique à
comprendre avec l'idée d'asphyxié
l'adversaire en un jour pourquoi pas eu
5 si nous prend pas et pourquoi pas f4
f5 fin bref de de vraiment commencer
l'asphyxient d'avoir un jeu de pièces
qui va être génial parce que vous aurez
un gros centre et l'adversaire jouera
sur trois rangées il sera coincé et du
coût d'achat h3 qu'un coup qu'on trouve
assez souvent
c'est même pas nécessairement pour
bloquer cette case là c'est juste un
petit coup d'attentes pour voir un peu
comment l'adversaire va se développer et
là je suis assez étonné je vous la vous
donc cavalier 8 ça il doit être
relativement marginal ici c'est des
choses il développa plus comme ça j'ai
vu une partie comme ça au championnat du
monde de de plus je crois
et c'est tes clés noires car ce n est là
je cadrais les huit qui va l'aider si ce
parti j'arrive plus à me souviens
contrôle qui c'était
le plan c'est d'appauvrir l'échiquier
des pièces et on voit souvent d'ailleurs
sous le plan le plus connu à la place de
cavalia 8 ch is on provoque faut acheter
ont fait tour huit cavaliers e4 qui est
qui est très connu dans cette position
là un peu dans l'idée d'appauvrir le
matériel mais cavaliers 8 c'est sympa
aussi ici dans cette position puisque le
cavalier qui vous semble bizarre stouff
en un clin d'oeil il a déjà vu la partie
mais il aurait fait de toute façon qu'à
aider six pour la case de rebond vous
avez le droit de notre cavalier au bord
sylla du rebond et du coup on voit les
cas les belles cases qui sont visés par
cavalier en d6 donc la malle un faux f
4g change pas fou des 6es du coup là
toujours pareil je n'échange pas sinon
cavaliers vient reprendre on a dit un
faux faire payer les changer du coup la
vie dit il fait payer les changes à ça
me chante quand si tu me prends je
reprends mes dans de bonnes conditions
d'un mètre 6 je veux pas prendre c'est à
toi de prendre un petit combat ici sur
ce sujet cavalier e 2 tu me prends c'est
toi qui payent donc voyez ils sont des
petites politesse sur le sujet
ils s'engueulent autour de l' échange et
un moment ces champions qui craquent en
premier parce qu'il a besoin d'enlever
ce cavalier 8 qui gêne la tour eiffe 8es
après cavaliers prend 1,4 à aider si
hockey facile logique jusque là et les
blancs sont clairement mieux dans cette
position mais la pression noir reste
solide
et si cette position elle avait l'air
soporifique par rapport à ce qu'on
voyait au final visite ici là était très
ambitieux stouff il a balancé un gros h4
donc jusque là c'est la baston parce
qu'il prévoit sans doute de faire grand
et du coup si on avait vu cette partie
on aurait dit qu'elle était plutôt
excitante alors que quand on a mis la
fin de partida on ne pensait pas à titre
perso je pensais pas que c'était passé
de manière aussi sauvage parce que là
ils envoient du bois
visite hu est alors je vais je vais
essayer de regarder parce qu'on nous
parle de caral celle de carlson great
food alors c'est peut-être ça mais je
suis pas sur une trame et ce n'est pas
les juke je vais faire ma petite
recherche de mon côté là et merci à toi
le shop merci à toi
je cherche le second grand dam youth
rappelle michel
je bave alors grande et muse gelé connu
qu elles étaient jeunes en bas en fin
2009 il faisait il faisait un tour à de
grands maîtres et à l'époque il avait
les dreads donc
était bien loin de joe bava
même si je bats vrai assez fantasque
aussi ils avaient des dreads donc il ya
bien changer maintenant
du coup tout tout tout tout cas oui dans
cette position enfin de l'idc g4 je
peins je pense que j'incarne n'a pas été
jouer ici vous voyez pourquoi j'ai
quatre n'a pas été joué en premier parce
que ça paraît plus logique pour le foie
f5 quand même souffre de jouer de jouer
g4
mais je crois qu'il y avait cinq en fait
si je dis pas de bêtises
alors soit vous cherchez le high speed
forgé la réf bon non mais je les ai
juste là dans ma base on l'a et
franchement j'ai quatre donné trop envie
mais à g5 de folie mois c'est une guerre
que cette petite tactile samsung wave et
du coup hkd ah oui hk de regarder le
petit tour 8 malin menace d'un prend des
donc j'ai quatre dames prend des quatre
vraisemblablement
du coup grand roque et là là je vais
faire j'ai catag les blancs et je suis
trop content et je vais dégommer mon
adversaire sauf que jean-claude hyper
mal un fouet f5 je veux bien que tu
joues g4 mais je t'enlève d'abord ton
fou énormissime d'attac et je gagne la
case the cat en plus au passage pour mon
cavalier donc regarder fou prend f5 il
ya une dame point f5 g4 gratos d'anaïs
g5 gratos dame f5 mais j'ai plus assez
de pièces pour attaquer avec les blancs
et surtout et la cavalière kraft qui
arrive donc faire attention aussi que
plus le pion son avance et des fois plus
que tout peut être faible donc là ok les
blancs réussir un g4 g5 gratos donc avec
pas mal de marché a pas mal avancé dans
les attaques mais comme j'ai pas
beaucoup de pièces derrière s'ils
l'attaquent
lll arrive à rien on va au final des
pions sont souvent c'est un peu pour
rien et en finale puis on peut mettre
ces faibles donc faire attention en
pratique un vous aussi on n'est pas trop
avancé trouve options comme ça ça peut
être des fois ça peut des fois compliqué
donc ici bon j'ai gardé ça a l'air
correct moi j'aime bien mes mots à moi
j'aimais bien en fait si tu me saoules
j'adore les blancs et si je suis un peu
choqué la décision de
de vie dit c'est là qu'on voit que voilà
c'est pour ça que je sais pas je suis
pas grand mètres de haut niveau il a
joué damage froid ici sauf que je trouve
assez choquant je peux comprendre qu'on
la change les dames à un moment avec des
blancs mais pas maintenant moi j'aurais
tenté ma chance avec la taxe qu'il des
couteaux des g1 à chaque g6 quelque
chose comme ça dans le style breton pur
jus souvent on va pas se mentir voilà
j'aurais fait exactement la même adopté
en bretagne souffre avec avec des
réflexions comme ça
mais c'est clair on va tous envie
d'attaquer on a poussé des pions donc
c'est logique c'est bizarre par contre
vous avec eux en finale plus et puis on
fait avancer on disait plus dépendre
faible donc ça paraît bizarre de pousser
des options et après je vais d'abord
ouest pour moi c'est incohérent mais
après bon il ya sûrement des raisons que
nous l'actionnaire ils l'estiment petit
plus pour lui parce qu'il a les pions
avant c'est justement et du coup il va
quand même être plus mobiles de la gagne
et je vois bien après la nuit l'arrivée
après il est clair que ce n'est
peut-être pas si facile que ça de
progresser parce qu'il ya des cadres
adieu 4 qui arrive cavaliers à six
cavaliers b4 peut-être pour pour faire
du mal aussi parce qu'attention ainsi
sur cavaliers à 6 je provoque à trois là
en deux coups avec b5 bi 4 ça peut très
vite s'envenimer de l'autre côté on
appelle ça kelly à 6 bon je me fais une
petite menace de k&b 4 si les blancs
jouent à 3 j'ai réussi à rapprocher le
point de percer ça c'est très important
à comprendre dans les rangs composé si
je rapproche le point de percer si je
vais jouer un coup de pions du rock
adverse vous pouvez normalement père
c'est beaucoup plus facilement avec vos
propres pions parce qu'il a avancé son
blog pions protecteur du roi tout
simplement et là vous pouvez le dégommer
facilement voilà l'histoire autour de
cette avancée du point de percée je
pense que ça se comprend alors que là
les blancs même s'ils ont gagné du temps
pour le faire ils ont déjà fait trois
coups quatre ou cinq coups pour attaquer
là ça va être très longue faire un deux
trois quatre cinq et en plus ils vous
seront peut-être donc ça sera peut-être
efficace tandis que si sûr car à 6 à 3
et est joué en deux coups je pers donc
ça peut vraiment accélérer les choses de
manière limpide bon et d'un match 3 été
joué au hockey hockey damage 3 il estime
que sa finale est meilleur ici visite il
a peut-être raison alors quand je vois
ça
je me dis que les noirs vont faire nul
centraux sans trop forcer
on va voir on va voir un souffle mais
moi cette position
c'est clair mais je vois bien nulle
arriver maintenant je vois bien à
champlan de jouer solide
et tenir tenir vis dit je sais pas ce
que tu en penses toi
moi je pense la pollution oui je pense
que c'est
assez fermé quand même un jeu je pense
adoré ce film à paris mais là est ce que
tu veux qu'on aille voir des partir de
l'existant ouais bah en fait depuis tout
à l'heure du beauf mamediarov je sais
pas si tu as été voir mais ça m'excite
pas ce que parce que forcément il
n'arrête pas d'en parler dans le chat et
merci à tous ceux qui s'investissent
pour nous dire quel parti allait voir
est ce qu'il y avait d'autres d'autres
choses je trouve que que du moment où on
va aller voir ma média offre juste pour
te pour annoncer que prada attaquons à
un front plus ça ça ne veut rien dire ça
veut rien dire est ce que tu veux aller
en train de me dire tu veux les voir
pris un nombre de la faisant non on ira
le voir après mais la pollution est
compliqué moi j'ai envie d'aller voir
alors tu m'as donné envie souffre on a
obligé d'aller voir ailleurs tout c'est
pas mûres que l'on pousse de l'histoire
ah ouais on était en train de rattraper
la donc voir la prime à nantes à face à
jiri
whip youtube mais un roi il sait pas
faire le petit rock
souffert ou la paperie enlevé de passer
la tour il a fait un demi petit rock il
a oublié de passer la tour bon attention
à les joueurs qu'on commente ils sont
vraiment exceptionnels bien meilleurs
que nous et jambette stouff parce que
prague d'ananda c'est une des pépites de
l'élite mondial de sa catégorie d'âge et
du coup c'est le poulain de stouff on
est quand même en
relative préfinale c'est à dire que il
ya quand même eu les dames d'échanger
une pièce mineurs d'échangés si d'autres
échanges devaient arriver on va dire
qu'il reste quatre pièces on parlera 3 4
pièces de prêt finale dès qu'il ya un
échange on rentre en préfinale double on
est en pré pré finale avec cinq pièces
sur l'échiquier voilà c'est compliqué
les échecs
ça veut dire quoi d'être prêt préfinale
en préfinale en finale ça veut dire
qu'on porte une attention toute
particulière sur structures et activités
donc placement des pièces et que les
rois petit à petit
peut-être des pièces à part entière et
que la sécurité des rois va de moins en
moins nous intéresser c'est pour ça
qu'il s'est permis prague nalanda
d'avoir un roi un peu olé olé attention
des france fait mater en finale mais on
peut plus se permettre d'avoir un roi
romantique c'est ce qu'il a obtenu là
avec son roi en g8
donc on voit que les blancs peuvent
récupérer le pion aux quatre un peu
quand ils veulent avec fu prendre le
cadre en quatre pour prendre quatre
messes à offrir loin la part de fouet
les cases blanches au f5 prime ce qui
serait pas forcément une bonne nouvelle
pour le pot au lait blanc
même fou aussi se fout des cinq
éléments d'accord avec toi as to face et
l'histoire sur le jeu de couleurs si
vous donnez votre fou d'une couleur
regardez bien après les casses comment
elles sont sur cette couleur là le fou
de cases blanches qui est donné ce tout
vient nous expliquer web hamon se prend
le fond f5 en russie ce dessin agression
tout ouvert donc ça fait peur
donc du coup c'était important de ne pas
se jeter son matériel la voie que vous
avez un bouton - année j'ai guéri avec
les blancs à sacrifier un pion pour
avoir de l'activité donc un con tre jeu
avec ses pièces avec la paire de fou
avec le fort cavagnan ou 5
sacrifier un pion c'est pas pour le
regagner dès qu'on peut quoi là par
exemple que sa griffe en option
maintenant on voit bien que les noirs ou
leur horaire de fou et le case blanche
et donc échanger un avantage contre un
autre avantage qui était le tube plus
pour ma part de tous les blancs ne sont
pas intéressés par saad et blanc veulent
continuer à faire améliorer la position
qui sera donc là attention la cavale et
prend
dès qu'elle avait dépensé 30 m gay qui
est menacée dont il y aura près ce qui
se passe ce qu'on peut faire est-ce que
c'est grave cavaler procès 3 ou est ce
qu'il faut le défendre parce qu'après
tout comme ses quatre des blancs
peut-être que je pourrai jouer un plan
avec base de ces cinq pourvois les cases
noires et fo f6 éventuellement d'avoir
ce qu'on peut faire
en est dans tous les cas on peut se dire
peut-être que les défendu pour l'instant
qui ont ces trois virtuellement par les
tactiques potentiel sur le four et 7 ce
qui peut nourrir c'est bon on on peut se
dire qu'on est plate assez tranquille de
ce point de vue là mais avoir une vision
encore mais c'est métro faire attention
parce qu'elle va dépenser 3 par exemple
qu'un valet processus je pourrais même
fougue sf6 pour attaquer aussi des
cadres la mémoire
mais je peux faire flipper l'on fait un
fou mais pensez à tous revus ouais ouais
là il ya beaucoup de choses je mange
matoub et blanche c'est 6 après y'a des
gars travers un conte ficelé ça va être
mais oui ça sent mauvais mais c'est
compliqué maintenant que tu entends dans
tous les cas ici il faut des réponses
concrètes de la niche parce qu'il ya des
faits avoir des menaces et prades allant
d'un niveau du calcul il est il est
hyper hyper bon donc 7 us un truc à
priori oui on va le voir en fait pour
nous tous c'est pas facile cette
position et je pense que demain on
pourra neiger guerry avait pas mal c'est
parce qu'elle est très déséquilibrée et
il ya plusieurs choix fou prend en
charge des tests comme comme choix mais
c'est un coup c'est un coût potentiel
parce qu'il aurait une avance de
développement ou pourquoi pas il ya un
coût qui donne quand même envie c'est g4
pour aller chercher
les problèmes c'est en tout cas c'est
dans cet état d'esprit que anish giri
doit jouer les coups comme g4 il doit
jouer de manière très ambitieuse qu'il a
un pion de moins il veut pas d échec le
long terme il veut une baston maintenant
ou alors ils jouent fou prend 1,4 pour
calmer un peu le jeu et
et profiter d'une avance développement
mais je pense que ça fera nul si fo
prend 1,4 franchement j'ai 4 5 ou un peu
excitant basée sur le fait que le chaos
régnant en l'air sur sur est franchie
vous voyez il ya double double pression
franchement j'ai quatre c'est hyper
excitant parce que j'ai ici
j'ai quatre c'est vraiment le coup et on
pourrait penser qu'il va le jouer je
pense pas qu'on puisse jouer j'ai quatre
cavaliers français 3 je le sens pas
réglé noire avec deux pièces en l'air le
roi un peu dégueu tactiquement on voyait
que des cahiers français six proposée
par stouffs a commencé à faire mal donc
je préfère quelque chose de ouais
j'aimerais bien voir g4 madani guéri
alors voilà le commentaire de galice
martyrisé donc je pense que tu dois
connaître
à la place de prague je ne serai pas
gravi pour l'adversaire met cette
politique thomas niche
mais est parti
moi je travaille ils vont devoir il il a
mangé le crash moi je serais assez
content de voir qu'il ya un peu en pls
aniche est
donc bon généralement contre des
adversaires et il se prend la tête comme
ça car se contentent us sata un peu
confiance je pense dans la partie donc
il ya eu il ya il faut croire qu'à 34
ans n'avait pas du tout pratique
maintenant la
bafouer f5 et bas après le roi noir est
encore en en g8 dont kaka maman de
développement il ya des problèmes je
suis entré qu'on peut trouver rapidement
mais si jamais à prague arrive à sortir
un peu de sa genre à jouer si je pouvais
jouer fouet f 5 h et 3 h 7 en un coup eh
ben je vais davantage
l'art est ton problème c'est le roi
j'aime ce qui est mal placé une paire de
talent de conteur la cause 2 et monsieur
c'est pénible aussi le tempo mais la
question c'est est ce que tu vas faire
parce que je refuse ce pacte à tout va
la mettre où se situe entre 4 à ce que
tu vas voir comment toujours parce que
moi surtout f4 je pense que je peux
jouer j'ai si souvent comme ça ouais
ouais ce que je vous aussi sous est-ce
que tu as eu à ce jeu x f6 c'est
compliqué comme position dans tous les
cas si jamais prague arrivent à se
sortir
de tout ça et ben ils auraient une
position assez confortable moi je pense
que ça va fermer cette position se
trouve que la paire de faux donc faux
avec 5 a été joué c'est tout à fait
légitime va compenser l avantage du roi
et de développement général d et des des
blancs ici donc du coup c'est quand même
c'est quand même vraiment
vraiment moins intéressant d'un coup
j'aurais bien aimé voir le coup j'ai 4
je suis un petit peu déçu donc tout rien
et maintenant on va se faire suer avec
cette partie c'est à peu près sur
monocycle déjà nuland ans est dans cette
position on verra tout à l'heure si j'ai
raison mais autant prime la honda je
pense qu'il avait chose tout à l'heure
et là maintenant le protégé de stuff va
faire une jolie nul avec les noirs le
vois comme ça est évidemment là ce qu'on
pense tout du coup sûr la partie que
vous avez tout à l'heure à paresser de
la media 9 pièces qui est partir en
cacahuète la partie la plus intéressante
aujourd'hui jusqu'à jusqu'à présent
même si on avait fait le tour des stades
maintenant qu'il ait fait le tour des
stades on va pouvoir faire des grands
formats et s'arrêtaient du coup de
mémoire stouff on s'est arrêté à eux
quatre fous e set je crois donc petit
rappel pour ceux qui n'ont pas vu le
début de partie c'était une sorte de
catalan après un début ce mislav donc en
tout cas une semi cela avec g3 qui est
une ligne très très marginale vous vous
regardez dans la base de données il ya
quand même assez peu de partis et du
coup c'est pas un système qu'on
recommande beaucoup donc dû bofa est du
leu leu travailler puisque c'est un très
fort théoricien
m'hamed a joué à six pour défendre v5
qui était en l'air dans cette position
je n'ai pas dit tout à l'heure que zulte
esprit je peux qu aucune seconde est ce
que tu peux admettre la caméra sur le
joueur allez soyons fous et c'est vrai
qu'il faut pas que j'oublie les caméras
réseau tester la technique voilà
il ya la technique agir en même temps et
les échecs c'est fou donc vous avez la
cam et vous voyez normalement maintenant
mam est d'arriver à l'écran et du coup
oui comme je le disais il y avait la
petite menace enfin la grosse menace
cavaliers prend b5 et on reste avec nos
deux pions pour il a donc fallait pas se
prendre qu'à elle promet 5 avec le fou
qui rayonne sur la tour donc il a
défendu son pion bessac et si on prend
ces six tout à l'heure j'ai dit c'est
pas grave y'a d'un v6 fou bessette à
suivre le fou va se mettre face à
l'autre fou et les noirs auront égaliser
à peu près cette ouverture petit rock
comme l'a dit stouff bam du boeuf est un
peu le même choix il veut pas reprendre
le pion tout de suite il préfère garder
l'initiative et surtout bessette il fait
le coup classique b3 pour
avoir de l'initiative reprendre de la
dame ou de la tour et avoir soit une
fine de deux pièces active il ouvre le
fou pour un fou à 3 ultérieure bon bref
ça joue mais mamediarov a posé une
question pratique il a dit ben moi je
m'installe avec bekaert c3 un énorme
pioncer 3 est maintenant prouve moi que
tu as essayé l'initiative contre ce pion
ben qui est hyper fort c'est un éléphant
à deux cases de la dame là pour plus
tard donc maintenant soit du boeuf il
gagne la partie dans les 15-20 prochain
coup arrive à prouver quelque chose soit
huppert et apparemment on a parlé de
l'évaluation dans le tchat apparemment
ça s'est mal passé k et ses 4 c'est bien
ils pressent à eghezée pièce
à 5 à 3 ils essaient d'ouvrir la
position x 6 mai mamediarov reste à la
fois solide et actif au f4 fou b5 et on
s'était arrêté après eux quatre qui
étaient assez étonnant de bloquer le fou
souffle je sais pas trop quelle était
l'idée derrière de secouer 4 ce que je
pense et un coup qu'on ne fait pas tout
de suite
on garde pour le four qui veut prendre
centre ça mais le fou est un petit peu
un petit peu triste 4 way et comme on
parlait tout à l'heure 4 e 5 y aura
cavaliers des cinq sur la belle case
voilà voilà toute l'histoire et
maintenant on va commencer à regarder
cette partie donc fuglseth mamediarov
joue sa carte c'est à dire il veut juste
rock et jouer simple
et dire j'ai un regret c'est ton pions
et à que dalle
voilà ce qui lui dit donc le défi
maintenant c'est de trouver des choses
concrètes avec les blancs et c'est là
que ça commence
cavalli abc ce qui est logique en terme
de philosophie mais c'est un coup très
risqué donc philosophie qu'est ce que
j'entends par là bas c'est la taca on
voit qu'il essaye de jouer dynamique
avec les blancs mais je comprends pas
trop le coup au sens la torah 6
le cavalier d'enfermer il a en février à
kaboul ou à quatre voies la meilleur des
cas qu'à toulouse vous au site en terme
et donc du coup on va trop seul à des
échanges
c'est ce qu'il avait prévu en fait à 4
pas le choix parce que comme 10 toof
soit je reviens mais bon j'ai pas envie
de revenir
soit je joue à quatre pour me venger dr
prend b6 et c'est juste un super oui
c'est même pas un sacrifice à ce que sur
cavaliers pro b 6 il ya foot.fr donc du
coup on peut comprendre apprendre b5
et ben là il va pas donner sa tour ya
pas de raison de donner la qualité
donc il a fait tout reprendre et 5 dont
finalement
là si je fais le compte ben je viens de
gagner la paire de food et noir c'est
très bien mais je viens de donner un
deuxième puis un
deuxième qui est évidemment plus
mais qu'est-ce que j'ai alors j'ai des
belles pièces avec les blancs mais par
contre la majorité 3 contre 1 ici elle
fait ultra peur sur le long terme
ou alors faut des éléments concrets
ainsi si vous voulez chez pas ça en fait
moi je manque d'idées ici pour justifier
la prise de décision
les cases blanches après un coup comme 5
seront assez ouverte pour le fou j'ai 2
mai après cas et dessins que je tape sur
rien quoi il est sain que je bloque tout
est sur des cinq des 5 c'est contrôlé
par les deux pions sait si ceux-ci ce
cavalier si je donne des buts à tour
bessin le groupe des 5 des blancs se
contredire beaucoup trop de fois pour
les noirs non mais là
là on a l'impression de voir m contre
amateurs ou m contre super grand maître
et du beauf pourtant c'est un client
normalement mais il sort pas la partie
de sa vie en fait c'est un peu
contrariant parce qu'il a été hyper
ambitieux j'adore ça quand les joueurs
de dix paires niveaux sont pas sur la
réserve à jouer des trucs un peu plan
plan
il a été hyper ambitieux mais mymedia
enfants en fait en face dans l'ambition
c'est quelqu'un aussi qu'il est même
avec les noirs du coup ils se sont rendu
coup pour coup et c'est vrai que là du
bof je crois qu'il a
le schéma ce qu'il a voulu faire son
idée un peu créative de sa crise de
pions le premier pion ils pouvaient
l'envoyer mais après il a l'air d'avoir
été imprécis puis l'a donc tour à deux
petits rock prévu depuis un petit moment
depuis fou aux sept parmi elles on fait
jouer
dames 1
[Musique]
en cause les gars pions
la cavalière à 5 il a été mangé ce pion
et du coup ben il ya toujours deux pions
de moi un psy je prends à 5 et la
position en train de s'appauvrir un
petit peu
tour d un été joués c'était une idée
pour comment dirais-je active et non en
fait je pense que du boeuf si on arrive
à le détecteur ex toof du beau fils est
aperçu lui même qu'il était très mal ici
donc maintenant il choisi
d'essayer d'être le plus brouillon
possible d'essayer d'en fumer son
adversaire et d'arriver dans une
position complexe quitte à ce qu'elle
soit peut-être plus perdante dans un
certain sens mais que ça soit le
brouillard et damas sept cavaliers prend
1,5 ben voilà il joue sa carte il ya des
petites contrariétés il ya des cahiers
français 6 à regarder c'est pas si
facile peut-être que ça a joué pour
romain médias off
donc la position pour moi même si on
indiquait un +3 dans le tchat mais en
fait
ok je préfère jouer avec les noirs ça
sent qu'il n'y a pas assez pour deux
pions ça me paraît cher mais je trouve
quand même la position complexe sais pas
ce que tu en penses souffre mais j'ai
pas trop une vision en ordinateurs dans
cette position alors par défaut je vous
dis hein pour être tout à fait franc
j'ai le module qui a affiché j'enlève
est vrai bien d'ailleurs stouff mois le
module sur wii ouais je peux l'enlever
ouais c'est cool baldé moi je ne mets
pas tout le temps
comme ça ça évite de le regarder mais en
fait si je dois commenté donc là le
module il indiqué +35 ans jeanne enlever
un an maintenant et sans fil et donc
vous pouvez nous engueuler si on fait
des fautes là on verra pas règle avec le
module ne sera plus affichée on peut
leur mettre des fois par contre ça peut
être intéressant des fois le maître
ponctuellement une fois qu'on a réfléchi
humainement ça c'est génial de l'avoir
ça nous donne la solution assez vite et
on peut l'interpréter
mais en fait
ici en partie si j'avais cette position
et mènera je me dirais c'est chaud je
sais pas si toi stéphane tu trouves que
c'est évident pour les noirs mais
ok ce gros pions et j'espère franchement
scorpion est génial j'ai vu d'évaluation
à 3,50
en fait il ya du contrôle sur la colonne
à et sur le
vis-à-vis entre la table est un trader
donc la bouger la dame serait je pense
normal ici peut-être d'un v6 ou dame
mais je pense qu'il faut gérer la dame
cavale et progressistes sur une trop
grosse menace est en fait si on arrive à
calmer le jeu et changer des pièces les
versions d'ailleurs j'ai influencé 3g la
prime plus
complètement d'accord avec toi stéphane
et en plus ce qu'est ce qui se passe
dans cette position est en fait je viens
de comprendre un truc c'est que par
contre on vous laisse la jauge de court
même si on n'a pas les variantes on se
rend compte quand même des trucs il ya
toujours cette problématique là donc ce
n'était pas non plus infaillibles ma
solution de d'enlever d'enlever les
variantes tout ça pour vous dire quoi
que cette position oui je pense je pense
très bien comme souffre à un coup comme
comme d'un v6 et on a et je me dis on
n'a plus un c'est à dire que je pense
que ici pour moi deux pions avance et
les blancs on l'activité donc ça qu'on
pense et je sais que leur dit qu il
proposait un coup comme fou c5 qui est
quand même hyper difficile à jouer
danse est dans cette position
c'est pas naturellement peut-être enfin
les coups comme ça m'avait diaraf il est
capable d'en trouver un mais
c'est quand même c'est que c'est quand
même des coûts qui sont difficiles donc
en tout cas là je pense que du beau fils
a quand même pas mal raté sa partie
néanmoins mamediarov et reptiles quand
même pour pouvoir jouer très très vite
et il a 24 minutes autant donc assister
si limpide que ça il aurait une heure
quoi donc du box il fait pas la partie
parfaite mais il pose quand même des
soucis pratique donc c'est loin d'être
fait cette partie c'est c'est rigolo
comme tout et franchement ça fait
plaisir quand même de cette ambition
après c'est pas facile en ronde d'un
tournoi même pour des joueurs de très
haut niveau d'être chaud et tout envoyer
directement c'est ce qui est en train de
se passer donc on va voir on va voir ce
que ça va donner
mais pour l'instant les parties les plus
intéressantes je pense que c'est
justement giry prennent nanda
boyarka google cars l'ecdc penneteau qui
font nul vous allez voir première nul
des répliques ou et je vous rappelle que
ça va a été annoncé très très vite voilà
il est mon goût on avait senti floué
arriver s'ils changent on retire ce
qu'on a dit tac je vais vous mettre des
petites calmes
ça peut être bon voilà que j'apprenne
beckham parker
[Rires]
seuil un petit alors on était resté on
était en hausse et une des parties qu'on
a regardé en premier voire la première
et sur la semi slave mise en place par
magnus carlsen et si penco avait joué
lentilles mais rang avec dams et 2 puis
b3 four b2 le truc le plus plan-plan
possible il annonçait qu'il allait
peut-être tester un petit truc et après
faire
peut-être faire nul sicard assène
répondait bien c'est un peu ça ça paraît
un peu présomptueux pour un joueur à
2700 contre le numéro un mondial un de
se dire que ça permet de facilement et
de carlson a va jouer 1
finalement je spoile oui
voilà alors il a perdu l'année dernière
contre issy tengo bas il veut se refaire
il veut s'allier est il un avantage
autant en plus mais si vous voulez
normalement dans ce genre de début quand
les blancs décide de jouer solide même
pour 400 c'est difficile de gagner alors
là où il attendait équilibrer la
position les joueurs parlent donc en
fait il ya eu 15 mai 2006 alors c'est
assez bizarre
avant de battre les world qui l'a voulu
analyser et il a joué un coup mais ce
n'est pas le coût qui voudraient mais de
toute façon ce qui s'est passé c'est
toujours normal c'est à dire que bon
c'est première ronde les joueurs bougent
le plus solide possible ok mais il met
juste les pieds sur les bonnes cases
alors pourquoi je dis ça parce qu'il a
il a fait son développement de pièces
mineurs et mais les deux tours sur les
colonnes qui vont s'ouvrir un ici c'est
ici que ça se passe donc il se passe
rien
et maintenant ils essaient de travailler
un peu la position pour voir s'il va
obtenir quelque chose mais elle a déjà
vingt minutes pour jouer des princes et
5 alors qu'il n'était pas encore si si
bien préparée up cavalli ac a dit il
c'est vraiment pas passé grand chose
donc tour c'est celle
magnus il anticipe le tueur mal placé
non mais en fait que le problème de
carlson c'est qu'en fait il ya beaucoup
de joueurs en fait qui le craignent et
du coup les joueurs ne sortent pas les
grosses parties contre lui parce que ben
carcelle c40 scène son tour du monde
parce qu'ils sont mais après ça veut
dire qu'on peut faire tous ces noirs
alors c'est pas ça il y en a qui vont te
restait quelque chose mais en tout cas
vague les noirs faire nul pour lui ça
peut jouer le tournoi aimé blanc quoi
donc c'est bien aussi mais regarde ouais
mais regarde un joueur à 2710
bas
blancs noirs et les comprendre quand un
gars qu'on regarde c'est bien sûr je
garde
mon temps un petit peu avec les bleus tu
vois mais l'aura des parties un pont
jouer mais c'est vrai que là
c'est bon c'est 2007 tu fais ton talent
détenus en plus la première oui c'est ça
le complexe faisait que ba très vite
j'avais annoncé souvent voyant ça que
salle est le truc le traquenard entre
guillemets et on a dit pas une partie
très intéressante on a dit pareil de
caruana car yakine on s'était dit
peut-être peut-être que ça irait pas
loin
voilà en tout cas malgré la différence
de niveau on avait senti que le choix
blanc s'était déjà presque une une
proposition nul un peu caché quoi
alors des fois on a des surprises mais
sa santé oui faire nul contre carsen
c'est super c'est ce que messi et cie
penco qui est si fort si prometteur
s'est dit et
pour les échecs c'est un peu embêtant ce
côté nul sans réels combats mais on peut
le comprendre il joue le numéro un
mondial ils se rassurent directement
il a plu à jouer car ce n y aura pas de
revanche avec couleurs inversées
donc c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas un
très mauvais résultat c'est parce qu'on
dit mais son tournoi et si penco et à
karlsson leur tournoi ils commencent
demain quoi voilà tout simplement et si
bien qu il a engrangé une belle nul
contre le numéro un mondial enfin une
nul contre le numéro un mondial
maintenant on préfère les parties de
combat
en tout cas oui
la montagne a accouché d'une souris
voilà c'est ce qu'on dit dans ces cas là
et on va aller voir fabiano et sergei où
il ya une autre exposition
parce que c'était soporifique tout à
l'heure
c'est c'est pas là c'est pas soporifique
c'est stratégique mais c'est c'est pas
la plus rigolote dépôt des partis dans
le gave à lyon le 5 qui joua un job
important
en tapant option c6 et le pion à 3 et 4
qui arrive et on attend votre action en
bessin pour la structure gorge
attaques de minorités ici avec le centre
bouclé on peut imaginer aussi la taxe
des deux côtés
ouais parce que souvent ce qu'on dit
c'est qu'il faut deux foyers pour faire
tergiverser la défense pour pour faire
plier la défense que si j'attaque que
sur ce pion c6 comme 10 toof elle et
noir vont se poster on voit qu'ils vont
se poster par rapport à ça donc
peut-être la taxe des deux côtés un
moment ça pourrait être une solution
quoi en tout cas dans dans ce truc là
je pense michel naudy qu'il est il n'est
pas il est pas content parce que il
n'aime pas trop ce genre de nul je
comprends à michel est déçu parce que
c'est un passionné des chats qui voulait
une partie de combat de gros combat
stéphane et du coup par rapport à ça je
comprends michel que tu sois déçu mais
c'est impossible aux échecs d'éviter les
nuls il n'y a pas de solution par
rapport à sa très clairement parce que
les joueurs peuvent même s'arranger et
caetera et qu'est ce que tu fais des
répétitions la victoire à trois points
ça existe aussi mais qu'est ce que tu
fais des vrais nul de combat donc pour
moi il faut faire avec mais c'est vrai
que plus à théories avancent plus les
joueurs sont bien préparés plus
l'annulaire difficile à éviter donc je
te laisserais nous donner des idées par
rapport à ça dans l'antre le chat on est
preneur mais pour l'instant pour moi en
tout cas je n'ai pas de jets pas de
bonne solution donc en tout après signe
un pressing dans cette position de quart
- là je crois qu on s'était quittés ici
et cariat qui n'avait le jouer le coup
logique fois 6e tout fin dans cette
position
avec les changes des pièces auxquelles
il a joué très vite b6 on se disait que
c'est si ça va être faible et ça ne
manque pas d'être vraie 1 voilà il
travaille il se met là au cas où comment
dirais-je cardiaque il voudrait se faire
ces 5 avec une structure de pions
pendant ou pions isoler qui arriverait
mais on peut pas le faire normalement
parce qu'il ya pas mal de pièces mineurs
d'échangé on n'a plus que deux cavaliers
donc c'est déconseillé d'affaiblir
soi-même sa structure avec des noirs
donc il préfère naviguer recycler ce
cavalier noir top h3 bon c'est un peu
hâtif mais pourquoi pas sans doute c'est
très très bien cavalier e5 est
maintenant pressing sur le pion c6 tous
de la partie bon ça va pas être très
rigolo mais il ya une position de
pressing il va tourner pour gagner
c'est exactement ce que cherche à faire
car voilà un goût nutrition tranquille
au
à 4 h théâtre proposée c'est normal
d'être sur les deux de front entre les
deux elle concentrait sur sur la dame
avec le cavalier lui des pions c6 et
c'est pour empêcher des 5 et les
bouquets n'en profitent pour jouer à 4 h
5 est attaqué de ce côté là
ce qu'on appelle on voit souvent dans
les commentaires de tournois qu'enfin
les récap qu'il y a des positions à deux
résultats typiquement on n'y est pas ce
que caruana maintenant car jaeckin et un
petit peu blessé et du coup il va
tourner autour et on va voir s'il va
réussir à finir ou non ça va être tout
l'enjeu de cette partie mais je ne pense
pas que car yakine soit content de son
ouverture on le sait si fort en théorie
que la avoir un bon - c'est pas c'est
pas agréable voilà du coup ok pour ok
pour ça ça te va tout et c'est ce que
vous allez voir un petit peu la partie
de la partie de ma candrian et ben
j'avais vu qu'il y avait eu la demande
dans le chat donc je comptais de la
relayer et du coup évidemment on va
aller se faire ça alors vous savez que
pour
que pour ça on n'aura pas la cam c'est
marrant j'avais laissé ma came la cam
avec les joueurs qui étaient partis
et voilà et je vais vous laisser la cam
entre
entre car jaeckin et
si je les trouve up de bella non pas du
tout voilà car yakine à l'écran pendant
pendant qu'on va voir marc andreu on va
voir l'échiquier de marque andrier en
tout cas voilà on y va directement sans
plus attendre
avec ah
c'est pas la même position que tout à
l'heure
pas du tout la même position tout à
oui alors là ont tout à l'heure on vous
dit
l'impression qu'il a qui n'a pas bien
géré
on était là oui on était même là tout
court après d'un processus fou e6 et on
disait que
cette position
on le voyait bien assez rapidement bah
potentiellement liquide et ça et ça pour
arriver dans une finale qui serait
légèrement difficile mais sans doute
nulle
le problème il ya quelque chose qu'on
doit éviter c'est la poussée du pion b
pour fixer notre faiblesse et je viens
de voir la position finale comme vous
fin finale
la position du direct et ça a bien
avancé
du coup ça c'est un peu dommage et sur
dame c'est ça qu'on pouvait pas ajuster
changé d'âme et met une tour en belgique
il n'a pas fait ce choix là en tout cas
mais ça semblait tentant
prise prise tour b8
salaires intéressants on va commander
depuis le début et c'est roke a
contribué c'est l'idée c'est intéressant
on voyait principe de liquidation qui
marchent souvent bien dans les positions
défensives
voilà dans les bonnes conditions mais là
du coup il a il a échangé je pense un
mauvaises conditions parce que je
vendais 5 il assez fort parce que prend
1,7 et est bien bloquée me fous eux 2d
sont bien b 5 points devant c'est
finalement fait il a une idée en fait je
pense qu'il a évidemment vu comme tout
le monde dans prend d'emprunt ces sacs
mais marc-andré il a une très jolie idée
s'est dit je fais dans bessette
j'attaque b3 et je fais tour ses huit
j'échange les enfin tu vois il s'est dit
ça pareil permanent ou et il a peut-être
oublié je ne sais pas je peux pas parler
à sa place il a peut-être oublié le coup
de gong ou lis que je voyais dans le
feuillet notation dam des cats il envoya
plus d'enfiler
et sur d'un prend b3 on l'a tous vu je
pense
hop guily le mat de l'escale d'un mois
attention tombé de la dame elle est
enfermée
j'ai plus de gaza et la face il est
possible de les rater ça ouais c'est pas
impossible en fait c'est hyper malin
parce qu'on est dans une position alors
marc andrieu mardi c'est c'est une brute
de tactique qui a pas de souci là-dessus
mais
le fait qu'il soit dans une position
qu'on pourrait qualifier de seiche c'est
à dire très stratégique il était
vraiment concentré sur la stratégie et
puis il mettait une petite tactique à
son adversaire avec tours s'est vite
potentiellement il voulait simplement
l'urgence de la position ses activités
tour ferme à l'option b 3 donc d'un bep
700 blessés et près santé tout ça est en
fait sur dame des cats ben il peut
encore jouer éventuellement tour c'est 8
à ban devrait même pas même pas en fait
ce que tous ces huit j'ai peut-être un
problème avec avec tours prend pas ça
commence à être les problèmes cette
position du coup il a joué d'un v6 pour
se refaire et dans dix ans bon ben ok
finalement je suis d'accord pour les
changer d'âme et là il s'est pris un
sale coup cb4 c'est un excellent coup
qui valorise le pion b
et après bessin il ya ce plan-là
qu'israël vraiment une faiblesse elle
qui ont des seins qui sera consolidée il
a décidé de jouer la finale mais
maintenant j'ai ça comme faiblesse
celui-là il dure à attaquer celui là je
peux le presser hague le fou par exemple
je peux aussi faire b5 pour fixer à 6
voilà la tourbe et 8b 5 et ben
maintenant tout à l'heure il a vraiment
une position
qui était proche à mon sens de l'égalité
et maintenant ça a l'air d'être vraiment
plus dur alors petit je sais pas s'il
n'a pas oublié dam des cats je sais pas
je sais pas ce que tu en penses tu es
fan tu lorsqu'il a dû rater dam des
quatre avec d'improbables trois robes et
deux parce que sinon ils auraient
directement jean ses 5 îles
je pense qu'il a voulu faire une
tactique mais qu'il a oublié la lui même
le plus tactique wayne contre pour une
contre pointe et ses lacs au service de
la stratégie c'est à dire que finalement
il n'y a pas une matériel deux parties
de perdus d'un côté ni de l'autre mais
il ya une amélioration des blancs alors
que c'est marc-andré initialement qu'il
voulait améliorer un petit peu sa
position avant de rentrer dans la finale
égale est en fait celle inverse qui
s'est produit c'est gong ou lee qui a
amélioré sa position avant de rentrer
dans une finale de pressing et là encore
c'est une position à deux résultats
marquants dry peut-être quand quand
souffrent il peut faire nul encore cette
position mais sachez-le maintenant il va
souffrir jusqu'à la fin très clairement
j'ai trois ou sept nains qui permet de
prendre un peu d'espacé à la loi permet
d'empêcher bas d'un couloir d'améliorer
aussi louangé 5ème 6ème
et après alors que mon coeur tu n'es pas
de pulsions de dessins ainsi
changer ça qu'il a voulu se prémunir du
f4 ou du h4 fin des prises des espaces
donc il prend l'espace en premier comme
dit stéphane avant que l'adversaire
camboulit prennent de l'espace et créer
un autre foyer à surveiller parce qu'il
aura déjà assez de travail marc-andré
avec ses deux faiblesses là très
clairement il va souffrir dessus si en
plus il se passer un sale truc à
l'endroit ça ferait trop de choses à
surveiller
mais d'ailleurs c'est vrai je me pose
quand même une question est ce qu'il
aura pas ce plan là franchement c'est il
faut faire très attention à ce plan f4
f5
à tour ses 5 qui défend à la fois c'est
parce que c'est une faiblesse quand même
ce pion schtroumpfs là en bleu mais je
peux aussi tu es ma tour ans et cinq
étapes et la faiblesse noir et celle là
elle est très très dangereux faiblesse
parce que je peux avoir des v6 sont
d'ailleurs il ya bien un coup de moyens
de prendre vraiment
l'avantagé que blanc et toi de la paix
soit 7 pour ses 55 s4 s5
c'est difficile et du roi danse c'est
honnêtement j'étais assez confiant
voyant la position tout à l'heure et il
ya eu clairement une imprécision alors
que la partie était vraiment il faisait
une partie quasiment parfaite ou en
bolivie une partie propre sans prise de
risque avec les blancs et on voyait bien
la partie s'est terminée par la nulle
maintenant j'ai plus du tout le même
discours je change un petit peu
et malheureusement d'un autre joueur
français qui en difficulté dans cette
position qui va qui va se prendre un
pressing pendant longtemps et est ce que
tu te rappelles de la cadence parce
qu'on n'a pas cité jusqu'à présent
c'est vrai qu'elle est vraiment longue
mais je les plains dieu non je n'ai pas
non plus mais je vais te dire ça je vais
je vais rechercher
dire ça en quelques secondes
une seat comment dirais-je possibilité
pour éviter les nuls ce serait un 5/7 de
match de 30 minutes chacun bon ça
pourrait être un 3,7 au 6 impasse que 30
minutes chacun c'est déjà beaucoup mais
à titre personnel battu c'est bien
michel que moi je préfère le jeu en lan
pour la qualité de jeu les ce que tu
proposes c'est ça récompenserait
vraiment les joueurs de rapides alors on
a vu que magnus carlsen se débrouille
très bien en rapide mais on a vu à
busato rohff qui était comme un outsider
même s'il est très doux et cetera gagner
le championnat rapide il ya quand même
beaucoup plus de variance et moi je veux
encore des matchs l'an c'est ça qui est
un peu difficile voilà donc ok du coup
je propose de passer au tournoi au dirt
3 on va moi je te propose de l'or je
vais je vais vous donner la la cadence
était à partir en pause oui ce sera une
petite pause petite pause publicitaire
de pause toutes les heures à peu près
c'est ce qu'on a quand on a mis deux
minutes
alors donc la cadence à l'est de 1h40
pour 40 coups
ensuite au 40e coup on va avoir 50
minutes bras joue pour 20 coups et
ensuite on va avoir 15 minutes pour le
reste de la partie avec à chaque fois 30
secondes par l'épidémie donc c'est très
très plaisant voilà c'est décadence
un peu désuète maintenant puisque on
prône le jeu rapide vous avez vu par
contre quand je pars du monde qui
opposait nepomniachi karl scène que la
cadence était à peu près du même acabit
âge et plus exactement en tête la
cadence mais peu importe c'était à peu
près pareil et à titre perso je suis
pour c'est à dire que
pour moi le vrai jeu c'est le lan même
si j'adore avec stouff commenté le
rapide l'autre fois on s'est bien marré
mais le vrai jeu
les conceptions films se font en jeu
lent et du coup si les joueurs acceptent
de venir à ces tournants en jeu lancé
qu'ils y croient aussi à mon sens en
tout cas la majorité d'entre eux est du
coup moi je suis bien content pour la
qualité de jeu proposée que kylie encore
ces tournois à ses 14 à
donc sur ce on va passer une petite page
de pub les gars et on se revoit d'ici
quelques minutes donc restez connectés
c'est moi qui vais mettre la pub et ça
promet et voilà ça arrive tout de suite
la pub et on vous dit on vous dis à très
très très très bientôt
et que j'arrive à trouver à trouver
aller à tout de suite
et on est reparti vous le voyez se
trouve ne vous inquiétez pas pour lui il
n'est pas parti longtemps tout va bien
mais c'est la batterie qui faisait des
siennes donc comme vous le voyez on
était en train de parler de la position
de marc andré madrid 6 qui était en
légère difficulté 1 c'est ce qu'on avait
dit tous ensemble dans cette position et
ont suivi les coûts tour 8es tour e1 et
du coup ben il va pouvoir s'amuser gong
au lit à faire tourner bourrique
et tournez manège aussi bain
et faire souffrir marc andré m'aurait
dit puisqu'il peut balancer après la
tour en 1 5 traille et le pion g5 trail
pions des cinqueterre tour c5 re
naviguer revenir ici bref il va le faire
tourner dans le tous les sens et j'ai vu
par rapport à la question qu'on se
posait sur les cadences la proposition
de faire d'une heure trente plus 30 mais
qu'est ce qu'on ferait dans ce cas là
deux matches de 1h30 plus trente trois
matches en une heure trente plus 30
c'est pas facile hein je trouve que ça
ferait ça ferait du coup plusieurs
matches dans une même journée c'est
toujours beaucoup même pour des joueurs
de très haut niveau donc avoir pour
l'instant j'ai pas trouvé de solution
pour éviter les nuls parce que c'était
la question initiale qui était posée on
va retourner maintenant dans le dans le
tournoi a tranquillement et on va vous
mettre des partis qui en voit à l'écran
vous voyez du beauf et mamediarov et du
coup on va aller se faire plaisir avec
avec eux et on va retourner sur sur la
partie
la plus marquante sans doute et du coup
on vous rappelle que magnus carlsen a
déjà fait nul puisque comment dirais-je
son adversaire et si penco avec les
coûts la couleur blanche avait choisi un
début assez modeste et du coup ben il a
et là du coup jouer normalement magnus
mais il n'a pas pu non plus faire des
miracles et je pense que pour une
première ronde avec les noirs étaient
relativement satisfait de ça s'annule
sans trembler tout à l'heure on était
dans cette situation là on voyait
mamediarov il avait 25 30 minutes du
beauf un peu plus de temps de lui et je
me rappelle c'était à ce moment-là qu'on
qu'on a arrêté de comment dirais-je de
mettre l'ordinateur on en est sans fil
et on ne voit plus ce qui se passe et ce
qui est assez assez rigolo c'est que
dans cette
dans cette situation l'ordinateur
préconisait fous ces 5 qui a été trouvé
par madoff et sur cahier prononcé six
fours en f2 foot pro f 2 c'est très
simple à comprendre
en cas de 2e tour premier f2 on voit la
petite astuce dame prend un toc
tour prend 1 et simplement cahiers
français 6 on le rappelle marie diouf
dans cette position il aurait eu deux
pions de plus parce que dans cette
situation après calais promotion qu'il
avait déjà deux pions de plus donc sur
fous ces cinq cas les français si ce fou
preuve de toujours de pions de plus
roy h1 c'est le bon coup joué par
par son adversaire par du boeuf et
maintenant d'un b 6 ça me paraît tout ça
me paraît fort logique en fait il n'y a
pas de pas de souci par rapport à ça
puisque
c'est normal que du boeuf essaie de
garder un maximum de pièces c'est
vraiment ce qu'on avait dit et du coup
alors maintenant ce qu'il faut expliquer
il ya le cavalier c6 qui en l'air mais
j'ai mon cavalier b8 moi-même qui
qu'il est aussi donc là il ya un petit
peu de calcul à mettre en place dans
cette position puisque peut imaginer que
le cavalier qui prendrait en fait en b
8e peu fou prend b8 on voit déjà que
c'est pas forcément un coup incroyable
même d'un français six doigts doit
suffire le le fourbe évident clignote
toujours dont un coup logique serait
clairement les 1er et 8 mai il a prévu
2,5 fois semblablement le fouet f4 à
quelques arrêts les v8 aussi don qu'il
se vengerait donc la marée diaraf dans
cette position je crois qu'il a vraiment
deux pions de plus net il ya une perte
de fou qui traîne pour les blancs mais
quand lui qui traîne on voit que c'est
pas dingue puisque le fou j'ai deux et
pas incroyable le faux skt vraiment
meilleurs mais j'en ai un aussi de foot
cases noires donc c'est moins grave mais
est ce qui devrait être
important c'est pas deux pions de moi
c'est surtout ce gros cube - qui compte
et il va être toujours dangereux dans
toutes les positions
donc c'est fou prend b8 qui a été joué
bon il n'y a pas de ya pas de gros
risques donc maintenant faut calculer un
petit peu
mais j'avais annoncé vraisemblablement
d'un francis qui attaquent le fourbe et
8 ça part et ça paraît assez simple
comme coup j'ai mon fouet f2 évidemment
en l'air mais lui à son fouquet 8 en
l'air se doit suivre dire il doit y
avoir plusieurs coups plusieurs coups
potable ça sent coucou stouff tout fait
à nouveau parmi nous tous et je suis
désolé désolé que
ça va le faire et du coup on est reparti
on était en train de regarder la partie
mme marie diaraf stouffer c'est vrai que
j'étais en train de dire que tout à
l'heure on crée on enlevait le redis on
était dans cette position là et c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment assez rigolo ce
qui s'est passé puisque dans cette
situation lors dit préconiser faisait 5
trouvé par meyerhoff évidemment j'ai
envie de dire stouff et du coup il ya eu
qu'à les français s'ils font preuve de
gym à genève l'astuce était surtout
reprend f2 dame prend 1 avec le fait de
relais pour 6,6 tranquille d'options de
plus finale gagnante et c'était réglé
donc du beauf qui est pourri par des
sculptures tourcoing f2 d'impro 1 j'ai
pas cavalier cet interne et bien si tu
as raison que j'ai pas citer que j'ai
pas cité mais le carrier toujours
enfermés en fait donc c'est même
peut-être pas grave non plus surtout
reprend f2 si tu veux pour jouer quelque
chose de plus simple jeu qu'avait
processes direct et pas me faire suer
cesson - mieux parce que dans l'autre
cas le kavé il a enfermé gamme comprend
des 8 et qu'elle pourrait caser ceux qui
pensent qu'un réseau tu as raison tu as
raison heureusement réussi voilà dès que
que ce trophée me laisse en solo voyais
je propose une grosse saucisse voilà
c'était pour le tester évidemment à son
retour voir s'il n'était pas trop
fatigué vous voyez que un jour monsieur
choi s'accroche là il est là il est là
présent il des low cost et du coup
calcule tout à fait correctement donc
pas de souci là-dessus en tout cas on
voit que m'hamed il a une sacrée
positions et on était dans cet autre
solution on avait regardé fou prend 2,8
dans celle là aussi il y avait cavaliers
prend b8 sur lequel on avait statué
qu'il y avait eu cinq et du couffo prend
b8 a été joué comme je disais boys adam
france et 6 ont un coût et il faut
trouver quelque chose avec les blancs
bon il ya le fou noir en l'air contre ce
fou noir
tour des six ne change rien à la
situation le fou noir ou blanc reste en
l'air peut-être fou des six mais je
crois pas que ce soit possible issifou
des six oui par exemple ces deux
intermédiaires
bon il ya plein de coups comme ça enfin
ça va être dur on voit que sur food et 6
peut-être que je peux jouer
je ne sais pas j'ai beaucoup de coups en
fait mais ça veut pas ça veut pas être
une bonne position ici
on voit que le pion de pioncer comme je
le disais il est trop dangereux quoi
donc ça va toujours les problèmes
parfois s'en sortir non mais fou des six
après dans toutes les positions le pion
ce sera un problème c'est l'horreur
c'est pour ça que je dois je vais
finalement on doit s'amplifier avec les
noirs on voit encore dans les
applications
ok ben là on y est presque on est en
approche on approche à mon avis de la
fin
alors peut-être que une des idées s'ils
jouent un coup un peu neutre comme d'un
b 6 parce que dams et 5 il faut des 6
et 6 joug d'un v6 a peut-être x 7 pour
jouer à aligner ses gagner
est ok mais même dame 3 serait pas
ridicule mais je suis pas obligé jouer
d'un v6 vraisemblablement bonjour madame
ont lieu via l'allier casale dé 5,4 a
validé cinq soeurs coulin logique et là
je pense que du boeuf il a prévu
peut-être fou des six
on a toujours ses 2 qui a un coût a
analysé
mais là je pense qu'on est aux portes
aux portes du gain
dangeard légumes secondes sans prix
oui là c'est vraiment pas facile si vous
voulez pour
faut quand même trouver le dernier coup
la mamie york doit un petit peu
s'appliquer pour trouver la bonne suite
et
dans le calcul
normalement avec le pion en fait si vous
voulez je peux pas croire cette position
parce qu'on aura toujours une embrouille
avec ses deux c1 du coup il faut
calculer un petit peu stouff robot sky
des cinq je pense que c'est un coup
très raisonnable du coup ça paraît
solide
si je dis pas de bêtises je vois pas
beaucoup d'autres cook que fout des six
ça parce que là il faut calculer un
petit peu vous voyez que la position est
complexe le fou b8 et en l'air il ya pas
mal de choses en l'air donc là on est on
est dans le registre active d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure j'en ai profité pour
faire une erreur de calcul pour vous
montrer que ça arrivait très
régulièrement dans ce type de position
ou tout simplement parce que j'ai oublié
du coca vallée des singes food et 6 et
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on joue comme en
convertit
kg qu'une qualité en l'air donc
[Musique]
j'ai aussi un fou en l'air un ouais
ouais c'est ça je regardais des coups
comme ces deux
mais ces deux tours c'est un pour
l'instant
j'ai aussi pensé à coup comme camaïeu 4
pour défendre un peu les pièces tout de
suite vu qu'il y avait des repères qu'il
ait pas stable là maintenant ouais
barakat
par exemple aux caisses et tu manges tu
manges enfin vente d'un bien ce que
manger des 6 ab vite donc ça va mais ce
que je fous des six
je sais pas du tout à zéro et c'est
assez intéressant c'est bat à son psy
mamediarov plancher que c'est pas si
simple pour lui non plus sinon ils
débitent ray depuis tout à l'heure il
est très très sérieux dans son approche
de la partie
nous fait une grosse partie j'ai
l'impression bierhoff
[Musique]
oui comme en fait souvent second coup il
propose quatre
ces six cavaliers des sags ne marche pas
c'est à dire que cavalier e 4 c'est
quand même plus risqués comme coup tout
nous l'expliquent il dit que c'est les
moins stables quoi en fait c'est juste
c'est juste dur quoi juste dire comme
position non ça fait super peur
ouais j'ai hyper peur dans cette
position mais déjà il faut regarder km
et 5 fu des six pour l'instant j'ai pas
trouvé une suite si facile que ça
et il a joué cavalier e cards parce que
cahier des 5 c'était pas si facile quoi
peut-être que les deux marchent en fait
je pense
l'idée je pense c'est que toi tu voulais
faire quoi stéphane ici avec les règles
et blanc sur cavalier e 4 tu avais dit
quelque chose oui food et 6 quand même
c'est ça
ce que je disais de ces deux quand même
et stéphane m'a abandonné j'ai
l'impression
c'est fun m'abandonner je crois
je crois je crois que c'est c'est moins
limpide d'un coup
alors n'hésitez pas à me dire dans le
chat si tout le monde nous entend bien
alors
ouais
c'est gelé et on était juste sur
cavaliers eux quatre que stéphane
regarder à l'instant aïe aïe aïe pas de
chance
c'est terrible est ce que est ce que
stéphane va revenir avec nous
ce serait bien
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
peu importe on va regarder ce cavalier 4
et je suis sûr que stéphane on va le
retrouver prochainement pas de raison
tac tac tac
et oui stéphane est de retour parmi nous
avec avec donc ce coup cavaliers aux
cadres de demain milliards huf dans la
partie la plus intéressante de l'après
midi vraisemblablement
et sur cavaliers 4 n'a pas vu deux
coupes aussi pour pour l'adversaire
et
écoute tout toc
on est dans cette situation
assez difficile
alors
alors donc j'ai perdu j'ai perdu
stéphane
et stéphane heure de retour parmi nous
désolé je me protège sa connexion mon
téléphone et ça me plante tout le temps
là j'avoue chargé la taille est pas
atteint kg est pas ses fans pas de pas
de souci j'avais rechargé ma connexion
d'où ça venait j'étais un peu perdue
sans toi et du coup cavaliers leucate a
été a été jouée par maïoroff et oui oui
je viens parce
que sous des six se voyait pas comment
quand plus d'un but alors fou des six
j'avais une idée tout à l'heure à de
soumettre juste avant qu'il le joue ce
tc2
fouet trois sets de jeu c'est plus d un
et deux
[Musique]
oui
faut trois départs édicules non plus ses
deux fours trois ans parce que c'est
compliqué
au kef où des six
j'allais chez madame en mouvement
je criais partout donc voilà pour
l'instant on analyse correctement mais
c'est là que mamediarov va dévoiler ce
qu'il avait vu
quelle menace pour le média rohff
les shows de la position envoyée c'est
vraiment la partie la plus la plus
fantasque de l'aprem franchement c'est
hyper chaud
et la
la il semblerait
que ce soit pas si facile de trouver la
solution puisque on galère dans cette
position
donc ces deux jeux pour des f2 parce que
là skis et qu'est ce qui est réellement
en laye en fait chez noir il ya
peut-être donc stouff nous proposait
dame bien comme menace et la tour
et j'ai mon cavalier cloué et c'est pas
facile de
de l'enlever
qu'est ce qu'il a vu médias off on sent
que ça va pour les
il faut trouver
ouais
on fait pas les malins avec l'ordinateur
on sera meilleurs ça c'est sûr tour des
5 proposait sa rivale et irait jusqu'au
bout il faut en fait non
ouais mais cavalière dont on ne me l'a
jamais à cause de tout reprend
donc faut 3 il peut faire
[Musique]
il faut trois fois fuites ces deux
peut-être
voyez on commence à regarder des
variantes vraiment oui et fo 3 faut
regarder d'ambea
ton cou en fait parce que sur cavaliers
f2 j'ai toujours tout reprend f25 et
visqueux à la dame serait en l'air
mais il ya un coût qui est hyper bizarre
mais peut-être très fort
c'est tour des cinq d'or j'ai proposé
c'est vrai c'est sale et en fait mais si
je touche à rien bah moi pareil
je sais pas
par exemple comme à windham je peux
toujours bouffer en d1 moi je mangeais
la tour et fuse
à 81,5 tu peux toujours bouffer la tour
eiffel
oui mais alors est-ce que ces deux c'est
pas hyper fort
la position et c'est vraiment une
position de malades vous voyez que là
autant les positions plan plan on
arrivait à vous donner
les coûts est vraiment rapidement autant
là c'est hyper tendu et c'est tout autre
chose c'est une autre c'est une autre
école c'est vraiment une autre approche
est maintenant c'est que calculatoire
c'est calculatoire mais il ya toutes les
pièces en l'air des deux côtés voyez pas
ce que ont semblé noirs sont mieux
acception cessé mais doivent prouver ici
ils ont ça en l'air ça en l'air le laser
et ce en l'air donc voilà ça fait quand
même quatre pièces à surveiller en
contre ils ont le coup ces deux
mais ils ont ça ça à défendre urgemment
et il ya aussi d'un bien kim qui
menacent quoi donc ces deux serait assez
logique mais j'ai pas trouvé sur tours
c'est à comment faire pour l'instant de
de vraiment stable
non c'est durant c'est à dire mais les
hyper intéressant ma position
ces deux
tours c'est un
l'embêter pour savoir mais on n'est pas
les seuls puisque mahdia au fil à moins
de cinq minutes je préfére être dans mon
fauteuil parce que je suis là il n'a pas
de problème enfin l'huile à tous les
problèmes moi j'ai pas de problème si je
donne une pièce c'est pas grave c'est
souffre qui rigole
problème c'est que lui mamediarov il met
en jeu la partie s'il se trompe donc
attention
dur dur
dur dur est-ce qu'on reste voir ce i'm
not ont fait un petit tour des stades je
pense tout bas van den est ce qu'il ya
une partie qui intéresse moi ce que je
peux te dire que j'ai un petit peu
regardé
bon prince a fait un nul je pense
pas dessus hop je mets la casse ou
encore s intéressant à wil a
effectivement c'est vraiment nul puisque
tours 5 contre tours 5 on peut dire que
ça va faire une prochainement allez on
va dire ça
donc qui on peut aller voir autrement
vannes le reste contre grande elle use
[Musique]
up donc au niveau caméra j'ai pas fait
trop de progrès en cours de
jeu j'ai tout fait j'ai raté ou quoi
quelle quelle horreur
son parti ait été là je suis passé
devant je passais leur dire bonjour et
voilà
ah oui très intéressant incroyable
alors du coup on a une position encore
très déséquilibrée on vous le rappelle
deux pions plus pour pour vendre forest
mais un jeu de pièces défaillant une
paire de fous très active pour pour son
adversaire grand des lieux et il n'a pas
réussi
à pousser ses pions
j'adorais sa position tout à l'heure
et maintenant je vois la passivité la
passivité des pièces blanches et
cavaliers les tours et noir dessous très
forte et pion qui avance mais les pions
blancs qui peut aussi avancer que tu
vois que là les pions blancs ont fait
plus de mal à avancer grâce à la part de
fous pareils
alors on s'était quitté la à tour prend
1,4 j'avais proposé qu'ils avaient des 5
il a préféré qu'à valider un je vous
rappelle que c'était une des
propositions de nos ordinateurs
tour b 4
c'est logique hein c'était pour protéger
juste le pian 2 4 à 4 ans qu'est qui
semble logique pour pour tenir les pions
et des cinq là on vous l'avait dit à
qu'une des clés c'était de faire sauter
le verrou on peut même se demander si
dans cette position il n'aurait pas dû
plutôt jouer cavalier c3 avec les blancs
quitte à lâcher b2 et se dire j'ai déjà
non pas répondre plus mais une bonne
position pour avancer après les pions
c'est intéressant je pense mais il a
préféré garder son avantage matériel et
sur des cinq dames des deux dames des
ciseaux qui se passera et ça y est le
joueur blanc est obligé d'ouvrir la
position on avait dit que c'était une
des clés
ce tout fin de
d'activer la paire de fou et c'est ce
que grande russe a réussi à faire de
façon assez magistrale ok d'un prend 1,6
mais il s'en fichait grande et lui ce
qu'il voulait la bagarre et la bagarre
bas elle commence à avoir lieu la
position et on a plein les yeux elle
n'est pas facile à comprendre cavaliers
le 2 fou prend des 5
es là faut essayer de se libérer et
visiblement il n'a pas réussi à le faire
et sa position est en train de
s'écrouler tour trois fous des cartes
c'est plutôt al'avantage des noirs j'ai
l'impression suivi de f5 la tour s'est
mise en a trois tout à l'heure je
préfère jouer et blanc maintenant j'en
réfère à chaud avec les noirs très
clairement clair bon tu vois tout à
l'heure on en parlait en tout cas
portant que sur les noirs seraient un
couple core
mais dans la pollution ici et laurent
deux pions deux mois
sous prend b2 ça récupère un pion ce
qu'on veut avec cavaler prendre prend b2
mais je râle trois points seulement
derrière et ce qu'ils font contre ogeu
c'est vraiment la paire de flou et la
force des fous ensemble en fait tous les
chéquiers donc j'ai pas du tout envie
d'aller chercher un petit pion comme ça
je préfère clairement joué l'initiative
et jeux pour l'attak donc là je pense
que des plans qui pourraient avoir lieu
dans un parc qui serait roi f7
soit prospère tu as toi rage suite des
fois ça peut être intéressant ou sinon
clairement de pousser f4 et de trois
mais la russie est intéressant et c'est
tout c'est des pions et provoquer des
choses
mais on n'est pas là pour aller manger
un petit pion mais là vraiment pour
provoquer plus que ça non mais c'est
hyper c'est hyper intéressant et
ça semble vraiment plus agréable à jouer
d'un côté que de l'autre on a vraiment
envie de se mettre du côté noir on a
l'air d'avoir pas mal d'idées et avec
les blancs
c'est d'amener le pion à dame mais le
problème c'est comment on fait quoi si
je fais à cinq je me prends tout
reprendre et 5 à 6m bloqué avec fou à
sept îles mais deux tours sont mortes
derrière et en plus une fois que je
perds ça il peut mettre l'autre tour là
je commence à me refais de ce côté là
donc c'est vraiment dur et
sur le g3 on voit grandir ou sajoo et g5
tempo
cavaliers 3 tempo ça commence à envoyer
ce qu'on va voir le simple
faut aussi ce pour faire f
4k et ses yeux qui menacent attention il
ya aussi le pion b2 en l'air va ça y est
c'est sexy de partout mais attention que
la table de mal tourner un
aussi maintenant des cavaliers de troie
parce que si je mange si je suis fou
aussi
canaliser de la romancière et sur le
vous prend b3 faux promet de pardon
à quel moment maintenant à la place de
folie sur cavaliers 3 fou prend b2
qu'elle allait prendre des cinq
peut-être un fo prend à trois
jeux pour enfants
dès 4 et je garde a laissé 4 et alpes
yankee est très dangereux
en fait sur le terrain pions mais ça me
laisse un peu ronde avait
tout à fait du coup est-ce que je joue
un coup comme fou prend 1,3 qui est qui
est acceptable aussi parce que faut
aussi cela problématique c'est que il
faut calculer cavaliers ces deux
noms sur qu'à leur portée et il ya
encore tour prend b2
année je prends des quatre de la même
histoire voyait ce pion mais il ya quand
même ce serait dommage pouvoir perdre
leur part de fou et l'a peut-être que le
pion maintenant à serait comme le disent
tous fait une une opportunité énorme
et 6 août auprès de l'uci tombé de tu me
mange des cinq je mange des deux vues
dans la pression sur le clan f2 et ce
qu'avaient les 3 4 comme ça
c'est vraiment bien c'est dans l'esprit
donc tu veux faire tout reprendre et de
cavaliers des sacs aminé tour d2
et attaquer f2 et du coup pour attaquer
vous deux vous chat un jeu tout récent
c'est moche surtout reprends mes deux
pour l'instant je suis pas encore obligé
peut-être de prendre
je regardais tour des 1 il faut aussi
sans doute
du coup il ya plus qu avec ces deux
noms intéressants pour trouver de bons
partis très indécise en tout cas là
c'est chaud hein ça a commencé à
bastonner des deux côtés on est là on
est en plus dans les groseilles note il
reste dix coups de jets
avant
avant de récupérer le temps
est sympa est ce que on irait faire un
tour vite fait
pour voir où on est marquant dry qu'est
ce que t'en parler rapidement
je vous laisse du coup avec avec la même
avec la même gamme et on va voir dans le
challenger ce qui se passe
avec la partie de marc andré mary j
c'est toujours toujours toujours le
pressing qui continue mais voyez que on
s'y attendait donc il y avait eu on
était là à peu près tour 8 ou re ans
exactement la tour des huit a été joué
dans gaulle il a joué tout re 5 pour
mettre sa tour et après la jouer le plan
à 4 4
oui mais en deçà sont aussi attendait et
maintenant la position c'est vraiment
une position pour se faire presser f5
elle là je vais un peu vite parce qu'
il pouvait pas se garder pour plus tard
cette réaction ce que comme dans la
partie on a vu qu'ils avaient fait f6 ce
marc andry balle puis on se rassure
blanc donc peut-être qu'il aurait pu
attendre mais en tout cas quoi qu'il en
soit cette position elle est vraiment
elle est vraiment sous est très très
difficile
pour prendre un sac
c'est maintenant un pion de moins et
[Musique]
c'est
c'est quand même compliqué à tenir
heureusement que le puma f5 et sur blanc
ça fait partie des espoirs mais de leroy
un des six attendent un petit peu
je n'avais pas vu aussi ses fans il
reste cinq roues de grand grand âge note
pour pour ma crème à l'odeur
de la seconde à la fondue et voilà ils
jouent avec leur âge ou si vous voulez y
aura trente secondes par coup pendant
cinq cours ajouté et ensuite il récupéra
récupérera au 40e coup son rajouts mais
ce qui est un petit peu dommage c'est
que tout à l'heure ils avaient une
position
vraiment hyper sympa avec maintenant ça
c'est ça s'est vraiment dégradée alors
je me pose une question c'est comment
on
sort nos pièces que la la tour des 5es
les crèmes coincé et j'ai la pression
sur le pion b
voilà sur quoi joue marquant dream est
bon les blancs vont pouvoir mais leur
les haltes ex-couple attaquant
supplémentaire au combat ses jeux je
suis vraiment coincé tchèque - c'est
peut-être aussi un petit roi de cette
l'éveil ou une gueule set j'ai manqué du
coup mais je fasse ça mais
bizarrement oui puis sur x 8 pouvoir
mais j'ai toujours tour ses huit
éventuellement si besoin
mais bon quand il ya la pression sur b5
donc voilà ça c'est un plan dont akg toc
toc
je crois pas trop quand même et
on n'a pas trop le choix ici à
excitement barjots des cours
on se prendra tour
ok en tout cas la position vous voyez
elle est difficile il va il va tenter de
sauver
sa poésie mais
c'est quand même compliqué voilà il est
en difficulté et il est en train de se
faire travailler ne pas facile cette
première ronde du tata steel pour pour
marc landry les 20 premiers coups
étaient véritablement excellents et au
21e il a il a fait une imprécision et
depuis ce fameux 21e kubala position
s'est dégradée dégradé petit à petit
avec une belle présence technique de la
part de son adversaire et basse est en
train de deux vrilles et il a encore un
peu d'espoir mais ça va être quand même
très très compliqué voilà donc
[Musique]
donc du coup c'est c'est dur dur dur dur
donc on est parti
on est reparti on va envoyer
on va repartir dans le a et voir les i'm
not comment ça s'est passé pour
mamediarov sade va
stouff
ce qu'on va voir ce line up qui étaient
la partie la plus compliquée on rappelle
que magnus il a fait nul très rapidement
que prague d'ananda contre guiry ça
devrait être nulle et la voilà ça bien
vrille et c'est de plus en plus
compliqué on s'était quitté là et on se
posait la question de comment jouer dans
cette situation
sans froid ici de
deux mamediarov avec tour des huit ce
problème pour joe cada lieu 4 il faut le
faire perdre oui tour dehors confiance
nous ont proposé plus des solutions à
base de d'ambea mes tours 2 pourquoi pas
c'est un peu dans le même sens f5
avec l'idée que sur ce point m6 qui a
été jouée
en fait j'avais dix pires qui avait
sûrement le fout en l'air il a préféré
cesser de d'abord
f70 premier set
bon on voit que la jauge vous dis que ça
c'est complètement rééquilibrer dont la
position était vraiment hyper difficile
pour les deux joueurs y en a partout
voyez il ya il ya des pièces n'apporte
de non protégés deux partout ouais rayon
laser un pion qui pourrait la promotion
ça c'est non protégés ça s'est attaqué
ça c'est non protégés non protégés
emprise voyez c'est le bazar emprise
c'est pour ça qu'on n'y comprend rien et
là faut des capacités calculatoire
importante et en plus les joueurs sont
en deuil notes
acquises c'est un jeu très logique
fil rouge aujourd'hui des des partis
surtout rien qu'est ce qu'on fait on
joue je trouve qu'on décide peut-être ou
d'un projet 6 d'emprunt des six plus tôt
j'aurais fou prend 1,4
et dans le d r
non je serai pas à cause de tour aux
injures poor's
[Musique]
tonton raid salut à toi mais tu arrives
en arrive en pleine guerre plutôt un
parce que la cd i'm not c'est le moment
le plus intéressant général allemand
dans les parties donc
faut pas rater ce moment là et c'est
supra chaud
c'est d'ailleurs l'énorme pression
qui entourait fin ça c'est le coût
écologique et maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on joue avec baignoire
oui parce que vous voyez
des variantes comme ça un tour des six
que je peux faire tous rêvent de ou
boire
cavaliers f2
tous rêvent de jets madame en l'air mais
j'ai aussi les échecs pour aller à promo
c'est le
sait mal de cash là pour traiter cette
position toi stouff ils font du mal là
les joueurs insectes aiment bien ça
quand même le combat chaque thème bien
ça mais c'est vrai qu'il allait les
positions compliquées c'est clair mais
après là c'est vraiment compliqué la wes
est particulièrement compliqué ces
bordels
éduquer nos valises on va enlever un
calcul et 22 tours f1 a été joué
du coup une variante potentiels parmi
tant d'autres donc tour des six
ça semble logique de récupérer le matos
du coup on fait surtout rld et si j'ai
peut-être juste fou et 4
avec le fief de en l'air
ouais ça semble vraiment pas mal ça donc
déjà
tour des six jeux était de le jeter à la
poubelle
ouais et d'un prendre un peu la même
d'un prend on va proposer fouet 4 aussi
même s'il ya des dames d1 on n'y croit
pas des masses à cause de tous rêvent de
voilà tous rêvent de mêmes fous ces deux
derrière donc
médias il est en train de réfléchir
et la c2 est née il ya plus qu'une
minute 30 conte avec mamediarov trois
minutes
pour jouer le picou oui et puis faut
vraiment très grave il ya un presque
matelassé cavaliers projet
3h pranger troyes et tours h5 ça ça fait
maths sauf que bien sûr vous voyez tout
sur quelle étrange et royal où pranger 3
mais c'est pour dire à quel point la
position est tendue
donc c'est vraiment
le bazar total alors déjà il faut jouer
un coin là on est obligé
c'est pour ça que un monde du golf à
jouer f7 c'est pour attirer mon rang f7
qui se retrouvent en difficulté j'ai un
clouage en fait en fait il avait sur le
clouage du fou motivés et voudrait
récupérer le cavalier et le fou est en
fait c'est pour ça que je me posais la
question certes si on doit pas essayer
de dévier des tours en f1 jour avec un
petit coup sûr mais en
mai je sais pas trop ce genre genre
toujours c'est un c1 dames maintenant et
c'est peut-être le seul coup non tu
manges de la touche dans en d6
et il continue de kadhai et j'ai ton de
faire fou de coparent est de fédérer
parts égales cast secondes pour nogueira
je peux vous dire qu'il va bientôt jouer
pas une grosse info mais
je vais remettre d'ailleurs la cam je
pense que je vais pas mise mais
serait pas mal
toujours à la recherche de la cam ah bah
ça y est c'est vrai il discute
on n'aurait plus à remettre avant comme
ça il ya un peu de suspense est très fin
il a proposé nul
je ne sais pas
on n'a pas eu le fin mot de l'histoire
je pense pas qu'il soit tombé quand même
mois il à 0
merci pour le résultat
15 oh pardon
non mais
problème c'est qu'il n'ya pas de ta pas
vu 1 0 1
non je ne sais pas ce qu'il s'est basé à
maintenant josé
alors si je maintiens voir pour une fois
tricher sur l'ordi voit la c1 dames nuls
je pense que c'est ça tu vois c'est il a
peut-être vu et ils sont fous les mecs
dans ce cas la c1 dames sa venue le fort
c'est quasiment
fait l'aller les
noms
il ya eu nul 6 6 mois il a proposé nul
sur sa
fougue et
sa wii u to raison vous oui tour f1
propose nul quand il s'en est sorti du
boeuf il a proposé nul et c'est pour ça
que mario rafa temps réfléchi c'est
qu'il y avait une convention deux nuls
en cours et ça ne pouvait pas le deviner
évidemment et mamediarov a dû sentir
qu'ils valent et avait laissé parce
qu'il pouvait encore continuer cette
position mais il avait déjà et de
laisser échapper un gamin plus tôt avant
enfin une position très avantageuse que
gains c'est toujours facile à dire on
avait bien l'ordinateur était très
optimiste de bout en bout dans sa partie
mamediarov c'est un multiple champion du
monde jeunes qui à l eau presque
2806 ça a été hyper compliqué pour lui
et vous avez vu qu'un ex tout foncé on
s'est un peu plus tu quand il y avait
toutes les pièces en l'air parce que
c'est très facile de faire des gaffes et
nous en commentaires on peut on peut en
faire beaucoup d'égards c'est pas c'est
pas trop gênant
ce qu'on remet les pièces on dira masson
a gaffé mais euh bah ils doivent eux
juste jusqu'au bout et maintenant bon ça
a été la plus belle partie jusqu'à
présent je sais pas ce que tu en penses
souffle mais c'est parti c'est
évident c'est clair ok bon sens sans
plus attendre à les voir
allez voir
caruana a peut-être contrecarre ya qui
nous tous bouteille notre préférence
moi j'aimerais bien voir des clubs de
devant le fort est parce que ça doit
être la fin d'une finale qui a justement
il devait se rendre sur m
s'est passé des choses et ail ail ail
blanc en vrai la part de food et noir
aïe aïe aïe pourront pas ces cas
là il ya un gros problème
du coup je vais vous mettre la
cabine se taper juste c'est une des
premières fois souffert le métier rentre
là
du coup on est dans la situation où
il n'y a plus la paire de fou comme
disait comme disait souffre on va
regarder comment s'est passée à laurier
cavaliers le 3 le fameux
fou prend 1,3 puis on prend 1,3 donc il
a réussi grâce son cavalier ou trois
hyper dynamique a enlevé la paire de
faux s'il y avait autre chose qui
souffre qui vous faisaient surprendre
mais deux c'était hyper intéressant on
en avait parlé c'était ça semblait un
peu plus dynamique mon fou prend 1,3 et
des jouets f 33 tours prend b2 et
simplement cavaliers f1
bon et là le travail devait être de
jouer contre le pion à 4 qui était très
dangereux et là il a joué sous ses 4 et
après tour ces trois maillets le pion c7
et le pussycat
ça sent
truc bizarre un petit peu ce qu'il a
voulu faire grande et luce je pense
qu'il a je pense que il a vu sa coiffe
l'outil fous ces quatre ils voulaient
empêcher le pion à dame ans et un coupon
de 5 et en plus c'est de la case enfin
la commune ouvert pour la tournée le 8
mai ainsi que tous les trois ça c'est
chiant force à prendre une décision dapd
est oublié et d'atours séance est très
malin parce que sinon il ya eu froid il
faut que je puisse faire pour ces deux
doctorats 8 hockey tour ces deux quand
même tout reprend tout reprend
enfin
reprendre les fans tout prendre un thé
de cette tour est venu jusqu'à 25 ouais
ou tour c'est certain
et après je reviens rase tout venant
ouais j'aime bien tout est devenu le
chouchou de
plongée dans
un bol et 2 les deux doivent être
vraiment bien j'ai compris les deux
blousons très bien
le teil plus précises votre ordinateur
mais bon c'est pas c'est pas trop trop
grave c'est c'est eh oui les 2 sont bien
à la finale promettait d'être difficile
donc du coup c'est c'est quand même
ok du coup
alors on est dans cette situation là et
sur fouet f3 il a fait tour c4
et la grande et lieu il ya plus que ses
yeux pour pleurer parce qu'il a vraiment
un pion de moins en fait un gros point
noir même
le fou qu'est devenu mauvais en f3 pas
mauvais c'est pas grand chose et ce
jusqu'à la lie des cas la ligue 2 il va
revenir maintenant des 3 et 4 ça peut
être comme à quai il ya encore un petit
peu technique mais en fait il va sortir
son roi de l'étau après le cavalier lala
et
et là sera bon
s'il arrive à sortir de l'étau ce pion
là il va clignoter il va pas permettre à
la tour de s'activer très vite si on a
toujours désigné 2 à 5 à 6
il ya eu 3 e set
tour csn si tu veux aller voir quasiment
mercredi accueillir le qui vient de
perdre à main c'est
bon on commence à raison il est
malheureusement pour lui bon là il a
fait n'importe quoi en plus grand des
lieux là il a dû craquer je sais pas il
a donné un deuxième pion bon il veut
peut-être essayer de le contrer mais bon
ça paraît pas de la bonne solution alors
on est reparti
donc triste nouvelle pour notre seul
représentant tricolore
et du coup je vous laisse avec les
caméras on n'a pas les caméras du
challenger donc du coup
hop
on avait quitté marc-andré en difficulté
à peu près ici je pensais pas qu'il
allait perdre aussi vite qu'est ce qui
s'est passé tourbes et si l'on dénote
donc il faut qu'il joue vite roy g iii
roi hussein au f4 d'accord faut 8,1 des
plans qu'on préconise s a pas lieu ça
lui a pas porté bonheur à tour c'est un
tout
et il n'a pas voulu prendre le pion
bessac il a joué autour des 6 et il a
perdu tous les cinq avaient scandé
grosse gaffe parce que tours d'hélice
leroy et protège les deux pièces donc
tournage attaque les deux et suroît 17
bat je vais le tir et dans un sens et du
coup on pourra lui mange et on peut
comprendre on peut comprendre la gaffe
qu'il a fait de m il a plutôt incongru
et bien sûr il a jugé les faits non mais
s'inquiétait mauvais et diversité tout
court est un qui vous prendront tour
prend pour contre jeu à la faille à tour
c'est cette voie là il n'a pas voulu
jouer cette vie des gens perdus
je pense que les versions wii et des
changes
c'est son dernier espoir
roide et si je peux pas trop parce que
trois des six là je perds tous les pions
même peut-être tourasse est d'abord
way sans doute 3 il d'abord
donc du courreau à 8,1 pratiquer quand
trois sets
ça a l'air vraiment difficile de cette
position avec l'euro en fait il ya des
faiblesses un pion de plus et le roi qui
est coincé sur la dernière donc du coup
cette position là on peut avoir des
plans comme ça comme ça avec le roi qui
mal placé la poussée du psion ok c'était
c'était extrêmement difficile et surtout
100 ans
dommage on a vu tout à l'heure la la la
le moment clé de cette partie on vous le
rappelle il y avait fait vingt premiers
coups d'une extraordinaire qualité et
dans cette position qui allait tendre
vers la nul ils pouvaient échanger adam
ça semblait assez facile à préférer
fignoler amélioré avec dame bessette et
ses prix l'excellent d'amd 4 et à partir
de ce moment là il n'a pas réussi à se
relever puisqu'il a joué d'un v6
laissant bekaert bessin gré en fait il a
fait double faute 1 je pense que
le voilà il a regretté de pas y avoir
échangé dame et du coup il a essayé de
les échanger derrière mais les
conditions n'étaient plus les mêmes et
après b4 il s'est pris b5 fixation du
pion à 7 est dans cette position après
b5 fixation du pion à 7 et tour c5
fixation du pion des 5es attaque du pion
des 5 il a commencé à se faire tricoter
et ça a été extrêmement dur
dur quand même un souffle les échecs de
haut niveau on le voit il n'y a pas le
droit à l'erreur hulluch il a fait une
imprécision il a un peu perdu pied après
cette impression il en a fait une
deuxième derrière et ça y est
il était dans une position extrêmement
difficile il a essayé de
de prendre son temps et de réfléchir du
coup ça va amener à être un petit peu
imprécis quand il est en crise de temps
mais gang ou lille a fait une partie
très très sérieuse et profiter de
l'imprécision adverse mais s'en sort
bien parce qu' il n'était pas loin marc
andry bas demain il a
va dire qu'il va on imagine qu'il va
changer de couleur sauf si double mais
il devrait avoir des blancs et
marc-andré on l'avait vu il avait un
moral d'acier je me rappelle que c'est
pour sa troisième normes de grands
maîtres si je dis pas de bêtises qu'il
avait fait un départ vraiment pas
terrible pas terrible du tout pour lui
et après il avait enchaîné cinq
victoires je crois pour finir pour
refaire sa norme ce qui était assez
spectacle avec 1 2 me sur 3 juin 2000
sur trois on peut le faire assez
facilement et après cinq sur cinq duke
cinq sur cinq enchaînant tout ça en
battant des grands maîtres
3 nuls et 5 victoires quelque chose
comme ça enfin c'est la folie quoi donc
dès qu'il a commencé à prendre confiance
de combat demain il faudra il faudra
partir ils voient que en termes de
qualité de jeu bah ça va il n'y a pas de
problème bon voilà c'est une ronde 1
c'est un contexte particulier qu'il
avait un adversaire à 2630 en face donc
c'est toujours hyper chaud allez on
repart dangereux
lorsqu'il ya des quatre
oui oui le fameux coup regarder sur d'un
bep cette dame des quatre il avait sans
doute oublié ce coup là puisque sur dame
prend b3 et en fermant deux dames comme
un match de l'escalier et du coup c'est
ce qui a permis à son adversaire ganguly
de jouer b quatre baies 5 mai mais là on
voit qu'il avait encore des possibilités
de jouer tous rêvé 8 août ou rabais 8 et
peut-être d'empêcher becaert qui était
quelque chose de très pénible encore à
nouveau voilà voilà
du coup basse et
c'est bien dommage c'est bien dommage
c'est comme ça de toute façon et on vous
envoie directement on repart
chez les stars alors du coup on peut
déjà vous dire que va y avoir pas mal de
nu deux nuls on va faire un petit tour
et là je vous envoie chez car yakine
qu'on n'a pas vue depuis un moment 1,3
compte de ça je peux vous dire que l'un
et l'autre ont la taille ni qu ils vont
faire nul 4 contre 3 c'est déjà nul ce
qui est marrant c'est qu'on annonçait
une position à deux résultats pour
fabiano caruana tout à l'heure donc une
position de pressing et en fait il n'a
pas converti cette position at de
résultat est encore pire et il a
apparemment ça a failli vrillé alors
comment s'est passé là c'était toujours
un pressing comment il a pu ne pas
gagner ça se comprend mais
il a vraiment une position très agréable
il n'a pas réussi à finir ce qu'ils
travaillaient le pion c6 on avait dit
et du coup par aman c'est là que tout
s'est passé en prenant rapidement sur
ces 5
il a fait des princes et 5 alors des
princes et saint qui était peut-être un
peu plus naturelle des princes et 5 et
simplement cavaliers prend 1,6
elle n'a pas vu donc le pion c5 va
tomber elle fera aussi je pense qu'il a
eu peur campion h 4 et là il fallait
intercalé f3
ça semble dans ses cordes c'est bizarre
ouais il a peut-être vu des choses
incroyables parce qu'il ya ça paraît
facile tout paraît facile mais le roi
est faible il ya encore des cavaliers ou
3 ou peut-être détour pour un f3 de
folie
il a peut-être eu peur d'un coup comme
ça regardez c'est incroyable c'est ils
sont capables de voir des choses comme
ça puis on prend un f3 dimpre en h4 et
là on sait pas trop et du coude à
peut-être pas voulu risquer ces choses
là oui je disais souffre que fabiano
caruana hôpital et une position à deux
résultats il était en train de masser
car jaeckin et maintenant il ya un 3
contre 2 qui va aboutir à annuler et du
coup tout s'est passé là sur ces 5
c'était le dernier moment où l'idée
semble-t-il avec l' avantage après la
jouer cette position très très disputée
et la ca attendu assez facilement vers
la gnôle ils ont échangé les pièces et
comme ils sont très forts en technique
caruana quand il a senti que ça commencé
à déconner il a simplifié cette position
et il est arrivé là en trois contre deux
et ça je peux vous dire qu'ils en ont
fait plein et que c'est archi nul voila
grosse partie de caruana qui a été très
très proche du gain
comme on l'annoncé et tout s'est passé
vous regarderez c'est le moment clé
c'est le 30e coup le 30e kun blanc ou
après ces 5 il n'a pas trouvé une suite
assez assez logique avec avec ben france
et 5 et ça veut dire sur b prend ces
cinq-là sur cavaliers pranger 5
il y avait d'un projet 5 pour essayer de
calmer la position et de rentrer avec un
ping plus dans la finale
par exemple d'un projet sac d'un projet
h pranger et des français il aurait pu
avoir une finale de ce style là et à la
place il a une finale avec un peu de moi
même si c'est une finale qui n'est pas
dangereuse pour lui le tour 3 contre
tours 2 ça fait toujours mieux voilà ce
qu'on peut ce qu'on peut revenir jeudi à
haut niveau
à haut niveau la safrane eu le cul toi
tu vois la mer sinon y en a qui l'a
perdu
je me souviens j'avais parlé voici à
désolé j'avais parlé avec jean-marc
degraeve grand maître et en fait on
parlait de la finale avec tours ah oui
c'est près du tour ouais c'est
intéressant disaient ils disent et web
on trouve retour tu joues pour de
résultats ce qui efface si t'arrives pas
à gagner d'un nul tu vois et en fait des
non mais je les ai perdus avec toi et en
fait il sait tour cavaliers championnat
c'est toujours fou c'est dur fou ce que
je connais ça rigole c'est tout refusé
sur par exemple donc là il a perdu il
n'a pas vu la tour et après la paix en
vue de la finale avec tours
qui va voir donc tu as même bien moi ça
marque les grands maîtres
exactement il a perdu le tour fou de
retour mais c'est lui qui avait tort
mais oui tout arrive je me rappelle que
le regrette et grand maître fettouche
keane moldaves dans un match des
olympiades
russie moldavie la moldavie est en train
de créer un super expo en faisant match
nul contre les russes il allait faire 0
0 et
en fait ce qui s'est passé c'était assez
horrible il était au 48e coup vous
connaissez la règle
normalement dans ce genre d'histoire
il faut faire cinquante coups et la
partie est déclaré nul s'il n'y a pas de
prise ni d'avancé de pion dans une ferme
roi tour fou qu'on droit tour baïda
match nul c'est la règle des 50 coups et
au 48e coup bas ce veto chine alors
qu'il y avait plus aucun risque il a
aligné sur la deuxième rangée son roi et
sa tour et s'est pris une enfilade donc
comme quoi tout arrive c'est alors que
ça c'était un super grand maître à 2600
et des coups bas l'horreur quoi bon bah
alors là on a une situation
ou à nice guéri
fait allégé pressing dans la finale mais
ce n'est pas suffisant puisque
puisque le 40e coup a été passée donc la
prague nalanda n'a pas perdu autant
sinon il serait pas en train de boire un
coup dans sa gourde
sonatel
qui balancerait la gourde sur
l'échiquier peut-être mais
ouais il serait pas aussi serein on va
dire et du coup comme comme on le disait
là ça touche ça touche à sa fin puisque
là on voit bien que anish giri va avoir
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à passer dans
cette dans cette position puisqu'il en
miss à tour en a cinq et du coup elle se
retrouve aussi un petit peu passive dans
un certain sens du coup là ce n'est pas
possible de gagner cette position c'est
pas possible réellement de progresser
donc il ya aucune inquiétude pour le
poulain de stouff souffre à jouer la
grosse cote il a décidé de parier sur
prague d'ananda mais vous rappeler
l'histoire des petits seube vous
rappelez s'ils prennent en venait à
gagner aujourd'hui pam le seul pour
stouff mais maintenant eh ben non ça
elle annule la nous
a raconté et alors c'est qu'un bon
résultat franchement c'est un bon
résultat en plus c'était une jolie
partie il ya eu de la fight mais je
rappelle
voilà que mon poulain il me semble que
c'est eux
vente forest bonne forest et je vais
voir où la jauge est excité là je vous
l'assuré
qu'est ce qui s'est passé avec l'âge eh
ben j'ai l'impression j'ai l'impression
que ça sent le solde cette position
parce que on voit les deux petits pions
pions or là pour tout le monde c'est pas
dur à gagner ce genre de position il
faut rien donné et pousser les pions
jusqu'au bout on dit que deux pions 6e
savoie une tour 2 billion en cinquième
on va dire que sa voix un fou donc là il
est pas mal dans l'histoire
vannes forest vannes forest gagné sauf
en fermant les guenot 20 pour les bleus
il a du temps à la pendule dont ils né
sera pas échapper sa victoire alors
attention ces joueurs là de très haut
niveau ne sont pas infaillibles mais
quasiment ils sont particulièrement
faillible comme tout le monde quand ils
ont peu de temps à la pendule sinon
généralement ils sont quasiment
infaillible d'ailleurs on peut constater
qu'au 37e
il atteint favoriser un petit peu on
joue en 3e set je pourrais je trouve que
c'est pas une décision extraordinaire ça
ne sais pas ce que tu en penses tout
faux il a peut-être considéré qu'il
avait perdu et je pense qu'il est foutu
temps quelque chose quoi il a tout les
viennois il a essayé d'après d'amener sa
tour ans et 8 pour faire des guilis
voyez hein mais bon
c'est clair ça va parler sa pâle et très
loin pour lui malheureusement sur un
coup comme pour ces deux il y aurait
simplement je pense cavaliers mettront
un peu précis et termine à dos puisqu'on
menace triple fourchette en d4 donc une
triple fourchette ça aboutit souvent en
fourchette classique si on bouge une des
trois pièces et puis voilà quoi donc là
c'est c'est terrible je pense que vous
le voyez là il n'y a plus de réel
suspense dans cette danse est parti donc
trois nuls pour l'instant une quatrième
du lac giry là
et la victoire de duda que je viens de
voir apparaître vous voulez aller voir
d'un heavy dit on va les voir duda on va
les voir comment il a gagné il avait un
principe c'est clair et duda plus fiable
que richard laporte sachez jouer dans
les périodes qu'on n'a pas vu du coup on
en fait on n'a pas suivi grand chose
pour être tout à fait franc on a essayé
de voir un maximum de parties on avait
vu le début je me rappelle qu'on était
là avec une conception de richard
rapporte qui était intéressante ils
allaient lâcher des centres mais contre
il comptait bien revenir un jour très
taxée 5 dans ce début de londres qui
avait dérivé en position à deux
candidats mais on va dire un petit peu
les choses comme ça donc d'un mécène a
été jouée pour voir un petit peu le fil
de la partie et souffre du m'arrête
quand tu veux si tu vois quelque chose
d'important alors qu'havas lieu 5
amélioration des pièces on est dans la
phase 2 fin d'ouverture début de milieu
de jeu où les deux joueurs améliorent
leurs pièces et vont ainsi faire le jeu
de restriction des pièces adverse
logique donc bk appareils richard
rapporte coup piquant pour embêter les
pièces de l'adversaire fou prend 1,5 ça
semble normal pour dégommer la structure
de l'adversaire on a dit que les
positions les rois sont tranquilles on
joue activités et structures dont les
pièces et les pions donc cavalier e 4
f3 et l'ipic
le fou comme ça il n'a pas le retard de
la paire de fou pour cette position elle
paraît comme un tout petit peu plus
agréable pour les blancs ils ont des
petites perspectives sur sur le roi
éventuellement - cavaliers c5 je pense
que c'est très bien aussi parce que il
ya richard rapporte à ce moment là de la
partie il voulait peut-être une finale
où ils pouvaient peut-être valoriser
c'est son 3 compte deux allèles
allèles dames
c'est possible et assez importante c'est
qu'on a vu le cours en f2 bref deux
cylindres les blancs et ça c'est
important parce que vous savez que
généralement pas le rock c'est important
c'est un peu comme moi tout le temps
faire mais en fait le rock ne serait pas
beaucoup ici parce que l'opium iii est
faible leroy défend tous les pions ici
j'ai bien la colonne h pour la tour et
mon rôle est très mobile en fait et sur
le long terme peut-être avancé des pions
g4 à avancer mais la meilleure case du
roi cf2 et donc on est d'accord en
général le roi en est toujours en
sécurité avec l'europe mais ici c'est
vrai que
les pièces noires sont pas assez active
pour poser des problèmes sur sur sur le
roi vote d'autant plus que des pions
faible du roi ce que le piège des pions
et 3 et g3 j'ai envie de dire qui sont
ces cases noires et les noirs n'ont pas
de foot recasement non pas la possible
pour attaquer sur quatre soirs donc du
coup peut-être plus tard quatre lotos
rang des cas andré a ramené le toit en
17 et le roi et grand c qui aurait été
honorable en tout cas c'est une position
où on peut presser avec les blancs on a
le plus de pions des cinq défunt des
quatre thèmes bien à l'avancé ce qui m'a
aussi les cases pour le fou de qui
pointent je vois la c4 ou quoi et du
coup le pion c'est aussi un peu à l
argentin franco comme tour c'est à
le pion c'est pourra pas défendue par le
pion béotien prouvant leurs dires et non
par m tu à l'idée de tomber de bessat
gonfla on a vu que ça avait bien sûr ses
avantages et ses inconvénients et le puy
ans et qui est toujours à rire et c'est
complet que quand position qui passe
avec eux en pratique c'est bien mieux
bien fâcheuses pour les blancs ici on va
toujours tous choisir les blancs même si
on a cherché en vain car on perd le pion
aux singles on peut rentrer en septième
donc on a
on a du jeu en fait ce qu'on peut dire
il n'a pas fait le rock il a fait une
cabane on va dire hein mais ça marche la
cabane la cabane c'est le concept tout
fait sauf qu'il a inventé ce concept de
la cabane à mr rené ça c'est la
recherche de la brie sur deux du roi et
du coup on voit ce petit coup de la
cabane que nous fait stoufflet gros f2
voilà on retiendra ça c'est important
redonner le mais c'est c'est très très
bien expliqué et du coup c'est une sorte
de rock un petit peu atypique c'était
encore que meilleur dans ce dans ce cas
précis que le rock traditionnel et du
coup c'est vraiment c'est vraiment assez
sympa de voir ça et en échange du pion
doodle il a estimé que sa tour arrivé en
décès c'est d'ailleurs ce qui s'est
passé et du coup qu'il avait un jeu de
folie en échange des pions sacrifier que
ses pions la a été faible quand même
donc là il a continué à travailler
colonnes
richard rapporte à essayer d'aller
détruire la cabane de stouff mais ben il
ya une christophe duda il a aussi
l'habitude des cabanes et regardez il a
joué que 4 pour le mettre le fond angers
6 et il a tranquillement géré les
petites attaques de l'adversaire / g / h
4 da prix d'un match de décès de
proposer des problèmes fouet f1
tranquille et regarder à pont
reconstruit une sorte de d'abris d'abris
un petit peu atypique avec très
prochainement le roi qui est venu en g2
pour ne plus avoir de problèmes il ya la
caravane de ce trophée là c'est la
cabane de jan christoph voilà mais en
tout cas vous voyez que
c'est quand même sympa c'est petit
concept de roi parce que si vous faites
ça à la maison ou dans vos blitz ou dans
vos petites parties des fois vous allez
vous faire gronder par par les joueurs
expérimentés en disant oh attention à
ton roi et là on voit que les joueurs
très expérimentés il arrive à jongler
avec le roi dans n'importe quelle
position c'est ça qui est assez sympa
quand même avec ce petit concept de la
cabane qu'on retient mais bien entendu
bien bien bien entendu on peut voir
aussi que les pièces ne sont pas ses
actes il c'est pour ça qu'on peut se
permettre de ne pas re ok d'avoir notre
droit ici à angers 2 si les tours noir
était vraiment en jeu ou quoi ça
pourrait être plus compliquée mais ici
les tours noir enfin la seule que la
nouvelle au bras par claude hmsn
et blanc qui rompt la domine
complètement donc nord au moment du
voile à s'activer c'est pour ça avant
que le principe de la cabane est
possible ici tu aimes bien aussi le
principe de la bonne foi c'est bien ce
que tu as inventé toute petite cabane de
jardin
[Musique]
[Rires]
les petites les petits trèfle musicale
mais à huy
sont sortis mais du coup ce quiz ce
qu'on peut voir c'est assez visuel ce
que 10 toof c'est que en fait on a
quatre pièces active même le fouet fin
je le considérais actif puisque c'est
une pièce que l'on peut recycler
facilement par contre le fu g6 et les
tournois des gueux et richard rapportent
ils attaquer avec saddam donc même pour
le pion de moins vu que j'ai la grande
colonne ouverte qui est l'élément
central de la position en terme
d'activité massa compense largement et
là je me régale d'autres belles belles
parties comme de bas des deux joueurs
d'ailleurs elle était hyper sympa cette
partie aussi on n'a pas assez vu parce
qu'on on s'est focalisé déjà sur la
partie de ma qu'andris marouazi et la
partie de marriage of et du boeuf qui
était particulièrement esthétique mais
il y avait de quoi dire aussi sur sur
ces chics et
est du coup en plus je pense que si on
n'a pas vu cette partie là je pense que
c'est un peu de la faute de ce souffle
voilà moi je suis pas une balance mais
je vous le dis il a été déçu au
championnat du monde de rapide par son
poulain jan christoph duda qui lui a
fait perdre beaucoup et du coup il a un
peu annoncé il a un peu pris en grippe
en ce moment peut-être une petite
fâcherie passagère en fait mais
nous sommes quant à orange est suisse en
réfléchissant je crois que je suis un
gros enfin en fait sans vous vois ça je
crois que jouer
je pose tout le monde en fait parce que
regardent jeu je suis pour pour duda
lors des championnats du monde de hockey
car enfin il partit il fait bon résultat
est bon il rate il rata des podiums deux
fois
là je suis pas pour lui parce qu'il va
parce qu'il m'a vu il m'a déçu bon là et
qu est-ce qui fait il gagne
peut-être il a peut-être gagné le
tournoi du coin
il va certainement
ouais ya michel qui va essayer de t d
donc
ouais
montrer les gros c'est avec un petit
servent déjà à la tendance c'est pas lui
qui commençait comme concept mais vonn
forêt c'est un joueur que j'aime
beaucoup aussi j'aurais pu parler
aujourd'hui vraiment simple profil que
j'aime bien mais bon j'ai pas le droit
de parier contre prague à
ccc on a joué dans la même équipe à
cannes en vrai
c'est pas du tout envie paris contre
roddick oui bien sûr franchement c'est
quand on a des jeunes aussi fort et
qu'on est passionné d'échecs comme nous
c'est hyper attachant de voir des jeunes
comme celui ci se débrouiller aussi bien
et du coup quand les avions en
partenaire d'équipé c'est vrai qu'on a
un peu privilégié et je te comprends
souffrait de le soutenir à fond et
j'espère qu'il va faire un tournoi avec
beaucoup de nuls avec beaucoup de nuls
solide solide voilà que des nuls ce qui
serait un tournoi vraiment
bon pour lui voilà 1 50% mais avec
beaucoup de nuls voilà voilà ce que je
lis et ce que je lui ai fait je suis
quand même vraiment vraiment sympa du
coup bon alors on finit juste le film de
cette partie d'un mètre carré
que j'ai c'est un très très gros score
contre l'irlande à a joué une fois je
conduis je crois que j'ai dû lui mettre
11,2
d'accord en en glisse
au ping-pong voilà je sentais je sors le
média local est au début ouais et m'a
d'abord et l'allaitement bull at-il
injouable c'est ce que j'imaginais c'est
pour ça je me suis dit ouf il devait
être chaud non mais on se doit en plus
que ce corps produit c'est toujours
possible tu mets 3 2 en bullet frein sur
une grande forme de stuff c'est possible
non mais là 11,2 au ping pong
ouais bah c'est respect car ils sont pas
très bon c'est pas très bon au ping pong
là je me souviens quand on était partis
sont là et fait un stage en l'un des
quelques années on l'avait vu là-bas en
fait juste leur jeu préféré il adorait
il prenait ragga dub hip hop etc zhang
lei avec avec la raquette et il devint
le plus possible tu as donc lui il en
faisait et leur faisait 8 et détendez
vous n'arrivez pas à la il n'avait pas
l'anglais donc tu vois que le niveau
quoi et est donc moi j'arrive dans la
raquette et je sais pas je me suis
arrêté sur un embranchement des marques
qui allait de 4 à 2 3 400 tu agents plus
tu perds jamais quoi c'est impossible de
perdre et le crédit qui se fout quoi
alors qu'en fait juste c'est normal
juste nuls ou qu
est ce que tu la plus marquée au ping
pong que lui va de marquer aux échecs ça
c'est vraiment une question importante
il peut me mettre on se doser chacun
enfin en blé de ses pommettes remettre
pire que ça en bus est aussi mais je
pense que quand même j'ai plus de
chances de battre des chèques qui ne
pourront qu milliards d'euros ping pong
sais pas je suis bon c'est qu'il est
très mauvais j'aimerais bien de jouer
contre toi finalement sous puisque le
ping pong j'aime bien j'aime bien j'ai
mis un jour enfin à 1 contre des joueurs
de deux campings de bistrot tu vois ces
macaques voilà oui oui c'est ma came 1
parce qu'après dès que ça joue trop non
non c'est plus mon truc mais
du coup oui franchement d'un médecin y
regarder d'un mètre 4 leur faivre là
c'est joli comme tout il rentre en
finale parce qu'il sait que le pion
davance des noirs est bloqué pour toute
la partie et maintenant il va convertir
jan christoph son avantage en finale et
du coup ça fait hyper mal je vois qu'il
ya une autre partie qui vient de se
finir
c'est nos petits
grands des lieux servant de forest est
bon ça on a vu en direct là je vais pas
rappeler à ce tout ce qu'il a perdu le
petit pari de la journée ça serait ce
serait moche que je rappelle donc je
peux en faire des caisses le savez le
triomphe modeste ce qui me caractérise
et pour l'instant ça se passe bien ce
tas de tata steel à ça ça me chauffe
mais en tout cas on voit qu'il reste du
biou visite champions qu'on ira avouera
après la petite explication de cette
partie et prague 90 en algérie on vous a
assuré la nul donc on va aller voir que
ça se finit bien comme ça donc ça sympa
et comment il a converti son avantage
puisque regardez bien quand il ya les
parties de haut niveau mais moche pas du
monde de rapide c'était hyper
intéressant les conversions j'ai
particulièrement apprécié les parties de
47 ans je perds du monde de rapides pour
leur simplicité et là on va voir comment
simplement il va gagner tranquillement
cette position alors comment il fait
qu'ils améliorent les pièces et la
meilleure son roi le roi c'est une pièce
à part entière maintenant regarder il a
joué roigé trois hymnes euros à tour des
3 pour protéger f3 et maintenant il veut
il va installer son endroit au bout du
monde on crois j'essais 3g 5 il n'a pas
peur de se faire mater
faut faire gaffe évidemment tout rage
suite pour le match fou prend f3 tour à
chaque match mais malheureusement il a
cage des caps surtout reprend f 3 ar
mais rêvons un petit peu
pourquoi pas un f6 mais pour l'instant
mon roi et quid donc en fait il avait
jugé duda qui n'avait pas de problème
pour ces sept ramène une autre tour
pression sur six pression sur ses cinq
tours ces huit tours 7
pour ces huit y jouent au chat la
deuxième il revient à la situation
initiale parce que le mec peut plus
bouger tourache et fit il revient encore
et là est ce qu'il aurait pu jouer pour
ces 8
c'était peut-être pas bête je sais pas
pourquoi il n'a pas cessé de répéter
tourache 8 il est pris les deux tours et
a toujours faut prendre si ce nom
bizarre cette fin
ben pourquoi aussi c'est toujours avec
tours cyclistes c'est quoi
la tour s'est vite fo prend aussi ce nom
a comme ça aux piétons 17 du coup selon
laquelle c'est à troyes bat
oui
il faut paraître trois peut-être mais
c'est là bas je fais d'abord sage
échanges pour que tu n'es plus puis
maintenant il faut prendre forme et là c
est ce que je mange dehors du coup là je
mange ou s'est vite du coup c'est plutôt
assez vite du coup non est-ce que la
place de manger alors à la place de
manger
à l'auberge de me
wade pour conserver ton c'est autour de
7 parce que du coup quand je mange aussi
ce jeu me la zf set c'était pas le cas
dans l'autre moi on s'est quand même
prise de risque que mon fou sort enfin
bon là je vais pas de laisser les 2
1 il a complètement en fait on s'est pas
rendu compte tout à l'heure mais on
pensait voir une belle conversion
là je pense que peut-être que tu
retrouves 6,8 il peut revenir comme ça
ou comme ça tu vois mais retravaillé la
position mais il y avait encore du
boulot en fait
je pense que t'en penses stéphane mais
c'est vrai que là il ya eu la guerre la
gaffe astronomique parce que tour c'est
cette c'est hyper facile de voir que
maya tour dès cette fin le veau en deux
secondes normalement affiche a rapporté
chez pareil là et il a oublié
puisque l'aller se prendre les deux
tours en septième il a dû enfin il a dû
repenser parce que les joueurs sont au
zénith mais c'est lui qui avait du temps
en plus ça qui est bizarre donc
finalement duda et converti aussi grâce
à richard rapporte qu' allah a fait une
erreur assez étonnante ne sais pas ce
que tu en penses
en fait nous sommes très désagréable et
souvent quand vous mettez la pression
sur les adversaires
franchement ça marche bien vous allez
vous apercevoir que même un joueur que
vous considérez fort si vous le mettez
sous pression il sera pas dans ça dans
sa zone de confort il peut faire des
bêtises par contre si vous êtes vous
jouez un joueur que vous estimez plus
fort que vous et que du coup vous
recroqueviller en défense souvent lui
dans sa zone de confort il va se faire
plaisir avec vous à ce que vous là je
peux vous le dire donc
donc vaut mieux vaut mieux y aller et
alors que jiri et prague d'ananda on
vous le confirme ils ont fait match nul
donc on va pouvoir aller voir une partie
qu'on avait annoncé comme assez
assez pénible dans le sens d une finale
il y avait un début très ambitieux entre
visites et
et comment dirais-je shankland donc et
après ça c'était complètement calmés
et on annonce est un petit pressing au
départ on va vous montrer la position il
y avait ce petit pressing la de départ
et apparemment ça s'est grandement
avancé puisque ben il ya ça me chante
lente qui est en grande difficulté
visite avait une meilleure position
puisqu'il a un meilleur jeu de pièces
ici un meilleur roi et il a réussi
egea oui il a joué j'ai six pour
empêcher le cavalier d'arriver sur la
belle case mais maintenant elle a
rapproché le point de percer ce qui a
permis à vie dit de percer avec h5
du couchant claude a tout de suite réagi
par une attaque
de réaction au centre
par rapport à l' attaque de l'ale dam
des blancs 1 souffre du grand classique
pour l'instant oui
tour h 1 on double
tour 8 7 tours c'est un
assez logique il ya toujours des petites
histoires sur la colonne sait puisque si
m'envoie d'asson s'éprend d'un e prend
des cetc la partie
malheureusement les deux belles tour
là-bas sont muselés par cavalier et le
pion qui contrôle les carottes fait un
gros boulot à caracas à eux deux les
deux caisses d'entraidé et saluera donc
en gros tu ta la colonne eux mêmes ne
sert à rien en fait c'est ça c'est
encore cavaliers l'attaqué ne sert à
rien par contre la colonne c'est
regardait vie dit il a joué tour c5 je
fais un petit et du coup ils travaillent
sur la colonne c'est
et du coup dans cette dans cette
position c'est parti pour le pressing
pendant toute la partie tour des six
tours c8 et là on va souffrir dans cette
position ce n'est pas encore perdue
parce que la position est très solide
elle est plutôt saine mais c'est une
position qu'on appelle à deux résultats
où je suis coincé je sais pas trop quoi
faire
j'ai pas trop apprécié champions je
regardais assez peu dans le chat parce
que pour une fois j'ai mon chat sur le
téléphone portable et j'ai l'impression
d'avoir vu que michel avait dix était
meilleur que moi au ping pong ça c'est
un truc hyper énervant pour moi tout fin
je vais je vais regarder vous avez dit
cela
j'ai l'impression que michel l'a dit
dans mes toiles je t'accuse pastou
feinte inquiète pas en reste en bons
termes tous les deux mais michel j'ai
l'impression qu'ils débordent là ce soir
j'ai l'impression qu'il déballe grave
justement il disait qu'il miserait sur
toi en fait ah bon alors il est très
raisonnable ni salle ce soir c'est
vraiment un script qui
[Rires]
ferme ce qui attend les verts ' je vais
le regarder je regardais geab ce que
déclarait déborder la déborder donc prêt
si on continue on travaille alors qu'est
ce qu'on fait dans ces cas là bas on
améliore toutes les pièces et on essaie
de taper sur les petits pions et en fait
ça c'est à l'air hyper bizarre ce qui
s'est passé je pense qu'il était
vraiment gêné dans cette position alors
pourquoi il est gêné mais on commence à
voir l'histoire qui arrive à bouque
parce que la tête donc au jeu qu'avait
lieu si ceci provoque haye
tu veux jouer car il y avait de la place
cavaliers ainsi ce jeu peut-être quelque
chose non mais ça c'est normal ça c'est
normal ça c'est normal par contre le
reste est pas facile à avoir ces trois
tours c3 puis bat à son navigateur
l'accès aux colonnes des tours d'essai
des bons jeux ton roi qui rentre un peu
comme landu trop dure la guyane de tours
donc du coup on se retrouve
évidement donc il a essayé quelques unes
en voir il n'aime pas sa position ça me
chante landes et il essaie un f6
intéressant pour dynamique pour essayer
de sortir d'une position compromise et
après j'ai prend f3 f7 il pensait être
peut-être tiré d'affaires mais pas du
tout h plongé à changer ça c'est normal
y'a pas le choix et cavaliers detroit il
reprend f6 et c'est vrai que ça paraît
intéressant il a liquidé un peu le
matériel sauf que il y a une case
d'avant pose pour le cavalier une belle
colonnes pour la tour donc il ya encore
du travail
le cavalier sur la meilleure case de
l'échiquier qui permet à tour de rentrée
enlève cette plus travail sur le pion
faible dont le cavalier futé esclave de
son propre pions et là c'est la galère
de jouer cette position position à 2
résultat est sans doute qu'un seul
résultat puisque l'aca l'air d'être
vraiment vraiment très très avantageux
on aurait pu penser à tour f7 il a
préféré à 4 il joue toujours pas tous
rêvent 7 il le jouera quand il aura
envie
et là il y en a eu plus envie et la
position est quand même très très
difficile roger
tu vois que l'europe arrive en f3 il ya
un petit matin 3 3 miles away
attention b6 et roy f3
il est en train de préparer le travail
il veut gagner selon g5
vraisemblablement
commence à être il ya des schémas qui
vont se créer
des petits réseaux de matelas avec un
[Musique]
voile à montreux mater encore mais tu as
bons tours fc est que dumont 3g car pour
aller manger le fond c'est ça on pousse
ses pions f les noirs pourraient avoir à
l'unité aussi avec tours fc est un
cavalier e cissé un jour manger d'écart
mais attention que la cannelle et aussi
ce serait le pire coup la position parce
que les blocs 2e tour f7 matin
pour tous ceux qui nous rejoignent on
rappelle malheureusement la mauvaise
nouvelle de la journée au niveau du seul
tricolore qui joue dans le tournoi b
attention le 3b on a dit c'est un
tournoi où il ya quasiment que des
grands maîtres c'est la petite pépite
française marc andrieu maori djiké le
plus jeune grand maître de l'histoire
de france et du coup ils s'inclinaient
contrats grands maîtres indiens à 2630
quasiment gang ou lit il a fait une très
très bonne partie est
il a fait 2-1 pressions successives et
là une position très difficile à
défendre est en crise de temps il a fini
par céder et la position commence à
s'écrouler de stations sur sur
l'échiquier
c'était une grosse partie et on a vu de
l'exigence 1 2 petites imprécisions puis
c'était c'était déjà trop dur donc
dommage mais on sait que marc andré a de
la ressource et demain il sera déjà
prêts à en découdre donc voila voila
pour cette mauvaise nouvelle et puis
nous on va on va finir sur cette partie
c'était l'heure de mettre une petite
pause parce qu'on n'a pas mis on a sauté
une peau je crois souffre
d'une pause oui on va faire une petite
pause oui on peut disposer après on
finit on finit avec le spectacle c'est
pour tous ceux pour juste respecté comme
d'hab vous savez
allait être j'étais garé à tout de suite
je vous mets la pause le petit écran
comme d'habitude
yes
bon ça
et nous voilà repartis pour la fin du
tata steel stéphane avec la partie
que que l'on voit maintenant
houssam shankland est en grande
difficulté avec les noirs contre vie dit
voilà je me radhia et ben là c'est en
train de se dégrader visite vient de
donner son pion son pion comment
dirais-je en rangée 4 et du coup il ya
eu cavaliers projet 4 et interviews si
ce n'est de jouer même tu dis pardon
voilà leur excuse moi un coup le club le
coup gkd des noirs qui permet cavaliers
ou six en fait parce que beaucoup
d'avancées curieux en arrière monsieur
noir joue cavalier aussi ça la place de
farges et 4 eh ben il y aurait tout rêve
sept matches voilà
champion du stade hilal il a dû le voir
c'est pour ça qu'il a il a décidé de
lever l'option pour s'activer et
essayer de
tenter quelque chose donc g4 qui avait
décroché quatre qu'elle va laisser la
partie et oui eh ben pour te dire ah
ouais malheureusement marque andry s'est
incliné on a montré la partie tu pourras
regarder le replay si tu veux on a
expliqué ce qui s'était passé est une
grosse partie pendant vingt coups et
après deux impressions successifs qui
lui en fait avoir une position très
difficile et qui il a commencé à prendre
du temps et que soit la pendule ou sur
l'échiquier ça a complètement grillé
tout simplement
voilà
donc alors du caudan 7 dans cette
histoire
ils essaient g4tv projet quatre
cavaliers ou six excellents coups
mais il va pas rater un nom peut déjà
vous le dire ce qui va se passer il y
aura cavaliers ou trois qui a été joué
d'ailleurs ou f6 aimerions faire tour g4
protège le pion ce qui a été joué
d'ailleurs hockey et maintenant bahia le
pion des cinq en l'air donc il va le
protéger soi qu'à et ses 7 soit tour des
huit et il va se faire travailler après
très tranquillement ses pions de plus
c'est une défaite défaite en une petite
demi heure voilà mon prono le rhum blanc
qui va partir en d3 pour venir défendre
le pion des 4 la tour qui la trouvent
georges qui va probablement aller en h4
peut-être pour essayer de jouer ou s4 et
s5 comme tu le propose la tourangelle 6%
chasser le cavalier est aussitôt h4 qui
peut être jouer donc il ya pas mal galli
en règle et blanc parce qu'on a une
faiblesse et une force est en cours du
coup si le principe des deux faiblesses
on va s'appuyer sur les deux on va
travailler autour de cela et des pièces
plus active aussi est par exemple quand
je mène mon voilà effectivement mon
cavalier va vraiment bien tapé là donc
là je pense que chaque land il va se
battre mais il doit être
il doit être bien bien démoralisé dans
cette position mais
il n'y a pas le choix
donc là c'est un peu moi un peu moins
sympa est ce qu'on pourra aller se
trouve ça devra en attendant que ça se
décante un petit peu dans cette partie
voir les parties des chants du
challenger est ce qu on s conçu un petit
tour
attendez ce que je peux aller jeter un
oeil pendant que tu étais là pour voir
un petit peu ce qui est intéressant donc
là
c'est juste pour voir les plus beaux
films de la journée ce qu'on a vraiment
regarder la soude est parti pour le coup
c'est bien franchement il n'y a pas trop
de partis donc on peut passer du temps
et vous expliquer les meilleures parties
et charge à vous après de nous dire voir
les parties vous préférez les parties
que vous avez envie de voir et et nous
on s'exécute et je rappelle qu'on va
alors tout fils va streamé pendant toute
la durée
toute la durée du championnat et pour ma
part je l'accompagnerai les week-ends et
c'est çà me robin le maître fide qui va
accompagner stouff pour les les matches
en semaine or jours de repos évidemment
voilà et on ne s'est pas fait un petit
coup de promo tout fait moi j'ai pas les
commandes pour pour tout faire mais en
tout cas sachez que vous pouvez
retrouvez stouff sur sa chaîne
twitch lorsqu'il est stream
régulièrement et ma part pour ma part
c'est pareil sur la chaîne pro evolution
et chaque n'hésitez pas à aller faire un
petit tour et vous pouvez me retrouver à
raison de cinq créneaux par par semaine
j'en fais un peu moins là les week-ends
parce qu'il ya le tata steel mais après
on reprendra dès la fin du tata steel
des créneaux sur le week-end aussi et si
non en semaines il ya mardi mercredi
jeudi pour ceux qui veulent et
du coup il ya aussi la chaîne youtube de
duchess com fr qui et qui est présente
et du coup n'hésitez pas à aller jeter
un oeil à tout ça
voilà le tour promotionnel stouff en
baisse jeudi les liens sur les soldes
jacques
deschênes qui peut le faire quand même
donc n'hésitez pas à aller faire des
petits tours là dessus et les contenus
devraient vous plaire du moins on fait
notre maximum
et là ça me chante là on il est parti
dans une grosse réflexion alors même si
on a dit que c'était globalement une
position qui est foutu il a quand même
un maigre espoir allégé pas c'est moins
de 5% à les 1% de chance eh ben il va se
battre pour essayer de rendre
la vie difficile à vie dit et surtout le
faire douter un moment et pourquoi pas
arracher un demi point
son destin n'est plus entre ses mains
ces visites joue normalement à son
niveau il gagnera facilement mais il
faut être le plus précis possible pour
faire durer le combat et espérer que
visite à un moment s'embrouille et que
la position deviennent un peu plus
complexe mais là c'est vrai que c'est
c'est quand même très très mal parti
alors tout fait ce que tu nous as trouvé
la perle rare
dans le tournoi b du temps il reste il
reste deux parties restent à partie de
jazz gère ça se prononce je ne connais
pas en plus un pour être tout à fait
franc donc là on est sur des des joueurs
plus confidentiels c'est un jeune joueur
du danemark qui jouent contre l avis
j'ai vu dans l'abri gagner a reconnu
mais il a une finale gagnante
et sinon on a des filles donc le match
des filles donc c'est
une heure
contre tous à laura et
apparemment la jeune russe la joueuse
russe est archi gagnante
la somme atteint
les parties puisque le pion h4 d'erwin
l'ami va sauter et du coup après la
qualité en plus va permettre aux blancs
d'oeufs de commencer à pousser les pions
sans être trop gêné par la majorité
noirs ici les blancs ils vont prendre
ils vont partir avec la tour exemple en
d4 verger qu'attache qu'attache inquiets
commencé à voir comment ça monte le roi
aussi hein pourquoi pas pour accompagner
les pions même en f4 bon etc etc donc ça
devrait pas poser de problème
on va regarder déjà les deux parties en
cours comme le monde comme à 10 toof et
donc c'est les deux féminines qui sont
présentes dans le tournoi qui se joue
tous les deux
donc elles ont un niveau lui n'est
maître mais a dépassé les 2500 donc je
vois où va l'eau va qui est jeune papa
sera grand maître mixte
vraiment prochainement et du coup
son adversaire
c'est assez étonnant elle n'est que
grand m féminin alors qu'elle a déjà un
hello qui s'approche de 2500 donc elle
va passer maître international et sans
doute grand maître dans la foulée
il me semble qu'elle ait le meilleur
lots des moins de 20 ans si je dis pas
de bêtises jean r parce que quand vous
allez sur le site de la fidh il me
semble qu'on voit ça sa photo dans la
rubrique des classements
elle est meilleure et l'eau féminin des
moins de 20 ans c'est un gros gros
espoirs
et là bon c'est assez simple de
comprendre que
les deux rois sont
en l'air mais c'est les noirs qui ont la
main donc on a la main comme ça on va
commencer à forcer les choses pour ces
deux sa menace presque mat si je vais en
f1 je prends ma de l'escalier donc on
est quasiment sûr qu'il y aura à tour
ces deux rois 3 et là on peut commencer
la chasse au roi pour le faire sortir
donc tour ces deux rois ou trois
dames géants ont fait un peu de calcul
d'ailleurs stouff
wife 4 wii est juste dame siens qui
gagnent la partie avec trois f 4 et
carly et g5
s'est perdue
directement fait cette position d'allié
derrière voilà cavaliers en l'air
derrière donc j'espère que vous avez vu
on vous montre pour ceux qui n'ont pas
l'habitude du jeu à l'aveuglé or c'est
bien quand même qu'on vous fasse même
pour ceux qui n'ont pas d'expérience à
la vague vous fasse travailler les
aveugles parce que pour calculer aux
échecs il n'y a pas le choix et du coup
il faut s'entraîner comme ça à
visualiser les cases dans un premier
temps faire des petits exhale aveugle et
ensuite faire de plus en plus d'exercice
et se servir de la capacité de calcul
donc là on analysait tour ces deux c'est
facile à calculer les ventes forcées il
n'y a qu'une solution re 3 ok pour 3
d'un géant qu'une solution roi f4 et
quand vous faites une chasse au roi
c'est à dire et chaque échec échec pour
déplacer le roi au mauvais endroit en
droit faites le au maximum monte et là
il est vraiment plus vulnérables
normalement il est près de vos pièces en
plus et du coup la dame si on gagne il
fallait l'avoir vu avant puisque la ire
wife 4 kg 5 donc sur trois ou cinq on va
se faire mater et suroît g3 d'un projet
5 avec un gain quelques coups plus tard
vraisemblablement ou alors peut-être
encore mieux si j'ai envie ce que je
peux faire sur moi j'ai trois pardon
dames 1 pour favoriser le gain du
cavalier parce que c'est plus précis je
veux bouger djourou age ii pour garder
la dame comme ça je fais d'un prend hk
trois quarts
et je vais gagner le pion b200 perdre b3
sinon dans la vente que je propose est
directement rouages et trois dames
pranger 5 les changes de dames est
effectué hélas après tour prend b3 je
peux me à l'airé dans la finale donc
aucun intérêt de jouer cela même s'il me
reste un petit pion on sait que la
finale le roi tour fou peut conduire à
la nulle sur un bon joueur un bon jeu du
défenseur à groix tour donc faut faire
vraiment attention faut vraiment faire
attention
dans ses positions là est ce qu'on va
s'amuser à aller voir les partis qui
sont
comment on est arrivé là et c'est ce
qu'ont fait un petit tour des stades
stouff à moins que ça a évolué de
l'autre côté
alors
juste change vite a réussi avant gestion
des cinq as et déjà donc en fait ça joue
assez vite hein c'est bizarre en fait
parce que j'en croise l'art a défendu en
fait adacore va y laisser sans doute de
l'embrouillé un peu ils essaient de
prendre le contrôle jeudi au gala
cologne béton qui a eu lieu avant la
partie a eu il ya eu p 5 voilà sûr qu'il
va lui sur torch 2 caps alors même si
d'un point de vue scientifique
ordinateur sans doute que shankland ces
défaillances qui les fait regardez donc
donc ça on avait vu il essaie à tout
prix de s'activer parce qu'il sait qu'
une mort lente l'attend donc du coup il
y avait cinq cavaliers prend des 5 3 et
7 et ils essaient de l'embrouillé
trouver du contre jeu comme nous à 10
toof avec la tour qui va s'activer au
moins ils préfèrent avoir deux pions de
moins que 1 mais avoir des pièces
activer des petites carottes dans tous
les sens patron que ça va être
rapidement parce que là on voit que ce
roi 4 qui est la partie
si j'imagine que les langues vont fermer
pendant quatre ans à 4 un peu c'est
quand même le but on vous les ouvrez la
colonne et imaginons envoie ton père
en fait ce que je sais ce que je veux et
sur l'échec qui aura toujours cavalier
carhaix au soir cinq ans destiné à
cavalli ou 3d et on va commencer à
pousser les pions
hamas et l'horreur à l'horreur absolue
ce qui est assez cocasse c'est que c'est
le seul échiquier on n'a pas les caméras
c'est la seule caméra qui ne marchaient
pas de toute la journée et évidemment
c'est ça a pas manqué je trouve c'est là
c'est la partie qui finit en dernier ok
là on est quasiment quasiment à la fin
on vous dit par avance un que voilà
cette partie elle va terminer dans un
quart d'heure à ce moment là on arrêtera
le stream souvent quand il y aura une
partie l'a complètement gagnante pourra
des fois vous voulez c'est à ce moment
là mais là on va peut-être la finir je
pense qu'elle va s'unir d'ici quelques
minutes 1 1 souffre
oui je pense oui ça va ça va terminer
les ascendants vraiment expéditif
maintenant il n'y a plus trop de
moi il n'ya plus trop d'idées
il faut qu'on en fait faut être
solidaire la cavalier pions pions roi et
faire un bloc et commencé après activer
la tour pour chasser le roi et l'amener
sur la 8e par exemple ça peut être
du coup on voit bien ce genre d'idées et
c'est là la boîte est mise en place il
faut être un tout petit peu méfiant mais
bon là il continue juste pour dire
même à niveau amateur cette partie
serait complètement gagnante et les
joueurs le sentir est
donc là
après c'est pas leur bonne partie qu'on
l'on gagne ouais il même vous voyez hein
parce qu'il ya des joueurs qui ont plus
ou moins de fragilité et je sais qu'il
ya certains d'entre vous qui trouve
respectueux des fois d'abandonner vite
mais en fait
allez-y 1 continue au maximum si vous
avez
deux mois et
et comment dirais-je et que vous êtes
malade et d'ici quelques coups
etc et si globalement vous êtes un
joueur très expérimenté et que vous avez
une grosse pièce de moins plus de chance
vous avez vous avez le droit d'abonnés
c'est un droit mais en règle générale on
voit que les joueurs les plus combatifs
c'est aussi les meilleurs donc allez-y 1
allez-y bâtiment s'il ya une chance il
faut jouer
ouais ouais pat visite rejoint doudaeva
de forest voilà
alors sous you buy a pas de français
dans ce tournoi là il ya il ya marc
andré mardi dans le tournoi baisse on
l'a vu c'est le plus gros espoirs
français actuellement on peut citer
aussi marco materia mais qui est un peu
plus jeune et qui a un énorme espoir et
on a d'autres aussi évidemment mais
c'est vraiment le plus gros espoirs pour
l'instant et du coup il y aurait pu y
avoir des joueurs comme mvl et firoud de
ja
je sais que firoud déjà une proposition
parce que j'ai vu un article là dessus
pour le faire mais il a refusé parce
qu'il ya une une légère embrouille l'an
dernier au tata steel pendant qu'il
était en train de jouer une partie et
les organisateurs ont fait du bruit ils
ont voulu lancer les matchs de départage
pour la première place dans un souci
logistique
du coup ça a déplu à ahfir hodja et du
coup quand il a reçu la proposition pour
cette année
bah il n'a pas accepté les conditions et
il a demandé des conditions meilleures
ce que l'organisateur a refusé voilà
donc ils sont en froid est-ce que ça
dure à
son que j'avais moi
version gsab est exempté de l'année
dernière il y avait eu le match de
barrage pour la première place et lui
était pas concerné parce qu'il avait
fait un tournoi moyens et en fait ils
jouaient sur une table larcher quel
numéro de table en fait déjà en courant
car en fait les organes avec besoin
voulait prendre sa table à lui pour
faire des braquages là où il était élu a
dit m on joue quoi il fait comment on va
se déplacer tout est là bas et il était
avec notes et legear une position
gagnante et y la france quant à la diva
trash en train de jouer la partie tu vas
pas me déplacer et enfin c'est un
tournoi 5ème en gros tournois toyer
d'argent en jeu il ya des gars tout le
plateau face au mcee ici faut pas faire
ça et si ils l'ont fait et du coup bah
il est parfois il a changé de table il
est parti voilà alors qu'ils étaient
dérangés en plein milieu de sa partie il
a gaffé il a fait match nul et du coup
il est énervé il ya un scandale ex à ce
niveau là les organes sont excusés de
souci les ide et voilà et en gros cette
année bien il ne voulait pas jouer les
conditions étaient invités comme ça et
en gros
ce qui s'est passé quand même firouz ja
a demandé m chaque joueur en fait tu
reçois à cacher c'est tu veux donc à une
invitation dès que son pays dont hôtel
payé la bouffe c'est à mais il aussi
sata un cachet de là on veut nous
enfin je pense que c'est ta connection
argentine qui fait des siennes
je pense qu'il a demandé alors ce que
j'imagine c'est qu'il a demandé en
compensation
ouais on n'a pas trop entendu stouff
être un petit peu coupé là tout est figé
il va revenir sous fin voyez c'est la
magie du direct la fin d'histoire de
stouff a été coupée j'imagine qu'il a
demandé en compensation peut-être la
différence dit qu'il avait perdu en
en ratant son avantage la fin j'imagine
que c'est ça la petite la petite
explication de souffre qui va revenir un
an dans quelques instants vous allez
retrouver se trouve qui s'est figé qui
nous racontait vraiment l'histoire avec
plus de détails que je n'ai pu le faire
et
est du coup alors cette partie n avance
pas forcément très vite mais en tout cas
il est prêt si l'ajout f3 il se
précipite pas et ici
il civile dit tranquille il va faire le
travail maintenant il ya plus d échec
par-derrière donc je vois bien jouer 4 f
le gain qui semble plus tranquille est
ouf on a récupéré on n'a pas eu la fin
de ton histoire au moment ça dlp au
monde les neiges ou talent et j'ai
téléchargé momo internet les problèmes
ici
du coup je disais quoi en fait était en
train de nous dire qu'il avait demandé
au niveau conditions un meilleur cacher
et on sait pas de combien on ne sait pas
pourquoi mais tu es en train de
l'appliquer pas mais il a demandé en
fait une composition par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé l'année dernière
est peut-être il avait perdu en gagnant
[Musique]
alors que c'est quelque chose comme ça
c'est pas du tout ça je peux pas te dire
combien je n'ai aucune idée mais mais du
coup ben genre a refusé et ils ont ils
ont dit par écoute on est désolés par
rapport aux relations qui s'est passé
voilà dams a maintenant on lui demande
un truc qui est beaucoup trop cher donc
du coup par écoute on a refusé mais on
espère on espère un jour leur voir venir
oui la porte n'est pas fermée j'espère
parce que c'est quand même un peu
malheureux pour pour fuir ou de jacky
avait et la chance alors il est
extrêmement fort il le mérite tout ce
qu'on veut mais c'est un jeune joueur
autant qu'ils profitent au maximum de
pouvoir jouer s'aguerrir en vue de ba de
devenir le
le candidat à la couronne mondiale après
on peut comprendre parce que fin on peut
comprendre sa frustration
en tant que compétiteur d'avoir été
dérangés derrière de déconner une
position très avantageuse
d'avoir des excuses en échange ce qui
donne encore plus de légitimité au fait
qu'il ait dit que c'était pas normal
c'est vrai que ce qui a été fait comme
tu le relate oui c'est absolument pas
normal mais bon après c'est dommage
l'année suivante de se retrouver dans
cette situation là quoi voilà c'est ok
je comprends mais après bon sens
c'est une fois juste c'est un gros
tournoi il ya eu un incident ok il ya eu
des excuses ok tourner la page il
faut faire la part des choses quoi ils
étaient légitimes et au début
et après un an plus tard demander des
compensations par rapport aux soucis en
fait soit il demande tout de suite soit
c'est trop tard quoi après c'est
entériné ouaip et même
la fille rousse za je pense quand même
pas qu'il soit aura plein de
l'ancienne-douane
minutes en vélo bon maintenant ça
devrait aller je pense que williams ou
puis c'est que le début la wii en plus
maintenant non on n'est pas inquiet pour
pour la santé financière de son projet
chaque ça c'est sûr non mais en fait ça
on sait ouais c'est il ya de lego là
dedans ils estiment avoir été lésés et
il estime qu'il ya pas eu réparation que
des excuses ne suffisent pas c'est un
peu ça bon ça prend des professeurs d'un
hyper importante dans la presse c'est
dommage parce que c'est quand même un
des plus gros tournois bah ouais c'est
ça c'est un beau tournoi à gagner c'est
un tournoi je pense auquel il rêvait de
participer à un moment
oui donc un peu dommage cette histoire
quoi un peu dommage
vous êtes parti qui devrait gagner assez
rapidement je pense qu'ils tour h4
a l'air très fort là ce courage cette
croix qui va avancer
malheur quand même très compromis pour
pour pour chaque clan war gun bill qui
prend son temps pour finir la partie pas
perdre pour pas gaffer 1
mais
[Musique]
complètement mais ouais bon on peut l'en
pour tabler sur une belle victoire
ouais de
conte plein de vie dite complètement ici
bon je pense à moins d'intérêt peut-être
ses fans
ouais je garde juste un petit truc là
parce que je voulais voir ce qu'on avait
les appariements de demain déjà les
armes les chercher pour qu'on puisse
voir un peu ce qui se passe s'il ya des
chinois il ya des chocs 92 forme et si
on
[Musique]
voit des joueurs qui en tout cas bon
ratio est aujourd'hui de deux parties
décisives dont il y aura eu trois
parties décisives si visite confirme son
gain il y aura eu quatre nuls mais sur
ces quatre nuls il y aura eu du beau
médias rohff qui aura été archi chaud et
caruana cariat qui nous caruana était
vraiment faut dire gros avantage va
presque gagnant giry prague nalanda
c'était animé pendant toute la partie en
fait si on fait le bilan moi qui me
disait que carlo scène c'était super à
suivre je peux à du monde rapide
aujourd'hui la partie était assez
décevante parce qu'il avait les noirs
avec le joueur en face c'est 6 et épicé
et si penco a
décidé de débloquer un peu magnus et
manu ci s'est laissé faire là dedans
c'est à dire que les délits se sentait
pas le besoin de tout tenter pour gagner
on est au début du tournoi et les noirs
et du coup ça arrange et un petit peu
les deux joueurs de faire ça nul de san
pietro de combat sinon c'était c'était
une belle journée pour les et chacun
clairement à charade et ses devoirs de
trouver sur le site officiel la cie les
appariements pour demain
il fera encore
je sais pas a pareillement qu'ils sont
[Musique]
voilà ça perd un petit peu de de son
intérêt parce que la ville était très
lent à jouer puisqu'ils en fait vous
voyez un majeur ce niveau là et c'est
archi gagnant qu'est-ce qu'il fait
réfléchie veux vraiment pas il en a déjà
gâché des avantages un des gros
avantages même à son niveau et du coup
par expérience il vérifie tout il va
assurer son gain et y est ça peut pas
être mauvais de toute façon de prendre
son temps dans cette position et de
laisser shankland dans son jus et de
voir toutes les possibilités blanche
mais là à titre personnel il ya
plusieurs coups possibles mais f4 f5 ça
me donne vraiment envie voilà mais il
cherche peut-être à fignoler encore plus
dense est dans cette position
le tour h4 de proposer par rapport aux
stéphanois est fort aussi je moi j'ai
envie de valoriser mes pions on peut
aussi jouer peut-être cavaliers ou trois
pour pousser le pion des bref il ya
énormément de solutions dans la cave a
lieu trois et du coup ça c'est
intéressant à titre perso f4 f5
tranquille je fais le job
c'est officiel il ya pas apparemment
serey die invite au lycée les dom
il donne
kfw standing ce
résultat
est pas les appariements
ouais bah là
on reste un peu sur notre faim on sait
que visite allait jouer il a joué une
séquence un peu plus vite et la séquence
où ça semble facile il prend son temps
alors c'est qu'il a vu des petites
difficultés par des gros ça c'est sûr
toi tu voulais faire des petits prono
pour demain je trouve que je te connais
tu vois je veux voir un peu ce qui se
passe quoi
ouais
j'avais hâte de savoir qui joue et
prague nalanda par avance
par exemple si jordan va va pouvoir
mystifié quoique jardin il y avait lavé
les blancs et un moment je faisais pas
le malin quand j'ai vu les deux fous
sera menée honnêtement je pense n'est
pas passé loin de
de gâcher son avance d'actionnaire
ouais
je pense pas qu'ils tirent au sort tous
les jours
oui souvent faut attendre les appareils
mans c'est un peu comme dans les open du
coup vous attendez votre appareil mans
ce soir là c'est ce qu'on veut ce qu on
vous refait immersion totale immersion
totale
inside perring
bon et puis la
belge sep avidité on s'endort un petit
peu un c'est l'heure de la sieste
web attention je pense qu'on va pas
tarder non plus avec camilla
bah ouais il faut parfois pas qu on
déconne vous nous faites confiance 1
dans le tchat on n'a pas passé une jolie
après-mdi ça a été plutôt rapide avec la
cadence on voit que finalement il y
aurait moyen dans des partis un peu plus
disputé de oued que ça joue jusqu'à les
20h30 maximum
en règle générale à moins un peu comme
auch pas du monde que sa dure énormément
avec une finale très technique avec
matériels limités vous rappelez un la
partie la plus longue du championnat du
monde entre magnus et nepomniachi à une
un impact énorme sur la suite du
championnat d'ailleurs
et là ça peut se terminer vraiment tard
mais sinon tous les soirs on devrait
terminer vers vers 20h 20h30 et
finalement se retrouver chaque jour à 14
heures avec une petite blague le dernier
jour donc le 30 janvier dans quinze
jours on n'y est pas ça sera à midi que
ça démarre à et ça faudra pas oublier
l'horaire et sinon tous les jours on se
retrouve à 14 heures appelé
et
et du coup il y aura quelques journées
de repos aussi bas on va on va vous
laisser c'était une bien y amener en
votre compagnie merci à toi stéphane
c'était cool sur merci à toi d'abord
même bravo à tout altérée bravo à toi
stéphane parce que on vous rappelle à
ses fans et il fait très chaud chez lui
il a réussi à stopper le coc vite dans
cette mauvaise période là et il est
quand même là debout pour me faire une
master class sur obs pour ensuite
commenté les parties tout l'après midi
donc bravo à toi stéphane c'était encore
très sympa est a encore réussi à me
filer un seul donc je suis obligé de te
remercier aussi parce que tu arrive
toujours à l'époque
à un moment quand tu vas de refaire mais
je vais pleurer que sais je commence à
avoir l'habitude
de le gagner je disais un pote que
j'avais commenté le tata steel avec toi
et il me dit ah ouais c'est cool en plus
tu vas te refaire plein de seube tu vois
maintenant ta réputation elle est connue
tu vois ce toof ça on voit quoi donc
c'était c'était vraiment sympa merci à
tous ceux qui ont participé dans le
chatt merci à tous ceux qui ont
participé à tous et on vous retrouve
demain angel forme demain meurt donc ça
c'est à dire à partir de 14 heures on
essaiera même de prendre l'antenne un
peu avant aujourd'hui c'est à dire est
peut-être moins cinq avions fait on va
peut-être faire cet effort de folie
voilà en tant que ça demain
et on vous on vous dis à très bientôt et
j'arrête ce stream je vous dis à ciao
bye bye yes à bientôt ciao ciao ciao
kevin salut stuff allemand